finally we have reached the last day of
software development week offered by
simply learn
this week has been an amazing journey of
learning the software development
process we started right from the
building blocks the data structures and
algorithms then started off with c plus
plus then we landed on java and obtained
a comfortable understanding of core and
advanced java concepts later we learned
the python programming language and now
here we are at our last stop javascript
javascript is rigorously used for
multiple purposes
whether it is a mobile application or a
desktop application or a website all you
need is javascript
it is also recognized as one of the most
popular and highly used programming
languages in the current iit industry
this session is dedicated in helping
learners to get acquainted with the
javascript programming language
now without any further ado let's get
over to our experts
we'll begin by understanding what
exactly javascript is
and then we'll understand the learning
path to javascript
followed by which we'll see tutorials on
concepts like creating your first
javascript program using hello world
then we'll move on to more technical
topics like arrays loops objects this
keyword functions
form validation regular expressions and
email validation moving ahead we look at
asynchronous programming concepts like
promises and async await we'll also look
at a detailed tutorial on dom and
finally coming to the most awaited part
to develop five different projects using
javascript
and lastly we'll end the session by
looking at the top interview questions
in javascript so i hope you're excited
for it so without further delay let's
jump right in
first let's have a look at a brief
history of javascript
javascript was written in 10 days by
brendan ike in 1995. he was working at
netscape at the time and was
implementing java the hot buzzword for
the browser
later he developed a more easy to use
programming language called mocha the
idea was to make java available for big
professional component writers while
moca would be used for small scripting
tasks
moka was later renamed to javascript
now in 2009 node.js was released this
allowed programmers to write full
applications in javascript
npm was also created for installing
reusable bits of code in libraries
so moving on what exactly is javascript
javascript is a server-side and
client-side programming language it is
commonly used to create web applications
now all of these applications in
javascript can be seen in diverse fields
like gaming web development
server development robotics among others
popular javascript libraries and
frameworks like react js and angular
have skated tremendously in the past few
years
let's begin with javascript fundamentals
i'm sure these are topics that everybody
has already learned however getting a
fundamental strong lays the foundation
for better and faster learning
some of these include the lexical
structure of javascript
javascript variables types and
expressions
javascript functions which include the
function constructor self-invoking
functions functions as values and
objects arrow functions generator
functions and predefined functions
then there's javascript arrays it could
be adding methods mapreduce and filter
then there's javascript loops which
include the for loop for in loop while
loop and the do-while loop
and then we have objects which include
creating objects object properties
methods and accessors
moving on there is data structures like
boolean string number null undefined
there's control flow statements like if
else
there's data object
there's type conversions that is
converting from one data type to another
then there's mathematical operators and
lastly there's scope and javascript that
talk about the local and global
variables
now once you've laid your foundation
strong you can go ahead and work on more
advanced topics
now let's have a look at them
first one
being call backs now this is a pillar
for something called as asynchronous
programming
and then there's promises
and finally there's async await that are
built on chief asynchronous programming
there's closures that are an extension
of variable scope and define how global
and local variables are accessed the
help in delaying the execution of
certain code or functions
then there's prototyping
followed by inheritance now they specify
how javascript objects and methods from
a prototype
next up there's binding
there's also regular expressions where
you'll have to learn about
flags patterns quantifiers
meta characters and basic string search
and replacement techniques
lastly we have unicode event loops which
involve blocking an event creating a
simple event
and
moving on let's look at some of the
important web platform tools required to
master javascript
first up we have cookies that talk about
how to create read change and delete
cookies for any web browser
there's local storage that is you'll
have to know how data is being stored
locally in the browser
we have apis or application programming
interfaces that define how to extend
functionalities to a browser
one such important api is the fetch api
which is important to request resources
be it network is the document object
model that defines how anything that is
being changed on the browser is
affecting the model state and vice versa
and lastly we have service worker which
is basically a script that runs in the
background of a web browser offline app
development
moving on let's have a look at the tools
script
now javascript offers a wide range of
these libraries and frameworks
however you could choose to learn
whichever that suits your interest and
requirements
firstly there's react which is an
excellent javascript front-end library
that helps create interactive web pages
now there's angular which is a
javascript frame
next up we have view which is also a
front-end javascript framework used to
create single page applications now
although these libraries and frameworks
have the same objectives their
underlying architecture and working
differ and as a result of this different
people prefer different frameworks and
libraries for app development you
kickstart is typescript
now typescript basically defines a set
of types to javascript and helps users
write javascript code that is easier to
understand
typically all the typescript code
compiles down to javascript code
next for a simple overview of what we've
learned
we have beginner level or fundamental
topics then we have the advanced level
topics there's web platform and finally
there's tools
but you must be wondering how can we
help you
now one thing you could do is take up a
simply learn certification course
to help you understand this better let
me just open javascript
and there are a few courses and masters
program that we provide
you have the node.js training course and
then there's the full stack weight and
object oriented
now the best part about javascript is
the fact that it's open source and is
cross-platform compatible meaning one
piece of code written in any system
regardless of the operating system
functions the same in other operating
systems as well
lastly most commonly used is a part of
web pages it allows client-side script
to interact with the user and make
dynamic pages
now moving on to the next important
question why javascript
now being the most popular language in
the world javascript has a huge fan base
and benefits from a large community
support
javascript is now being used in many
industrial fields such as web
development mobile application
development and also game development it
is very diverse in nature
there are great career opportunities for
javascript developers as this technology
seems to be holding on its own when
compared to other languages
all right now moving on let's go ahead
and execute a simple program
to understand javascript better
so we'll go ahead and execute a simple
hello world program
all right for that first thing you need
is a text editor in this case we've used
the vf code editor
so now let's go to our
text editor that is vs code and here
let's open a file
you say
file
and now you can
type in your code here so we will have
to add the javascript to the html code
and then print out the words hello world
on the browser window right that's our
objective so let's add the html
boilerplate in this file
so let's type in
html
this is our tag
and then next we have the body tag
so within the body tag
we can add the script tag to insert the
javascript into html page right so we
say script
language
equals javascript
and type
equals
text
slash
javascript
all right
let's close the tag
and then
in the script we call a javascript
function that is document.write which
writes the string to our html page
right so we say document
dot write
and within braces we say hello world
okay and now we close the tags
you also close the body
and finally
all right
now when we save the file
we're going to save it say on my desktop
and i'm going to call it index
dot html
right so make sure the extension is html
and then save it
already exists
i say replace it
and now once you save it as an html file
you can see that the colors have
appeared so any errors will be easily
indicated here
so now let me save this and now let's go
ahead and execute the file that is
stored
so let me go back
to my desktop
and here i have index.html
there you go when you click on the file
it opens in your browser
and you can see the words hello world
in this video we will be learning all
about javascript arrays and the popular
methods of the array object
so what exactly is an array
now an array object lets you store
multiple values in a single variable
it stores a fixed size sequential
collection of elements of the same type
now an array is used to store a
collection of data and it uses only
integers as element indices
however associative areas can also use
string indices
moving on let's understand what area
operations are
now we can perform various operations on
an array in javascript
but let's start by creating an area
so for that let's go ahead and create a
folder first which will consist of the
file that we're creating right so for
that
let me just uh go ahead and create a
folder
and i'll call it demo underscore adding
so once you're done with that open your
visual studio code editor
and here say open
folder and click on demo array
okay it's creating the workbench all
right and now here you can see
the new file icon so go ahead
and create
demo.html file
all right here you go now let's start
typing the code
the first thing we do is type in our
html tag
and here i have the head tag
[Music]
and let me say javascript
tutorial
all right and now let's create the body
tag
now within the body tag i create a
paragraph tag
and create an id
and let me call it
demo
and then close the tag now i'll explain
to you why we're doing this a little
later
so first let's go ahead and create the
script tag
so say script
[Music]
and within the script let's create our
array so let me use the keyword let
and say we give the name of the array
cars
equals in square base braces
we say bmw
and
volvo
[Music]
and then say
honda
all right so now we create an array now
one more thing is that we use the
keyword let so that which indicates that
the array can be changed throughout the
program
all right so now we go ahead and display
it so
i say document
[Music]
dot get element by id
and here i say now the id
created was demo so i say demo here
and i use the dot
inner html property
which is equal to cars
okay let me change this to bmw first
all right so what exactly in our html
does is that it is responsible for what
is being displayed on the web page
okay now since we've taken id as demo
any changes made is reflected in this id
and then displayed onto the web browser
all right so let's save this and now
execute the file
so here i go back to my folder and then
to the file and go ahead and click on it
so there you go
the heading is displayed and the entire
array is displayed here
all right so let's go back to our vs
code
okay so i hope this was easy to
understand
now let's go ahead
so the next operation is to access an
array element
so let us go back to our vs code
and here
let's create another variable say let
bmw bmw's variable don't get confused
with the array element
so bmw equals
cars
of the index 0.
so basically
curves of 0 is nothing but
bmw all right so that is being saved in
the variable bmw
and now let's just go ahead and display
this
so we let's just copy this
and place it here and instead of cars
you use the variable name bmw that is
this one
all right so now let's save this
and when we
execute it
you see bmw here
that's how you retrieve an element from
an array
next up we have the array length
property which displays the length of
the array
so again let me show you how to do that
let's go back to our code
and here
let's create a variable and let's call
it length variable so i say let l e n
equals
cars dot left
now you can use the length property
which will retrieve the length of the
array for us it's as simple as that and
now after this
again let's just
copy the same
code here and then
let's
pass len
okay
now let's save this
and when you execute it again
it says three
so we've successfully retrieved the
length of the array
all right so the next operation is to
access the last array element right so
let's go back to our vs code
and now let's create another variable
and let's call it last
and we'll just say last equals cars
and within square braces
cars dot length
minus 1
right so basically
the length of the array is three and
three minus one is two so it should
retrieve
cars of two which is honda right
so let's just
execute this let me pass last here
save it and see if it
displays honda for us
there you go
it's as simple as that
all right so moving on
the next array operation is loop over an
array item
so for that let's go to our
code
and here
let's use the for loop so i say cars
dot
for each
for each
and within this
we'll say
item
comma index
comma array
and now we use the arrow function
and display the content on the console
so i say console.log
of item
along with its index
so let's save this
and now let's go ahead and execute it
all right now as you can see nothing is
printed on your web page right because
whatever is being printed has to be
printed in your console so now click on
f12 which opens the developer options
and here you can see console so click on
that and now you can see the name of the
item in the array along with its index
so you see bmw 0 volvo 1 and honda
2. all right
so moving on
now that we've learned about the array
operations let's go ahead and learn
about the array methods
so the first method is tostring now as
the name suggests it is used to convert
an array into a string
all right so let's go back to our vs
code
and now
let's copy the same
code here
and here instead of last i just say
cars dot
to string
now you can use this method
to convert the array into a string so
let's save this
and let's execute it
all right
now here the same output is shown
which means that the type has only been
changed to string type
all right moving on
the next method is pop now pop basically
removes the last element from the array
so let me show you how that works
let's go back to our vs code and here
we have to save
the pop element into a variable right so
let's create a variable say last
okay and oh since last is already used
let me call it last one
last one of cars dot pop
now you can use the pop method to pop
the element
and now you can just
copy the same code
to display this onto our web page
and here
i just say
last one
now
since we've popped the last element the
array has only two elements right that
is bmw and volvo
so if you want to display the last
element it should display volvo right so
what we can do is we can just create
another variable say last two
and just
use the same logic here
okay
and now let's just
display it on your console and let's say
last two all right
so now let's save it
now the popped element has been saved in
last one which is displayed on the web
page
and the last element of the array after
the pop function has to be displayed on
our console
so let's go ahead and execute the file
all right so honda has been displayed
that is the element that has been
removed from the array
and now once we check our console
here you go here you can see volvo
which means that is the last element in
the area
moving on
the next method is the push method now
as the name suggests it is used to add a
new element to the array and remember to
the end of the array so let's go back to
our vs code
and here let me say cars
dot push
push is the method that we're using
inside of which we'll say
audi all right
and now let's just display the same
things so let me copy this
and here let me say cars
okay so let me save it
and once i execute it
it says bmw volvo and audi so we've
successfully added another element to
the end of the array
so the next method is the shift method
now basically shift is used to remove
the first element from the array
now this method shifts all the elements
reducing the indexes of every element by
one all right let me show you how this
works
so let's go back to our vs code
and here let me just say cars
dot shift
it's as simple as that
and let's just display this
let me copy the same thing
let's save it
and when we execute it
here you can see it just displays volvo
and audi so now cars has array elements
volvo and audi
with array indices 0 and 1.
all right so moving on the next method
is unshift
all right so to add an element into the
beginning of an array we use the unshift
method
therefore this method increases the
array index by one
right so let's go back to our vs code
and use the same function
unshift
so i say cars dot unshift
and here we go let's
save it and here we have to specify what
we're adding right let me say hyundai
okay
let's save this
and when we execute it
you can see hyundai volvo and audi
it's as simple as that
all right moving on the next method is
the concat method now this is basically
used to merge two different areas
right so let's go back to our vs code
ensure
let's create another array first
and let's just call the array
bikes
okay
and let's create say
yamaha
and
let's say suzuki
[Music]
and then we'll say royal enfield
okay
and now
let's save this
and say let
vehicles this is another array which is
basically the after concatenation
the entire array is saved into this
array all right so let's say cars.concat
[Music]
of bikes we just concat bikes and cars
together
okay and then let's just
display this over the web page
let me change this to vehicles
[Music]
all right
let me save this
so let's go ahead and execute it
there you go now both the areas have
been merged together into a single array
so the next array method is the sort
method
now basically sort is used to sort the
entire array into ascending order
all right so let's go back to our editor
and here
let's just use the
sort method on the
array vehicles all right
vehicles dot sort
okay
and
let's just
display this on our web page
so
again
let's go back and
execute it and here you can see it has
been sorted
the next method
is the reverse method so the reverse
method is again used to reverse the
elements in an array so it's logic right
so sort was used to sort it in ascending
order now when you reverse it it just
sorts it in this ascending order
so let's go back here
i'm going to copy the same thing
all right and here instead of sort let
me just say reverse
so let's save this
and execute it
there we go
it has displayed the entire array in the
reverse order
all right
with that we finish the area methods
next up we have map reduce and filter
first up we have array.map
now the map method is used for creating
a new array from an existing one by
applying a function to each and every
one of the elements in the first array
and it does not change the original
array all right so to make you
understand this better let's go back to
our
visual studio code
and now here let's first create another
area
okay so let me call this num1
and let's have
integers let's say 2 3 4 5
6 and 7
okay
and now let's have another array
num2
so let's go ahead and say num1
dot
map
of let me define a function say multiply
okay
so multiply the function that is that
i'm going to define here
so let's say function
multiply
of value
okay
and inside this let me say return
value
into 2
okay
so what this basically does
is that it multiplies each and every
element of the array num1 by 2 and saves
the new elements into the array num2
okay
now after this
let's go ahead and
display the content so let me copy this
and let's display the content
in the array num2
right so let me save it
let's go back here
execute it
so there we go
every element has been multiplied by 2
and then displayed again
i hope this was clear for you
now the next method is the filter method
so the filter method takes each element
in an array and applies a conditional
statement against it
and if this condition returns true the
element gets pushed onto the output
array but if it returns false the
element does not get pushed
all right so let me show it to you
now
let's
go ahead and create another
variable
say num3
and here i say num1
dot filter
of say com
now comp is a function
let me define the function here
let me say function
comp
of value
takes a value as a parameter
within which i am going to check
if the value is greater than 4.
now it only appends the element into the
array num3 if the value is greater than
4
all right
so now let me just
go ahead and change this to num3
all right
let's save this
and when we go back and execute
here we go
now the values so let's go back here let
me check
now num1 had the values 2 3 4 5 6 and 7
right so according to this it has to
only display 5 6 and 7. do not get
confused with num2 here
we've passed num1 here so it checks for
this array
right
so according to the logic it should
display five six and seven
and it has done so here
okay
moving on
the next method
is the reduce method
now the reduced method reduces an array
of values down to just one single value
now to get the output value it runs a
reducer function to each element of that
array
okay now this method does not reduce the
original array again
so let's go back to our vs code
now let me create
another
variables in num4
and say num1 dot reduce
and let me call it sum
so what we're basically doing is that
we're adding all the digits 2 3 4 5 6
and 7 in num1 to a single value right
that is the sum and then we're going to
be displaying that
so what we're going to do is let's
define the function here
function sum
basically is total comma value
right and then here let's say return
total
plus
the value
okay
and after this
i'm going to
display the content so let's say num 4
okay
let's
save it
go back and execute
here we go it displays the sum of the
entire values in the array
this was pretty simple right
now before jumping into the for loop
let's first understand what exactly a
loop is
right so a loop is basically a
programming construct that executes a
piece of code as long as a certain
condition is met
all right and there are two different
types of loops we have entry control
loops and exit control groups now what
exactly are entry control loops now
these are the loops where the test
condition is checked before executing
the piece of code for example you have
the for loop and the while loop so in
their case before entering the loop
the condition is checked and only if the
condition is met it enters the loop and
executes the code all right when it
comes to exit control loops the test
condition is checked after the loop has
been executed
all right so in this case the loop at
least gets executed i mean the code in
the loop gets executed at least once
so the example for this is a two while
loop
all right with this basic knowledge
let's go ahead and learn about the
different loops
so the first loop is the for loop
all right
so what exactly is a for loop this is
the basic logic and the flowchart in
front of you so what exactly happens is
that say for example you want to print
the word looping
say 10 times right so what you can do is
you can start and you can have a for
loop which goes from 0 to 9
and then you increase the number by 1
every time you print the loop
once it's equal to 10 or even greater
than 10 it ends the loop
right
so let me help you understand this
better with an example so let's go to
our editor that is vs code
here i've created a folder called demo
underscore loops within which i created
a file called for loops
all right so now let's just write down
our initial
code for html that is
html
and then i have a head tag
[Music]
within which i say
javascript
loops
[Music]
all right
now i have a body tag
[Music]
within which i give a heading for
clearer understanding let me have a
heading say
javascript
for loops
[Music]
all right
let me just call it for loop
now let's have the script tag
[Music]
within which
i'll have
a variable say x
and now we have the for loop so we say
for
x equals
0
x less than
5
x plus plus
within which i say console.log
of x
so basically
what happens is
now you have the first variable which is
called the counter variable now this
keeps track of how many times the code
is being executed
right and next
i less than 5 is the condition now
the loop keeps executing as long as the
condition is met
and lastly the counter variable is
incremented and usually it's incremented
by one
right so here we've done the same thing
and
inside the loop we print the value of x
all right so let me save the file
and then execute it
all right it's printed javascript loops
here let me just go back
okay my bad i missed out on the title
tag
so this has to be enclosed within the
title tag
so let me just
change it here
now let's save this
let's go back and just refresh the page
and that is it so whatever is in the
title tag basically appears here all
right so now since we're printing the
value of x on our console we have to
inspect our element so let's go here
and here let's check on console
and here you can see all the values have
been printed from 0 to 4.
all right now this is a simple for loop
so next up is a while loop
now the logic is similar to that of a
for loop
first the condition is checked and if
the condition holds true then the code
is executed and if it is false it
terminates
all right so moving on let's understand
the general syntax
so here first you have the variable
whose value keeps changing
and then you have the ending condition
which is basically the maximum value a
variable can reach all right so let's go
back to our vs code
and here for better understanding let me
just change this to
javascript while loop
all right let's just
delete this and here
let's initialize the value of x to 1.
and now i say while
x
less than or equal to 5
within braces i
say
console.log of x
and then i increment the value of x
all right so let me save this
and let's execute the file
right so it says javascript while loop
and let's inspect
and here in our console it displays the
values of x
all right so according to the logic
x is initially initialized to 1
and the value
gets executed once it enters the while
loop
all right it's incremented and then
checked every time
until the value reaches
6 right and then it breaks from the loop
since the value does not hold true and
then it terminates
so this is a logic behind the while loop
next up is the two while loop
now here
as you can see
first the code is executed and then the
condition is checked if the condition is
true then the code execution continues
and if it falls it's terminated
all right so this is an exit control
loop
also in an exit control loop
the code is executed at least once
so let's go back to our vs code
and here
let me just delete this
now let's initialize x to say
15 all right
and now i use the do keyword
within which i write the code
so first i am going to print the value
of x
console
dot log of x
and then i increase my value
and here i mentioned my test condition
which is while
x
less than say 10
all right so according to the logic
initially the value is x
and once it enters the loop
here
it should print the value of x which is
15
all right and then it increments the
value but once it comes out of the loop
it checks for the condition
here the condition says less than 10 but
since x is not less than 10 it prints
the value x that is 15 and then
terminates
all right so let's save this
and execute it
so let me execute this
and here
let's check
the console
so there we go it prints 15. so what it
does is that it prints the value 15
first and then checks the condition
now
let's go ahead and change the value of x
to say
5
all right
so now it enters a loop
and then it prints the value of x and
then increments it
and when it comes out of the loop and
checks the condition
as long as the value of x remains less
than 10 it prints it
okay
so let's save this
go back here
and let's refresh the page
and here you can see the values 5 to 9
are printed so this is how the do while
loop works
moving on to the next concept
breaking out of a loop
now as the name suggests break is the
keyword that is used to break out of a
loop
now here is a simple code for you
so according to the logic it prints the
values
between 1 to 10
and say at the value 5 you want to break
out of the loop you can simply use the
keyword break
so let's go back to our vs code
and here let me just
make it simple
and save
or
x equals 1
x less than or equal to 10
[Music]
let's increment it
and within the loop
let's
display the value x
on the console and then
we're going to check for the condition
if x equals 5
all right
so if x equals 5
we break out of the loop
so let's save the file and execute it
and there you go it's displayed the
values from 1 to 5.
so basically the code inside the for
loop is executed and once the value of x
reaches 5 it breaks from the loop
simple right
all right so let's move on
next up we have skipping a loop cycle
all right so here
what exactly we do is we make use of a
keyword continue to skip a particular
loop cycle
say in this case we have a for loop
which displays the values of i
ranging from 1 to 10
however we want to skip the cycle when
it reaches the value 3. so what we do is
we make use of the keyword continue here
so basically it displays 1 and 2 and
skips the third cycle and then directly
displays 4
all right so let me show you in our
vs code editor
here
let me just remove this and save
if
x equals
5
[Music]
i'm going to continue
all right
after which
i'm going to say console
dot log of x
so let me save this
and then execute it
so here
let me refresh the page
and there we go
as you can see it displays one two three
and four and the fifth cycle
is kicked
all right and the rest of the digits are
displayed so that is how you can skip a
loop
i highly suggest you also practice all
of this and then play around with loops
to get a better understanding
so taking a step forward we're going to
learn about javascript objects in this
video so without further ado let's begin
and look at what's in store for us
so what is a javascript object
javascript is an object-oriented
programming language so everything in
java is an object
a javascript object is like a real world
entity having state and behavior for
example a car
now we can take a car as an object it
will have its state like color and model
it will also have behaviors like
accelerate and break
javascript is template based and we can
create objects without having the need
to create a class
generally object is accompanied by a
class that defines an object's
blueprints but javascript doesn't
require any class to be defined for
objects
moving on to the next concept
to create a javascript object
now basically there are three different
ways of creating a javascript object all
right so we look at them one by one
the first one is to use a literal to
create and define a javascript object
so let's go to our vs code editor
now if you have any doubts regarding the
initial setup then i suggest you go
through the previous video that is
javascript arrays
to get you started with it so here i've
created a folder called
demo objects and now i'm going to create
a file
called
create
underscore objects
dot html
all right
so we'll begin by writing the initial
code
that is the head and the body so i say
html
[Music]
within this i
create the head tag
[Music]
and then i create a title tag
and let's say
javascript
objects
then after the head tag i'm going to
create a body tag
and
let's create a heading and say
creating javascript
objects
okay
and now we create
an id
all of this is explained in the previous
video i really suggest you go through
the video before hand so that you get a
clear picture
and then i say id equals
say demo
and then i'm gonna close it
now the first method that we're going to
use to create an object is by using
object literals
right so what we can do is say script
within which i declare a variable
say
where student
now within the object we're going to
create three different properties now
this is basically like a dictionary it
has a property a key and then a value
okay so i say name
property
and let's say
chris
and then another property say age and
say 21
and another property say
studies
and say maybe computer science
[Music]
okay
so this is the syntax used to
create an object using an object
literally
now after this what we're going to do is
we're going to display this right now we
want to display the message saying
chris of age 21 studies computer science
so what we can do is say document dot
get element by id
and the id that we're going to pass is
demo
we say
in
html
equals
student dot name
which is chris
after which we display the message
of the age
and then the age that is student dot age
studies
student
dot
studies
okay let's save this
and when we
execute the file it says chris of the
age 21 studies computer science
all right this is one of the ways in
which you can define an object
all right so moving on to the next way
of creating a javascript object it is to
use the new keyword now this is the most
traditional way of creating an object
right so let's go back to our vs code
let's create another script
within which we say
where
student
equals new
object
i'm sure everybody has learned the same
way the same syntax
so
this is one of the ways
after which we can say student top name
equals chris
again student dot age
equals 21
[Music]
and then
student dot
studies
equals computer science
[Music]
all right now after this we again
display the message so let me just copy
this
[Music]
all right
so let's save this
and run our code again
and there we go it displays the message
chris of the age 21 studies computer
science
all right this was the second method
used to create an object
all right so then moving on to the third
method
it is to use an object constructor to
create and define a javascript object
so let's go back to our code editor
and here
we define a function so we say function
say start
with three parameters
that is name
age
and say
studies
okay
and now
within the function we use the keyword
this
so we say this dot name
equals name
[Music]
all right
we say this dot h
equals h
we say this dot
studies
[Music]
equals studies
now what we do is that we can
create a variable and pass parameters to
the function so we say where
student
equals
stud
and within braces we say
chris
comma 21.
[Music]
computer science
[Music]
all right so we've done passing the
parameters
after this we're going to copy the same
print message
here
[Music]
all right so let's
save this and execute our
file so let's refresh the web page
and there we go it still displays the
message chris of the age 21 studies
computer science so this was the third
method that can be used to create
objects
moving on to the next topic
object properties
now a javascript object is basically a
collection of unordered properties right
values associated with the javascript
object are called its properties
and properties can usually be added
updated or deleted excluding read-only
properties so now let's have a look at
the demo to help you understand this
better
so let me go back to my
vs code so this is where we left off
and this was how we created objects
right so now let me create another file
and let me call it
objects underscore properties
dot html
and now what i'm going to do is i'm
going to copy the first piece of code
here
all right let me just copy this
into my
new file
and here as you can see student is the
object that we've created and name agent
studies are the three properties
now say we want to update the age all
right so what we can do is here we can
just say student
dot h
equals
let me change it to 24. all right
and then we save this
and when we execute the file that was
object underscore properties
you can see chris of the age 24 so 21 is
updated to 24.
so this is one of the ways you can do it
or there's another method
you can just assign the property to a
variable and then display the variable
instead so what we can do
is we can just assign
h to a property cx
and here instead of displaying student
dot age we can just say
x
all right so let's save this
and when we run it
it says 21 because we haven't updated
21 to 24 anywhere all right
so 21 remains the same
so another method we can use
is we can just say
x equals h
so we're directly assigning the property
to the variable
and here
when i'm displaying it i say student
of x
all right
so let me
save this
and when you look at the web page
it still displays the same thing these
are different ways of accessing the
properties you can update them delete
them unless they read only
all right so let's move on to the next
concept object methods
now basically a javascript method is an
action that can be performed on the
objects
so you'll understand better with the
help of the demo
so let's go back to our vs code and here
i've created another html file called
objects underscore methods all right so
let's let me just copy the initial
code
paste it here and let's have the
enclosing tags as well
and html all right now here i declare
another tag that is the button tag so
we're going to be making this a button
here so i say
button
id equals click me so that is the action
that i'm going to
be performing
and the message that is going to be
displayed on the button will be
click
all right
we're going to see the usage of it a
little later
now let's go ahead and create an object
so i say script
[Music]
within which i create
[Music]
the user object
so we created using a object little here
and i declare the property name
as chris again
and age
say 24 okay
so let's close this
all right so the next thing i'm going to
do is i'm going to create a new function
that we will use as an object method
all right so i say function
and let's give the name say hi
okay
within the function we declare
we basically display a message
so we're going to say alert
and hello
all right so this is going to be
displayed in a separate dialog box
now once the declaration is done
what we're going to do
is we're going to use
create another property basically say
user dot
let's say message
and assign
say hi to it
so basically what we're doing
is we're adding the previously created
method
to a new property that is user dot
message the message property all right
so now i say
document
dot get element by id
and say demo
[Music]
and the message that i want is just
hi
plus the username
all right
[Music]
so what we're going to do is we're going
to display the message hello
all right when the user clicks on the
button
so for that let's say
let's just copy this
[Music]
and here
instead of demo
right we're going to be passing the id
click me
as per this
and the event is going to be on click
event
so here i say on click
after which
i'm going to simply pass
user dot
message
let me just
delete this
[Music]
all right so here i notice that i've
given an equal to sign i'm sorry it's a
colon
all right so let's save the file
and
let's go ahead and execute it
alright so here you can see high chris
being displayed and once we click on the
button
you can see
an alert which says hello
all right
so now let's move on to the next concept
that is java object accessors
now getters and setters allow defining
an object accessor all right to get the
value of a property in a javascript
object we use a getter and to set the
value of a property of a javascript
object we use a setup so let's go back
to our demo
and now let me create another file
and let's call it
object
accessors
and now again let me just
copy the first initial part
[Music]
all right so now let's go ahead and
create a new
object so let me say script
within which i say where
and let's call it
car
all right
so let me define the properties say
model
and
the model is say bmw
320d and
another property is a color
and let's say it's navy blue
and the last property say fuel type
and let's see it's
diesel
[Music]
now what we can do is we can you make
use of the keyword get
to access the properties so i say get
and say fuel
within which i return
this dot
fuel
type
all right it's as simple as that
so now let's display it
document.getelementbyid
demo dot inner html equals we say car
dot
fuel
all right so now let's save it
and execute our file
here you go it retrieves diesel for us
now this is one of the ways of accessing
the properties
now to help you understand setter
let's go ahead and create another
object
all right say where car again
now let's say the model
is
audi a4
[Music]
color would be bright
red
[Music]
and fuel type
let's keep it blank
all right
now to set the value we use the set
keyword we say set fuel
the parameter is fuel
within which we say this
dot fuel type
[Music]
equals fuel
right
now let's set the value for the fuel
say car dot
fuel
equals
petrol
all right
now let's display the same
let me copy this
and what we want to display is the fuel
type right so here we say fuel type
so let's save this
and let's go ahead and
execute the file
and there we go it retrieves petrol
so what it does is basically it assigns
the value petrol to the property fuel
type and then we display the same on our
web page
so this is how you make use of getters
and setters
so you must have heard about this
keyword several times so in javascript
this keyword basically refers to an
object which is executing the current
piece of code well in simple terms this
keyword basically just references the
object that is executing the current
function
now if the function that is being
referenced is a regular function
then this keyword references the global
object
all right i'm sure it must be a little
tricky at the moment but please hold on
and if the function that is being
referenced is a method in an object then
this keyword references the object
itself
so to help you understand the concept
better and to clarify all your doubts
let's look at a simple demo
so here in vs code i've created a file
called this.html
all right you can give it a name of your
choice now here let me first
define a variable
and let's call the variable
say
value
and let's set it to say 50
all right
now let's go ahead and create a simple
function
so let me say function
[Music]
my function
all right and within this
let me define the value
for value
let me set the value for
the variable value as hundred
okay
and now let me just alert it all right
so let me say alert
value
[Music]
okay plus value
and then let me have another alert
message
which is going to display this dot value
so let me just say this value
[Music]
and
instead of just saying value i say this
dot value
all right
now after this let's go ahead and call
the function
my function
so let me just save this and execute it
so here it says value equals 100
and then when you see this dot value it
says 50.
so now here you can come back to the
code and see
now when i just say value it takes the
value 100 all right which is taken
locally but when i say this dot value
since it is a normal function it's
references to the global variable which
is here
this value
i hope this makes sense to you now
now moving on let's look at the behavior
of this keyword within an object method
so let me create an object here
but before that let me just
comment this out
let's say script
and now let's create an object so
let's say const
and then i give the name of my object as
random
and within this let me say name
and let's call it
john
and then i create a method called info
okay
and within this i display a console
message
that says
hi my name is
and now i make use of this keyword i say
this
dot name
all right
and now let me just go ahead and call
this method
so i say random
dot info
all right so let's save this and execute
it
so let me check my console
and there you go it says hi my name is
john
so if you clearly observe here
when we say this dot name since it is
being used within a method that is
defined inside an object
it references to this
property here
all right unlike this case where it
reference to the global variable that
was mentioned outside
so i hope this helped you understand the
difference between the two
now let's look at another simple example
so now let me just change the value of
name here
to say tutorial
and now let's define another property
which is basically an array so let me
just call the property video
within which i have an add a let's say
javascript
another value
say this
and then let's say keyword
and in my info method i'm going to just
display these video tags so
let me just
save this
okay let me just delete this first
and let's say this
dot video
now since it's an array we can make use
of for each
and now for each intern takes a callback
function
and then i say
i'm going to call it
a tag
the parameter that's being passed
within which i just console log it
and say
tag
all right so let me save it
and then execute this
now here you can see that the values in
the video property are displayed that is
javascript this and keyword
now let's suppose
that you want to display the name along
with every
string here
right so naturally you would go ahead
and just say
this dot
name
right it makes perfect sense
so let me just
save and execute this
now if you see just the values of the
property video are displayed here
now the main reason for this is
if you closely observe that this
function here is mentioned within the
callback function
right so when it is referencing it is
referencing to the global object
which is unclear which is undefined in
this case so to overcome this what we
can do is that
the for each method takes in two
properties one is the function the other
one is the object so here we just pass
this
all right so what happens is it's going
to reference the current object that is
random so let me save this
and then execute it
and there you go
you can see that tutorial that is the
name has been displayed
all right i hope you understood the
concept of this keyword it could be a
little tricky but as you work on it
you'll get the hang of it
in today's video we're going to learn
all about javascript functions in our
previous videos we've covered topics
like javascript arrays and loops
if you're new to this topic i suggest
you go through these topics before
all right so before jumping in let's go
ahead and look at what's in store for us
first we're going to learn what exactly
javascript functions are
then we'll look at javascript function
expressions then the function
constructor
self-invoking functions functions as
values functions as objects arrow
functions generator function and the
predefined functions
also don't forget to subscribe to our
channel and hit the bell icon to never
miss an update
moving on to our first topic what are
javascript functions
so basically a function is a group of
reusable code which can be called from
anywhere in your program right
when you have a piece of code that you
want to execute repeatedly in your
entire program it makes more sense to
define it once and call it over and over
right it makes the code more efficient
and readable
this also helps programmers write
modular codes
so this is the syntax you make use of
the function keyword followed by which
you mentioned the name of the function
the name of the function is completely
your choice
next you mention the parameter list and
within curly braces you can define the
function
now the function body is basically the
code that is executed every time the
function is called
so let's go to our vs code editor
and here i created a folder called demo
functions within which i've created an
html file called functions.html
all right and now i've just typed in the
initial code
now let's create a function
so let me say script
within which i use the keyword that is
function keyword
and now i give
the name for my function i say my
underscore
function
and the function takes
a parameter say value now this function
basically returns the square of the
digit all right
so within which
i say
document.getelementbyid
the id is demo
and now it just displays value into
value all right so the function
basically displays the square of the
number
now outside the function let me call the
function
does
my function
let me pass the value 5
all right now let's save this
and execute it
so let me go back to my file
and here we go it displays the value 25
so this was a simple function which took
a value
a digit as a parameter and then returned
the square
moving on to the next concept
function expression
now what we learnt previously was
function declaration but a function can
also be defined as an expression
now this is what the syntax looks like
now here the function is created and
assigned to the variable explicitly like
any other value
the meaning remains the same that is you
create the function and store the value
that it returns into a variable and in
our case it's x right so let's go to our
vs code and let me help you understand
this better
so now
i create another function
and here i say let
x equals let's use a simpler function so
i just mention
function
and within curly braces i display an
alert message
and i display a message saying hello
all right
now
after that to display the message what
we can do is let me just copy this
our output
code
and replace it here
and here what we're going to be
displaying is the value x right now
since it consists of a function you will
have to type the curly braces now this
is crucial for its execution all right
so let me save this
and then execute
let me execute this
and here you go it says the site says
hello so we've successfully executed the
piece of code
we can also assign this variable x to
another variable and then call that
variable instead right we can say let
y equals x
and instead of calling x here
we can simply call y
let me save it and then let me refresh
the page
and there we go it still displays a
message hello
all right so this is one of the ways of
defining a function that is as an
expression
moving on to our next concept function
constructor
now javascript functions are defined
using the keyword function right now
functions can also be defined using a
javascript built-in function
now this is the basic syntax so here
we've created a function called my
function and we've used the keyword new
after which we've used the constructor
function
and inside we provide the parameter list
after that the return value
next you can call the function here
right so let me just go back to my vs
code
and now
let me just make changes to the same
piece of code here
i create a function say
my underscore function
okay
all right let me just change the name
to my function all right
and then here i use the keyword new
and the function constructor that is
function
[Music]
within which i'm passing all the
parameters
so i have
a
b
and i'm going to return the sum of the
digits
all right
and now while calling the function
let me just store the value in a
variable say x
and let's call the function that is my
function
with the parameters
2 and 3.
all right
and now let me
display it
so i'm just
going to copy this
and i want to display the value of x
right
all right so let me save this
and execute it
if you refresh the page it displays the
sum that is 5.
to make it more readable let me just
display another message here
let me just say
the sum
is x all right
let me save it and then refresh the page
it says the sum is 5.
all right now this is how you make use
of the function constructor
next up we learn about self-invoking
functions
now as the name suggests these functions
are invoked automatically without being
called
now previously when we learnt about
function expressions we saw that
parentheses were crucial
so you have to add parentheses around
the function to indicate that it is a
function expression
so here is a syntax for you so what
we've done is we've made sure we've
enclosed the entire function within
parentheses
so let me help you with that let's go
back to our vs code
and let me create another script
and here
let me create the function within the
parentheses
and say function
it's not taking any parameters
instead it is going to
alert a message so let me say
hello
welcome
all right
after which
we're going to call the function so
again we have to mention the parentheses
let's save this
and execute
so when we
refresh the page
it says hello welcome
so we never called the function
rather it got invoked by itself so these
are self-invoking functions
now let's go ahead and look at functions
as
values now in javascript a function is
basically a value so we can deal with it
as a value now here is a simple syntax
now if you closely look at the syntax
you might think that this is same as
function expressions well no in this
case what we do is we first define the
function and then we assign it to a
particular variable but in the case of
expressions the function definition was
defined during the initialization of the
variable right and also we have to
specify the parenthesis in order to call
the function
so to help you understand this better
let me go back to our vs code
and here
let me just erase this
and let's define a function
that returns the product of two digits
so let me just call it product
which takes two parameters let me say a
and b
within which we return the value
a into b
all right now after this let's create
another variable say y
equals
function for i'm sorry the name of the
function is product
so product
of 2 and 5
all right so this basically returns us
10 right so let me just
copy this to display this on our webpage
and here i change the message to the
product
and here let me change it to y
so let's save this and execute it
so let me refresh the page and here you
go you can see the message the product
is 10.
now what we can do is we can make
alterations to this
now say i want to multiply the value
with 5 again
right so basically this returns 10 and
that value is multiplied by 5. so let me
save this
and
refresh our page and there we go it
returns
and there we go it displays 50. so this
is how you can make use of functions as
values
moving on to the next topic functions as
objects
now javascript functions are a special
type of objects called function objects
now a function includes a string which
holds the actual code that is the
function body of the function
the code is literally just a string
although not recommended you can also
create a function with the help of the
function constructor
i will show that you a little later on
but for now let's look at the syntax
now here we have a variable called body
which basically consists of the function
body it's enclosed in double quotes and
that's a mistake please ignore it all
right so next we have variable function
name here we create a function using the
keyword new and then we pass the
parameter list
and the body basically tells us what the
function returns
all right
next we have an alert message to call
the function
so let me just show how this is executed
back in our vs code let me create
another
function
and let's say the function returns the
area of a circle right so let me just
create
a body variable
which returns
so the area of a circle is pi r square
so we make use of math
dot i
into
radius
into radius
right
so it's basically pi r square
after which
let's see
where circle
[Music]
and here let's create a function using
the new keyword
function
and then here we pass
the value that is the radius
and then
the body
right so basically
this is the definition of our function
so let's use alert
to display the area so we say alert of
circle
or five
all right let me save this
and execute it
so when you refresh the page
it displays the area of the circle
so this is how you can use functions as
objects
moving on to our next concept arrow
functions
now functions can be written more
compactly and more precisely with the
help of arrow functions
all right now arrow function expressions
are ill-suited as methods and they
cannot be used as constructors
now also while using arrow functions
using const is a safer option because a
function expression is always a constant
value
so this is the syntax now you can only
omit the return keyword
within the curly braces if the function
is a single statement
so this is the syntax first you provide
the name of the function
with an equal to sign followed by the
argument list
and later you make use of this arrow
icon and define the expression
so this is basically
nothing
but this
so let's go back to our vs code and
check for ourselves
so let's create another function
and here let me say
const
my funk
equals
now say we want to display the product
of three digits so let me just pass a b
c of my parameters
and we make use of this icon which
indicates that this is an arrow function
within which i say return
a
into b into c
all right
now let me just
assign this to a variable okay let me
say
product
because we've used x here
and then let me call my function that is
my func
and pass the value 2 3 and say 4.
all right so let's display
the product so let me just copy this
code
and here let me see the product
of the three
digits is
and let me say product here because that
is what is being used here right
all right so let me save this and
execute it
all right first it displays the area of
the circle
all right and then we say okay and there
we go it displays the message the
product of the three digits is 24.
so let me do one thing let me just
comment this out
okay
let me save it and then execute it again
it just displays this
all right so this is how we can make use
of arrow functions
moving on let's look at the generator
function
now regular functions typically return
only one value right or a single value
or sometimes even nothing but a
generator function can return multiple
values
and the speciality is that it can do it
so on demand all right now to create a
generator function we make use of an
asterisk
so an asterisk indicates that the
function is a generator function
so here you can see that we have a
function followed by asterisks and we've
created a function called generator
sequence
so here you can see we have the asterisk
after the keyword function followed by
the name of the function right
but the main method of a generator
function is the next method when this
method is called it basically runs the
execution until the nearest yield value
all right all the nearest yield
statement
then the function execution pauses and
the yielded value is returned to the
outer code
all right so the result of the next
method is always an object with two
properties it has the value property
which is basically the yielded value
and then it has a done property which
displays true if the function code is
finished or false if it's otherwise
so let me show it execution for a
clearer understanding so let's go back
to our vs code
and here let's create the generator
function
let's say function
asterisk
generate
function all right
now within which
i make use of the keyword yield
and i say yield one first
followed by yield
two
and finally i make use of return which
indicates the termination so i say
return 3
all right
now let me make use of
a variable say generator
and assign it to the generator function
that is generate
func
and now i create another variable say 1
which will basically
return the value when i call the next
function
so here i say generator
dot
next
okay so whatever generator dot next
returns it's stored in one
so to display the message i say alert
and now i'm going to make use of a
method called json.stringify
[Music]
all right so basically this method
converts a javascript object or a value
to a json string
all right so within which i'm going to
say
1
that is this
all right
so now let me save this
and execute it
let me refresh the page and there you go
here it returns
two properties that is value and done it
says value is one and done is false
right it is false because we haven't
reached the return statement yet
so what we can do is to display the rest
let me just copy these
and display it one by one
so there let's see this
and here let me say 2
and this is 3
let me copy this
[Music]
okay here i say
2
and then i say 3.
all right so let me save this and then
execute it
so when i refresh the page
it says one and false
after which again it says to and false
and finally when it displays three it
returns true for the done property that
means we've reached the end of the
function definition
so this is how you make use of a
generator function
now let's move on to our last topic that
is predefined functions
now javascript has many built-in
functions all right now here are a few
of them we have eval parse end pass
float escape and unescape now let's go
through one by one
all right first up is eval now this
basically evaluates a string and returns
a value
all right so to help you understand this
better let me go back to our vs code
and now let me just create another file
and let me call it
predefined
functions.html all right
and i've just copied the initial code
all right so for eval
the syntax is eval
within which
i say
expression
all right now this is the general syntax
so what this eval does is that it
evaluates the expression
and if the result is not a string the
result is just returned and if the
result is a string it is taken to be a
javascript program and evaluated
so let me show you how it's done
so first let's create three variables
all right let's call them
x
and initialize it to five
then y
with six
and then let z
be seven all right
now let's just displace the result on
the console so let's say console.log
eval
of let me say
x plus y
all right
after which i again say console.log
of eval
of z
here since the expression is a string
this gets evaluated
and here since it's not a string it just
returns the value z
and here since it is not a string it
just returns the value of z
so let me save this
and then execute it
all right so let me just
check
our console
there you go it evaluated the expression
and added the two values that is x and y
and returned 11
while z is returned as it is
all right this is what eval does
next up is parseint now as the name
suggests it passes a string argument and
returns an integer of the specified
radix or base
and the syntax basically includes the
keyword parse
and the string within paranthesis
pars float on the other hand passes a
string argument and returns a floating
point number
again the syntax has the keyword parse
float along with the string within
parenthesis
next up is escape now this returns a
hexadecimal encoding of an argument
and on the other hand unescape returns
the ascii string for the specified value
so what exactly is form validation
now i'm sure you must have filled
several online forms right a simple
example would be a new registration for
a website
now every time you miss out on giving a
particular detail or end up giving
faulty information the website alerts
you
so this process of ensuring that the
information provided is legit is called
form validation
now this generally happens on the server
side however javascript facilitates form
validation on the client computer before
sending it over to the server
now there are two functions performed
one is the basic validation which
ensures that all the mandatory fields
are filled now this is implemented with
the help of a simple loop
and the other is a data format
validation now this checks the data for
its correctness
so to help you understand form
validation better let's look at a simple
demo
all right so back in my visual studio
code i've created a file called forms
all right it's an html file and i've
typed down the initial code
now the simple use case that i'm going
to show will include the validation of
the email and the password fields in a
form
all right so for that let's go ahead and
first create a simple form
so here html allows the form tag so i'll
say form
within which i'm going to provide
our fields so i say input
and then the name i'm going to be
providing is email
all right and then i'll provide a
placeholder and call it
email
and then the type of the input is going
to be
text all right and then let me just give
a free tag here
so now let me just copy the same thing
for my password as well
so here we go i say
password here
and then the placeholder again will be
password
[Music]
and then i'm going to keep the type as
text
and finally i'm going to have a button a
submit button right so let me say button
type
is basically submit
all right
and let me just play submit on my button
all right
okay
so with the help of this we've created a
simple
form so let me show you how this looks
so here we go we have successfully
created an email field a password field
and a submit button and every time i
click on the submit button you can see
that my page is getting refreshed
now once the user provides the correct
email id and password we want to display
a message all right so for that i've
created another file called message.html
and this is a simple file where i'm
displaying the message hello there
welcome
all right
so this is a simple message that i want
to display
so for that i have to
add it in my form tag
now once the form gets submitted
an action has to be performed and the
action is to navigate to the
message.html file right so let me just
say action
[Music]
equals
message.html
now you can also provide a name to your
form so let me call it
my form
[Music]
all right
so let me just save this
all right so moving on we have to now
validate the information that is
provided for that i'm going to create a
function here
so let me call the function
validate
all right
so here i'm going to check for my fields
right
now if the email field is empty then i'm
going to alert the user saying please
enter the email
and if the password field is empty i'm
going to again alert the user to provide
the password
so for that we're going to make use of
this simple if else logic
so let me say if
document
dot my form
dot email
[Music]
dot value
is null
so i'm going to check if the value
provided on my email field in my form
is null all right
what i'm going to do is i'm going to say
alert
please
provide
your
email id
okay
and then
i'm going to say
document.myform dot email dot focus
now what exactly focus does
is that it makes sure that the cursor
remains at the email field that is it is
focused at the same field
all right
so let me just copy the same thing for
my password field
so let me say else if
let me just copy this
instead of email
i say password
[Music]
within which i'm going to alert the user
to provide the password
[Music]
i'll say please provide
your password
all right
so basically it first checks for the
email field and then for the password
field so let me just say finally else
do nothing
all right
okay so now what we're going to do is
every time we click on the submit button
the form gets submitted correct now we
can control when the form is getting
submitted
so basically the form gets submitted
when this function is executed
so for that we can use another property
here
called on submit
and here i'm going to call my function
that is validate so let me say validate
here
all right so let me save this and let's
check the output
so here as you can see
let me just try submitting it without
providing the email field
all right so here we go it alerts us all
right and once i click on ok
it still displays the message hello
there welcome
now that is not what we want right
so once the email field is empty it
should remain in the same page and the
form shouldn't get submitted but here in
our case it is getting submitted so for
that we're going to have to make use of
return values
so what happens is if my email field is
empty then i'm going to return a false
so here i say return false
and here as well
and finally when both my email and my
password fields are filled i'm going to
return true
all right
and same goes here
let me just say return validate instead
of just validate
right
so
here we go
let me save this
and now let's check the output
so here let's first submit the form
without providing any information
all right so it says please provide your
email id when i click on ok observe that
the cursor remains at the email field
so here let me just give some random
value
and then let's try submitting it again
without providing the password
and then it says please provide your
password
all right
okay now if you observe that the cursor
is remains at the email field so let me
just check my code once
here we go i haven't mentioned password
here
so let me change email to password
so let me just provide some random value
at my email field
and say submit
and then i get a message saying please
provide your password
and now you can see that the cursor is
at the password field right so let me
just give random information there
and then i say submit
and here we go
the message hello there welcome is
displayed
so this was a simple demo on form
validation
so i really suggest you pause the video
here and then go through the code once
so what exactly are regular expressions
now a regular expression is basically a
sequence of characters now these
characters could be digits or the
letters of the alphabet and this
expression usually searches for a
particular pattern now the user can
basically define what has to be searched
in a text all right and these
expressions could be alphabet or digits
as i explained before
also one of the main reasons that we use
regular expressions is for text search
and text replacement operations
so this is a general syntax you have a
pattern that needs to be checked and you
have a flag associated with it so
further on in the video i'll explain to
you what flags and patterns are but
before that let me give you a small
example of what a regular expression is
so i have made use of this website
called
regexar.com i'll link it down in the
description box below so this is the
website
now here let me just show you a simple
regular expression now see we have a
text that says
apple
all right and now we have to search for
the letter a
so what i do here now this is going to
be my expression so i first provide a
pattern right so i just say capital a
so when i say capital a you can see that
the letter a has been matched
in my text all right so it's as simple
as that now one thing to remember is
that here it is case sensitive
all right so if i say
a regular small a it does not get
matched
all right so if i want to match ap i can
just say ap and it gets highlighted here
all right so this is a simple regular
expression that matches with the text
so moving on
let's see what exactly these flags
patterns and quantifiers are
so what exactly is a flag so we
previously saw that the syntax consists
of a pattern and then a flag right so
these flags basically specify to alter
the behavior of a regular expression
now these flags are generally appended
after the red x literal and can be
specified as a second argument in your
expression right so let's see the
different flags that are supported by
javascript
now you have these five flags here you
have g which is the global flag now this
finds all matches instead of stopping
after the first all right then you have
i which is ignore case which makes the
entire expression case insensitive and
then you have m which is multi-line
so the carrot and the dollar match the
beginning and the end of each line
respectively
then you have unicode and if this flag
is not supported you must match specific
unicode characters and then finally you
have y which finds all the consecutive
or adjacent matches
so moving on we have
patterns now these patterns are
basically brackets and are used to find
the range of characters
now again we have these patterns you
have a to z which finds all the
characters from a to z in lower cases
only
then we have 0 to 9 which finds all the
digits between 0 to 9 and finally we
have the letters of the alphabet and the
digits separated by a pipe all right so
this basically finds any character be it
an alphabet or a digit
i hope this was clear to you so moving
on we have quantifiers now these
quantifiers define the number of
occurrences of a particular string
now consider n to be a string so we have
three quantifiers here we have the plus
we have the asterisk and we have the
question mark so plus indicates one or
more occurrence of the character n
all right and the asterisk indicates
zero or more occurrences of the
character n
while a question mark indicates zero or
one occurrence of the character n so now
that you know flags patterns and
quantifiers let me help you understand
them better with the help of a demo
all right so here i have a simple text
which says welcome to this tutorial on
javascript this video teaches regular
expressions
now here
when i search for a particular word say
let me search for the word this okay
so i say this
now ideally even this has to be
highlighted
right however it does not that is
because as mentioned earlier it is
extremely case sensitive right so what
we can do is here we have flags
so here i say case insensitive so once i
click on that both these words get
highlighted
all right so this is how you make use of
the i flag
now moving on let me help you understand
patterns
now as mentioned you can have a range of
characters
now just in case here
[Music]
say i just make it case sensitive again
and here
i would like to select all the letters
of the alphabet
from a to z
all right so when i do that you can
observe all the letters are highlighted
except the ones that are in the upper
case
correct because that is not mentioned
here so here when i make it insensitive
you can see all of them get highlighted
so this is how you can make use of a
pattern
now to understand quantifiers
let me use a separate text all right
let's have a couple of a's and a few b's
now here when i say a
you can see all the characters a are
being highlighted right which is correct
but when i use the astrix
symbol here what happens is you can
observe
all the four a's are considered to be a
single unit what aztecs does is that you
can see here it says match is 0 or more
of the preceding token now the preceding
token is a
and matches 0 or more occurrences of the
character a
now same if i say b next to it
you can see all the characters b are
matched
right
however you can check
the characters a in this particular text
are not highlighted
i'm sure you can understand why because
the expression that i'm looking for is
any occurrences of a
followed by the character b
in this text here there are no
characters a and b together
correct so here you can see that a is
not highlighted
but once i give an asterisk again what
happens is that the character a gets
highlighted
what happens is that b can have zero or
more occurrences so here there is a zero
occurrence of b so a gets highlighted so
this is how
the asterisk quantifier works
now one of the most important concepts
of using regular expressions
are the special characters
so here you're gonna indicate the
special characters with the backslash
so we have backslash w for example
now what w does is that it matches any
word character
right so all the characters here get
matched
now it also has a counter character
which is the capital w all right so what
this does is that it does not match any
word so it matches everything that is
not a word including the periods
now let's see if you want to match
all the white spaces you can make use of
the character
s here
all right and when you have the
uppercase s
it matches any character that is not a
white space
now let's say you want to match
a digit you can just have backslash d
so let me just type in a few digits
and here you go all of them get matched
now let's say you want to have a range
of values that get matched right now
let's say i want to match just
three digits
so i can make use of curly braces and
within which i can mention three now
here you can see that it matches three
of the preceding token correct so the
preceding token is basically a digit so
it groups them in threes
so let me just add two other digits and
there we go
same goes with the matching of words so
here let me say w
so when i say 3
all the characters are grouped in threes
all right
now let's say i want to group the words
that are 3 or 4 in number so here i can
just say
comma
4. all right now it gets matched
all right so now it gets grouped in
force
so this is a simple example to show you
how special characters work in a regular
expression
moving on let's see how you can use
regular expressions to search for phone
numbers
now here in my phone number
i'm going to have an area code
so let's say
0 is 0 followed by a neat digit number
all right so let me give a random number
[Music]
all right so it's eight digits so some
people write a phone number like this
while others could write it something
like this you could have a hyphen in
between and then
any digit number all right now how are
you going to look for this text
so what we're going to do is we're going
to make use of the special character
that is for a digit you make use of
hyphen d
and first we're going to look for the
area code that is a three digit number
right so let me just say
three here
and next we're going to have an optional
hyphen so for that now since we learnt a
pattern can be enclosed within square
brackets so let me just
say hyphen here
and let me say a question mark now a
question mark indicates zero or one
occurrence of the preceding character
right so we're going to have a hyphen
for a question mark
and then finally we're going to have a
digit again
and here the number of digits is 8. so
let me just specify that
all right so when this happens you can
see both my numbers are getting
highlighted
although the text remains the same it
could be specified with different
formats right so just like this you can
create expressions that match various
formats so this was just a simple video
to acquaint you with regular expressions
in today's session we're going to be
learning all about javascript email
validation
so first of all validation is an
essential part when you're communicating
with the user
almost all the websites and applications
that you use have forms that you need to
fill in and every time you fill a form
that information you provide needs to be
validated
so this is an essential and a crucial
part now when you're providing more
critical information like user
credentials say your id your password
your date of birth all of that needs to
be validated so javascript enables this
with the help of a feature called email
validation
now email validation first of all
ensures user authenticity
it also facilitates email validation on
the client side so that all the
processing that takes place on the
server side is faster
and lastly with javascript one can
validate a name password email date etc
now i'm sure everybody has used email
ids right so here's a dummy email id for
you one thing that you must have noticed
is that all ids come with an ad symbol
now the first part before the act
character is the personal data
now here it could include your name you
can provide digits etc so the length of
this personal information can be up to
64 degrees and following the at
character you have the domain name the
domain name can be up to 253 characters
talking about the personal data
now this data can include any sort of
information you can provide your name
your birth date etc so basically it can
consist of all uppercase and lowercase
letters of the alphabet
it can have digits from zero to nine
you can include all special characters
and lastly it could include the period
character one thing to remember is that
the period character cannot occur twice
and is not supposed to be either the
first or the last character
all right so this was just a brief
introduction to email validation now to
give you a better understanding let's go
ahead and look at a simple demo
so back in our visual studio code i've
created a folder called javascript demo
and i've also created a file called
email validation
i've also typed in the initial code also
if you haven't watched our videos on
javascript regular expressions and
javascript form validation then i highly
recommend you go through them
email validation is basically just a
combination of the two so i suggest you
first head back and watch those videos
and come back here
all right so the first thing that we
need to do is create a form that
includes the email field right so for
that let's go ahead and create a form
here i'd say
form
within which i give input
let the id be
text
and i'll give the placeholder property
and let it be email
and the type
text
all right
and then i will
break the line
and finally i have a button that's
basically the submit button right so let
me just say button
type
say button
and then
the message displayed is submit
all right
so now when you're validating a form you
will have to
provide certain cases that is the if
else conditions
to validate it correct now first i'm
going to create a function wherein i'm
going to pass the information typed in
by the user as an argument
and this function consists of a regular
expression against which the id provided
by the user is checked and if the
pattern matches it then the id is valid
and if it does not then you'll have to
alert the user so now let's create our
function
let's say
script
and now let me
create a function
called validate
all right
and now i'm going to create a variable
called mail
[Music]
and i'm going to get
the information provided by using this
id
from the input now i'm going to get the
text using this id correct so let me
just say document dot
get element by id
within which
the name of the id is text
let me say text dot value all right
so the next thing is to create a regular
expression
now consider two different ids here now
the domain of the first id ends with dot
com
while the next one is ending with dot co
dot n so when we're defining the regular
expression we'll consider all possible
scenarios
so now let's head back to our vs code
and here let me just say
variable reg x
beginning with a forward slash
and then
you have
a carrot now the carrot symbol indicates
the beginning of the regular expression
now since we can have the lowercases
uppercases and all the digits
let's go ahead and mention them so
here
let me say a to
z
all lower cases then we have upper case
and we have all digits
[Music]
0 to 9
followed by which we can also include a
period and an underscore so when you're
including a period symbol you will have
to use the escape character that is
backslash
and then you mention the period now one
thing to remember is that a period
symbol in regular expression means that
it can include any of the characters but
here since we're using the literal
character that is the period we have to
include backslash after that we can have
an underscore as well
all right
followed by which we have a quantifier
that is plus
now plus here indicates one or more
occurrences of all these characters so
here we include plus
after which we have a literal that is
the act symbol
followed by which we have the domain
name so again the domain name can
include all the letters of the alphabet
and the digits
so for that let me say
a to z
a to z and 0 to 9.
again to remember we have to include the
plus symbol
indicating that it
let me just get rid of this
so we include the plus symbol to
indicate
one or more occurrences of of these
characters
again followed by which we have a period
symbol
so for that let's just go and type in
period now you must be wondering why i
didn't use the backslash
now a backslash or an escape sequence
here can only be used within the squared
braces outside of it it is considered as
a literal
so here i just mentioned the period
again i highly recommend you go through
the javascript regular expressions video
to clarify all your doubts
so moving on
after this i have to mention
the extension that is dot com or dot co
dot in
now generally these extensions are in
lower cases
so for that let's just
go ahead and mention a to z
again followed by a plus that is a
quantifier
with an optional
dot again
followed by
the letters a to z
again these can
again i mentioned plus
followed by which i'm going to add the
question mark
now the question mark indicates zero or
one occurrence of the preceding
expression so in this case
this
extension that is dot in
is optional now the question mark here
indicates either a zero occurrence or
one occurrence
all right
so
uh to end the expression you have
the dollar symbol and then the front
slash
oh i might have missed something
okay yeah i haven't closed this so let
me just add the parentheses all right
so this is your regular expression
against which we're going to be checking
the email id
right
so now
we're going to use the simple if else
logic
so for that let's say if
reg x
dot text
dot mail
mail is basically what has been
passed by the user
all right now if this is true
that is if the mail when checked against
the regular expression comes in to be
true
then i'm going to alert the user
saying
you have
[Music]
provided
a valid email id
and i'm going to return
true
else
if the expression does not match
then i'm going to alert the user with
the message saying sorry
incorrect
email id
and i'm going to return a false
so now you must be wondering where is
the return value going so for that i
have to add the on click event on my
button
so here let me say on
click
it's going to call the validate function
all right so there we go
let me save this
and execute it
in my browser when i type in xyz
gmail.com
and when i click on submit
it alerts me saying
you have provided a valid email id so to
check the other condition as well let's
type in dot co dot in and submit
and again it says that we've provided a
valid email id
now uh let's just add
a period and an underscore as well
so if i say x
y z
dot
a
underscore bc at gmail dot co dot n
and when i submit it it again says it's
a valid email id
for a false case let's go ahead and
remove the add symbol
and submit it it says
sorry incorrect email id
or you can also go ahead and remove the
period here
and submit it
it still says that the id is valid now
here what happens is that gmail co is
taken as one domain name with an
extension dot in so here this is valid
so this was a simple video to explain
email validation
i encourage you to play around with
regular expressions and also uh
consider all possible scenarios while
you're validating your id in a previous
few topics we learned about areas
functions and loops however this time
we're going to take a step forward and
then learn about promises
now you must be wondering why javascript
promises even came into picture and what
exactly these promises are
so don't worry i've got your back in
today's video we're going to learn about
promises why they were introduced and
also i'll explain their functionality
so let's go ahead
first up why javascript promises
now javascript is predominantly single
threaded meaning
all processes contain the execution of
instructions in a single sequence
so basically in simple terms one command
is processed at a time now if a function
relies on the result of another function
it basically has to wait for the other
function to finish and return and until
then the current function remains idle
now this can be extremely frustrating
because it's time consuming and very
restrictive i mean you're not using the
system to its full capability so to
overcome these drawbacks asynchronous
concepts or asynchronous programming
came into picture so in this case the
main thread continues its execution
while javascript allows long network
requests and other tasks to happen
simultaneously
now with the help of features like
callbacks promises and async await
asynchronous programming can be easily
achieved
i hope now you understood why promises
or asynchronous programming came into
picture
moving on what are javascript promises
now in the case of synchronous actions
you could instead of arranging for a
function to be called at some point in
the future return an object that
represents this future event
this is what the standard class promise
is for
now a promise is basically an
asynchronous action that may complete at
some point in the future
and when it's completed it produces a
value
now it is able to notify when its value
is available
the easiest way to create a promise is
by calling the promise.resolve method
now this function ensures that the value
you give it is wrapped within a promise
now a promise basically has three states
first up is the pending state now this
indicates that the underlying operation
has not yet been completed
next up is the fulfill state this
indicates that the promise has been
fulfilled with a particular value lastly
we have rejected now this indicates that
an error has occurred during the
operation and the promise is rejected
with the particular reason
moving on a promise is set to be settled
when it is either fulfilled or rejected
because remember promises are immutable
they cannot change their state so once
they're either fulfilled or rejected
they're said to be separate
so when a promise is fulfilled it has to
do a particular job so for that we make
use of the then method now the then
method basically runs for a result and
this is used to attach a callback when
the promise has been resolved
all right same with the case of the
scenario when the promise is rejected
it makes use of a catch method which is
used to attach a callback when the
promise has been rejected
don't worry you'll understand the
concepts better when we get to the demo
so moving on let's look at a quick
flowchart to understand promises better
first up you have a new promise now the
promise is in the pending state
now this promise runs for an
asynchronous action now we check if the
action is successful
if it is a yes then we call the then
method and if it is a no then the catch
method is called
and to end it if it is fulfilled then
the asynchronous action is performed and
if it is not that is if it is rejected
then error handling is performed
and lastly the values of these methods
is returned to the promise
i hope this was clear
so moving ahead let's look at the
general syntax
you can use the let keyword and provide
a name for your variable and then you
create a new promise now this promise
object takes a function which in turn
takes two parameters that is resolve and
reject
so to help you understand all of this
better let's go ahead and look at a
simple demo
so in vs code i've created a folder
called demo promises within which i've
created an html file named promises
so i have the initial code ready here
so let's begin typing our code
so let's say script
and here as i explained we say let and
let's give the name car to our variable
say car and we create a new promise
[Music]
all right so the promise
object returns a function
which takes two parameters
called resolve
and reject
all right
so within the function
let's define
a simple use case
now let's assume that we're checking the
car for its fuel all right so we'll
create variable called fuel
underscore full tank
now let's set the variable to say true
all right
now let's set the variable to true
now this indicates that the fuel tank is
full
so now if the fuel tank is full
what i can do is i say resolve
all right
else
i reject it
okay i hope you understood what i'm
doing here i'm just checking for the
fuel tank and if it is full which is
true then it gets resolved and if it is
false then it gets rejected
so if the promise gets resolved
the then method is called right so let
me call it here i say car
dot then
now this runs a result right so it's a
callback function
within which i say document
dot right
the fuel
tank
is full
[Music]
happy driving
[Music]
all right
and if it is
rejected
i say
dot catch
[Music]
which also returns a function
[Music]
that says document
dot right
let's just display a simple message
saying that the fuel tank is not empty
[Music]
all right so let me save this and
execute it
so here it displays the message the fuel
tank is full happy driving
now that happens because we have set the
value to true here
now in case we change it to false
let's see what it displays
all right it displays the message the
fuel tank is not empty
so this was a simple example showing how
a promise works
now let's go ahead and understand nested
promises
so for that
let me just
comment this out
[Music]
and now let's create a function that
returns promises so in our case what
we're going to do is first we'll check
for the fuel tank now in our case we're
taking a scenario where the fuel tank is
empty and the engine of the car is
overheating
so as a result the car is not safe for
traveling all right so let's go ahead
and create these functions
so i'll say let
empty underscore
tank
okay which
returns
a promise
so within which i say return
new promise
and the function takes two parameters
that is resolve
and reject
which in which i'm going to display a
message
saying
resolve
it says the car
doesn't
have enough
fuel
all right
now let me just copy the same piece of
code
to check
for the engine all right
so let me just change the name of our
variable here
let's call it engine
and here it displays the message
the engine is overheating
all right
and lastly
when both of these scenarios hold true
that is the car doesn't have enough fuel
and the engine is overheating
we say that the car is not fit for
travel
let me just call it
travel
and here
i'll display a message
saying the car
is not safe for traveling
[Music]
all right
so
right now we've created three functions
that returns promises
so first we check for the empty tank
right so let me just call the function
here
empty tank
and we make use of the then method
which is executed when the promise gets
resolved
which takes
[Music]
a callback function
all right so basically when we check for
the empty tank
after this is executed we check for the
engine right so here we simply call the
engine function so let me just say
return
engine
all right
now this is a nested promise in itself
so on top of it i can run the then
method again
[Music]
so if
the tank is empty and if the engine is
overheating
then i'll just check if it is safe for
traveling or not
so let me say
function
[Music]
and here let me just return
the method travel
all right
now after this
if all of these are executed
then i say
function
finally i'll display a message
saying
saying done
all right
so let's save this file and execute it
so here i go and click on promises
[Music]
let's go and check our console
and there we go
the message done is displayed
so here since every time the promise is
being resolved a message is displayed i
can basically catch the message in a
result
okay
and this result can be passed to the
coming methods so here i just say result
i see result again
[Music]
all right
[Music]
so now we get the message the car
doesn't have enough fuel so we have to
append it with the next message so let
me just say message here
i've used msg
and let's just append it here
[Music]
and the final message gets appended here
[Music]
with the result
okay i have to add message here as well
all right so let's save it and execute
the file
all right so here you can see the
message done gets displayed first
and then since we're appending it after
the message done it says the car doesn't
have enough fuel the engine is
overheating the car is not safe for
traveling
so this was how you can make use of
nested promises in today's video we're
going to learn all about javascript
asynchronous concepts that is async and
away
firstly let's understand the basic
concepts of synchronous and asynchronous
programming in case of synchronous
programming all the actions are
performed sequentially so you have the
execution of the function 1 after which
you have function 2 and then you have
function 3 and after all of these are
executed the program terminates now
although synchronous programming is
clean and has lesser errors it has its
own drawbacks the entire system is
halted when a particular process is
being executed now as a result of which
it is time consuming and the system is
not used to its full capacity
so to overcome that asynchronous
programming was introduced now in this
case let's assume that a particular
function of the process is being
executed now let's consider that this
particular function is waiting for a
resource let's say a network resource
now instead of waiting for the function
to acquire this resource the main thread
continues its execution with function 2
and function 3 and when the resource is
acquired it receives a callback
indicating that the function 1 has to be
called and finally the entire chain is
terminated so this is how asynchronous
programming works it makes sure that the
system does not halt when a particular
process is waiting for a resource this
makes the entire system very efficient
now that you know the concepts of
synchronous and asynchronous programming
let's move ahead now async and await a
purely asynchronous programming concepts
i again suggest you check out the video
on promises before watching this
alright so moving on
what are javascript async functions that
is async and await now async and await
are built on promises the function is
basically accompanied by the keyword
async
indicating that it returns a promise
within this function the away keyword is
applied to the promise that is being
returned and the await keyword ensures
that the function waits for the promise
to resolve now on the surface the
execution looks synchronous while it's
actually asynchronous now at the place
of usage of the await keyword the
execution of the function is practically
blocked now async functions make the
code more readable and are easy to
handle when compared to promises now to
give you the general syntax you have the
async keyword associated with the
function name
within which we have the await keyword
with a particular promise now to help
you understand the entire concept better
let's look at a demo
now i've created a file called async
await in my visual studio code
so what we're going to be doing is that
we're going to have two functions that
help you check for the result now you
pass this code as a parameter to these
functions which in turn return promises
telling if you have passed and will also
give you the grade that you scored all
right so let's go ahead and say let
let me call the variable result
and let's have a function
which takes the score as a parameter all
right
within which it returns a promise so i
save return
new promise now as you know a promise
basically
has a function
which takes two parameters that is
resolve
and reject
[Music]
now i just display a message saying
calculating
[Music]
results
all right now if
my score is say above 50
i resolve it
by displaying a message saying
congratulations
[Music]
you have passed
all right
and
if it is less than 50
[Music]
i reject it with the message
saying you have faith
all right so this is a very simple
promise that i created
so moving on let's create another
function that returns a promise
so basically this function will tell you
the grade that you've scored so say let
grade equals
function
now this takes response as a parameter
so let me just say response
[Music]
now again let me just copy this
all right
within which
i'm going to console.log a message
saying
calculating your grade
[Music]
and we're just going to resolve the
promise with the message
your grade is
a all right
and then we append the response
[Music]
now the first promise either results
saying that you've passed or it rejects
saying you failed and in case it gets
resolved then the next promise is
automatically resolved with the grade a
all right
so moving on
let's call the functions so here let me
first call the function result so i say
result
and let me pass the value 80 since it
gets resolved and now i make use of the
dot then method
now here i catch the response
[Music]
all right and then i just display a
message
indicating
results received
[Music]
okay
now what i'm going to do is i'm going to
pass the response to my next function
that is the grade function so what i say
is i say return
grade and the parameter is response let
me just pass that
now what exactly happens is that the
grade function also returns a promise so
on top of that i can use the dot then
method
so i use the then method
and let me just say final grade
[Music]
now within which i just display the
message
[Music]
final grade
all right now lastly we make use of the
catch method
in case of errors this catches the
errors
so let me just say error
and then
console.log it
all right
so this is the code
let me save this
and let's execute it to see its normal
execution so this is without using async
and await all right
so let's go ahead and execute this
so here let me check the console
and there we go it says calculating
results results received calculating
your grade your grade is a and
congratulations you have passed
so this was basically without using
async innovate so now let me show you
how you can use async and await and how
easier the code becomes all right so
what we can do is let me just comment
this out
all right now what i'm going to do is
i'm going to call my function right so
i'm just going to make use of the async
keyword while calling it so i say async
function and let me call the function
calculate
results
okay
so now inside this method i'm going to
call the functions result and grade so
when i first call result the value that
is returned by result is going to be
stored in the variable response so for
that let me just say const
response
now i make use of the await keyword here
i say await
result
of 20 or
in our case let me just say 80
all right
so what the away keyword does is that
the function result ceases to execute
until the promise is resolved and
whatever the promise returns gets stored
in the variable response
all right so now after this let me just
display a message
that says
results
received
all right
now next i'm going to call the other
function that is great so again i'm
going to say constant and i'm going to
have to create another variable let me
call it final grade and it's the same
procedure i use the await keyword
and call the function grade
and i pass response as the argument
all right
and after this i'm going to say
console.log
for final grade
so it's as simple as that so first we
call the result function which returns a
promise which gets stored in the
variable response
all right then we're going to call the
grade function and pass the response as
an argument
and the result of which is being stored
in final grade all right and lastly we
display final grade so now you must be
wondering if this executes what about
errors what if the value that i pass is
less than 50 right for that i'm going to
have to catch an error
so what i can do is that i can place
this entire code within the try block
all right so let me just say try
and now what i can do is i can catch
now if there is an error it gets caught
and then i display it
let me say console.log
error
all right
and lastly let's call the function
calculate results
okay so let me save this and execute it
so all right here we go
it displays the same messages in the
same sequence that we saw before
so now to give you an example of
rejection so here let me just pass 20.
all right
let's save it
and there we go it says calculating
results you have failed so you can make
use of async and await instead of
complicating the entire piece of code by
using promises
well in this session we will be seeing
what exactly is dom
which is document object model
and how can we
manipulate the term how do we interact
with the dom elements and nodes
and then we will wrap up the session
with a very interesting and engaging
demo
which is about movies
so we'll be creating a movie webpage
where you can see the list of movies you
can search for these movies and we also
can add a new movie
and delete them so these dom
manipulations will be seeing for a movie
web page
so what is term
document object model
it is the data representation of the
objects that comprise the structure and
content of a document on the web
so this dom is a programming interface
for html and xml documents
and it represents the page so that the
programs can change the document
structure style and content
dom represents the document as nodes and
objects
this way programming languages can
connect to the page
a web page is a document
the document can either be displayed in
the browser window or as an html source
but it is the same document in both the
cases
the document object model or dom
represents the same document so it can
be manipulated
dom is an object-oriented representation
of the web page which can be modified by
the scripting language very powerful
language like javascript
dom is usually represented
in a hierarchical tree like structure
so you can see
this picture on to my right where you
can see a html element which will be the
root for the parent element
and it has two child elements that you
can see one is the head and then we have
the body
head consists of the metadata like title
it also consists of script and style
tags
and body comprises mostly of the content
of the webpage so in this example you
can see a h1 which is a heading tag you
also have another element which is the
list element that you can see which is
an unordered list which consists of two
list items now these two list items are
the child elements of this particular
unordered list
and these two comprises of the child
element of body which in turn is the
child of the root html parent element so
we have a parent and child relationship
that you can see over here
and when we speak about events later in
the module so you can see like how the
parent can handle the child event or the
child can be able to
manipulate the events of the
parent element via javascript
so we can use javascript to perform
different tasks of dom manipulation like
traversing the dom
you can read the
text or
the history text or in the text or
whatever property value which is present
in the form of
the element inside the element or a node
so you can do a read operation basically
or you also can
edit or update something
and we also can add new element we can
delete the existing ones we can change
the style so we can do all these
manipulation of this document object
model using just javascript
so
all of the properties and methods and
whatever events that we have um
available for manipulating and creating
pages and these are organized into
something like objects
so the document object that represents
the document itself the table object
that implements the special html table
element dom interface for accessing html
tables and so forth
so the entire dom if you see it's like
object reference object by object
reference
so what is the power of javascript in
manipulating this
dom
so we'll see the perspective of
javascript now so using javascript as i
told earlier
so you can add elements or nodes or you
also can remove the html elements or
nodes that we see in the structure
but this is just not html elements or
the content
even you can manipulate the style
so you know cascading style sheet or
this css
which represents the theme of a page so
for a webpage the theme or style is very
very important
so the html represents the content and
css represents the style or theme
and the javascript is the core
functionality or the feature of that
page so these three things are like you
know like a trinity of a web page or
website
these three things complement each other
and go hand in hand
so just with your javascript so your
content is definitely important uh
content is king uh for any um particular
website or system so content is
mandatory it has to be there
so without content it's nothing
uh but style is also very important so
if you have to attract your first time
customers
so you can attract them only with a very
nicely styled theme or design
so this ui and ux design is plays a very
important role to attract your customers
so after attracting your customers so
these are just not enough it is also
important to provide good features so
your customer is now trying to shop from
your website so
he is so attracted by your
design minimalistic beautiful design so
he starts shopping
and after that at some point or the
other he is unable to put items in the
cart or he is not able to contact you
via some contact form so these are
provided for your javascript or some
javascript packages like jquery or
angular or react so this is very very
important so the functionality and
feature if you don't provide it of
course the custom you're going to lose
your customer
so
your javascript is so important and
powerful here that um so i was saying
that
using your javascript you can add a
whole lot of html content
you can from scratch you can add styles
also or change the existing style
not just the font and color um you also
can completely change the spacing
padding alignment everything so the
entire theme style and content you can
change via javascript alone and coming
back to your
events
now this is very important part of
javascript
this is the place
where the user interacts with that web
page or website say for example in the
form of a
form so you have a registration form or
a contact form
so using these forms so where we have
these input elements like a button
we also have lot of text boxes and check
boxes so all using all these input
elements
so we can get the input and we can
interact with the user
so the user can click a button
and he can select something he can blur
or he can get into
some particular input element but by
gaining some focus
now all these are done in the help of
some triggering points which is called
as events
now we have these event listener
especially for older browsers
and these events are nothing but some
triggering point which can trigger some
actions
now these actions are termed as
functions
or your handler for that particular
event
so to put this in a very simple layman
form
say for example uh someone is ringing
the bell your doorbell and uh you are
getting up and uh
you are attending
the door so you're opening the door and
checking who is it
so in this scenario so someone ringing
the bell is the event
and you getting up and
going and saying so who is it and
accordingly responding so that would be
the function so that is the action so
you that particular event
doorbell ringing has triggered you to do
or take some action which is your
function
so we will see more about this event so
in this project we'll have lot of events
and we will also be handling those using
some functions and actions
so
what next
here in our
project so in this
demo that we will be seeing
what are we going to do so what is the
take away so what can you expect out of
this so you can see this screenshot
so this is the web page that you will be
creating
now this webpage as i told you earlier
it is a movie website um so it's like a
movie webpage it's a single page that we
are going to create
and you can see a list of movies to
watch some latest movie
so you also
have some red color buttons to your
right
so these buttons like uh so here it is
written as delete button and there is
also a green color add button over there
which is at the end of the page
where you can input some movie name and
you can dynamically add it now all these
we are doing via javascript so you can
statically add it also using your html
but in this particular example so we are
going to use javascript to dynamically
add
a new movie
and if you want to delete those movie we
are going to delete that also so this is
what we are going to see
as an example
and in this demo application so wherein
you can create these uh details of the
movies
now i have to say something here so i
have styled this using css
but we will not be going in depth into
the css because that is not in our scope
but i will walk you through the code
that i have written so that you get this
beautiful you know the background image
and the alignment and margin and padding
those are the properties that i have
included to get this style so i will
walk you through that then once that is
done so we'll focus more on our
javascript code so that we can create
this particular
movie website in an easier so very very
simple or easier manner so how we can
implement this particular
concept of dam daw manipulation so that
we will be seeing in our movie project
okay so let's get started
and before we begin with the actual
coding
uh of creating a new movie
and deleting a movie so before we do
that
i would like to walk you through the um
actual application
so let's get started on that
so before we get on to the coding and
stuff so i would like you to
take a look at the final webpage or the
website that you would be creating
so
let's take a look at that now so this
will be the um
website that you will be uh developing
so you can see that it's a movie web
page it's it's kind of a single page
application because we are creating
just one single
uh web page for this particular demo so
you can create any number of pages you
want later but for this we are just
going to create one index.html now in
this if you can see there is a list of
movies here
popular movies
yeah so most of my favorites that you
can see and as i move my cursor you can
see that there is a purple color
like a border that's actually a border
that i have written in css it's a border
property
so you can see that on the left which is
highlighting that particular row
and you also can see a corresponding
button in red which is the delete button
so when i press it's going to delete
that particular movie
and you also can see a text box at the
end of this page and there is a green
color button to add
a new movie for this
so
you can see the entire page has been
styled in css so it looks
quite appealing so i have given an image
which
emulates like a movie screen movie
theater screen
and there is a card that you can see so
this is the card
and so which has this title and a tag
line
and all these have been aesthetically
arranged here as you can see so there's
a lot of css here so which
goes about to create the theme and style
of any web page
so css is very very important so if you
have to
attract any um
no probable
customer for your page or for your
business the
something that is very important the
entity that is very important is your
style
or your theme so the css plays a
major role over here
so i will show you the um you know i
will have a code walkthrough of how i
have styled using css so let's try to
add a movie over here you also can see
there is a
placeholder tip also text also over
there
um
let's go on with this
movie
yeah the popular one
so let's say add and
you can see instantly now
avengers getting added at the end of
this particular row
and you also can see that there is a
delete button that got added
automatically so
if i have to delete a movie
so you can see that it just goes off
instantly
and i have to remind you um so this is
not
linked to any database so it's not
persistently stored
so if i have to refresh it you get
everything back
so this is just like stored in
an array so it's just a list of movies
that we are just going to store in the
page so if you have to have these
changes reflected of course you'll have
to connect it to a database so this is
what we are going to do
um so using the dom and using the
javascript feature so how are we going
to add an entity or element to your dom
and how are we going to delete it
so this is what you can expect out of
this demo
all right so
here we are in the
editor i'm using visual studio code so
this is the editor
that i'm using currently
i do use other editors like sublime
brackets webstorm
so this is purely up to you
whichever is the editor that you're
comfortable with and you're already
working even if it is going to be
notepad plus plus
um or if you're from a java background
and you use eclipse more you can go
ahead with eclipse
so whatever is your editor your
preferred preferred choice uh you can go
with that
visual studio code i've been working
since the inception so i have i'm also
from the dot net background so i've
worked
exhaustively with visual studio also
so here this editor is very comfortable
in many ways it is just not for
javascript
it you also can use vs code for
angular or react or python any other
type of technology that you choose any
type of web development you can use
visual studio so it has a very nice
intuitive and simple user interface and
it has an integrated terminal so where
you can run your server also and it has
a very good debugging
options with intelli sends and you can
install
packages on the go and you can also use
uh this particular space for uh
deployment also so it's pretty um easy
and comfortable
so if you prefer visual studio um and
you're from that
background or you have been using
exhaustively for main stack or monster
so you can use visual studio otherwise
it's completely up to your choice so you
can see that i have a folder
which is called as dom demo
where i already have three files there
so
two of which is nothing but some
pictures so this is the background so
that i'll be using
so
if you could recollect so i had shown
you the uh
webpage with that theater background so
i will be using these two images for
that so you can take a look at it
so you can see this one
right you could recollect that so i
will be using this for background and
where i will be listing out the movies
so i will be using this
image i will not be using the entire
image i will be cropping and i will be
using it
and the
all these style uh to use these images
for other style features also for
including those buttons and you know the
rows
all these i have used css cascading
style sheet
and so this is the style that i will be
including so
so i will not be um
you know explaining each and everything
so i presume so you all have some basic
knowledge of css
and html
um so what
i have done briefly to get that style i
will explain it
in a very um
precise concise manner so that like
you will get an idea like where what
feature i have included and you can
explore on your own these style features
so you can see that the background image
i have added as this property and the
size font family and colors and spacing
i have set
this is for the heading and
so you should be knowing about different
types of selectors like id selector
stack selector class selector so this
hash denotes the id selector
so i will be using this id selector when
i'm creating my html page
so what i have done is for that
particular i'm creating one container
okay so for that container i'm giving a
name called as wrapper
so where this container is the one which
is going to
list out all the movies for us so the
margin padding border now these are very
very important so if you want to have a
evenly aligned
readable legible list or text or content
so you have to play around with these
different properties of css
and you also can see that
there is a page banner so
this is the outermost container then i
will also be showing an image within
that where the movie list will be
displayed
and within that i will be giving the you
know the top movies that list so for
that and the paragraph for the tagline
so some of these alignment features and
width and margin i have given
so you also can see that i have given
certain elements
with these ids movie list and this is
for the button add movie
margin has been given there
and the list i do it's an unordered list
so unordered list um
i don't want to specify any particular
bullets there so ordered list will be
having like one two three or abcd
unordered usually bullets will be
displayed so i don't want any bullets so
i am displaying that as none
and so this is the one
i have used for the list items that you
can see
and by default if i don't move the
cursor the border left if you can
recollect i had one purple color one
right which got highlighted only on the
left border
so
by default i have made it as you know
gray so but when i hover the
so this is the pseudo list so when i
hover over it so the state it gets
changed so it becomes the color becomes
purple here
and these are the style features that
you can see for the
delete button so this is the delete
button so it's a class so that's why it
has this period symbol
and
so what are the different so it has a
radius it has a rounded corners that
button
and the text is white so all these and
again like when i hover so from red it
changes the background color
and you also can see
this is the
style for the add movie button you can
see that so this is predominantly it
isn't
um
gray color
and so this is for the input which is
your text box
and this is this is the add movie button
so this particular
button so i have made it as green
and you can see the other features also
and again so however it becomes like a
dark green so these things and all you
can change
right and for these labels so for all
the elements um that i will be creating
now in the index.html so
this is the style that i am going to
apply so
you can
go ahead with your own style there is no
restriction so you can change the color
the alignment you want to change the
the background layout so completely to
you so our focus is not css
for this particular demo
so our focus is on the javascripts dom
manipulation
all right
so let's start creating our webpage
so the first step how do we create our
web page is by creating a html page
after we create a html page and
set those content you know the list of
movies
will try to create
the most important file which is your
javascript file and we will connect all
these together to your html file so we
already have the
styles.css in place
um
so after we create our html page we will
be creating the uh javascript
page also and we will be connecting all
these three together
so here you can see there is an icon
which states new file
and
so let's give this name
index.html and you can see the icon gets
magically changed over there
so
i have a corresponding
you know
extension
file
which
actually
gives all these extensions that logos
will be
automatically updated so you might not
be having that
by default so if you want you can just
go ahead
with your
these extensions
you can see that so you can see this
this is the one that i have already
included ps code icons so if you want to
have those logos so that you have a
clear picture of what you're creating
you will be able to do it so here we
also can create one more which is your
app dot
js this is the one that you will be
creating next
so you can see this js icon also pops up
nicely so by default you might not be uh
seeing this icon so but if you have that
particular extension that file you
should be able to see it
all right so
inside my um
index.html so let's start with our
coding so first thing so you can see
that very nicely this intellisense is
also popping up
okay so here i say that it is a html5
document
so the html document earlier we had
html4 version for many many years
so recently it was upgraded
w3c which is our world wide web upgraded
that to the next level which is your
html file so here
this particular the first line where it
denotes the name space it's much more
concise and precise now otherwise if you
know about if you have already coded in
html4 you will know the pain of writing
that you know
lines and lines of that name space so
the first line indicates that it is a
html5 document
so now we'll have to specify the root
element or
the parent
element or the outermost one which is
our html so all our tags and elements
goes inside this
html tag
so we have this head
and we also have the body
so
so head as i told you earlier
during the uh discussion so where i was
saying that all the metadata
and other
properties like your title and
so if you want to link other files like
your styles or your script everything
goes inside your head
having said that
you also can include your
script src anywhere inside your body
also you can have more than
one script source also
not necessarily that it has to be inside
your head only
but we specify some meta data and other
um
within your head elements so here i'm
including one character set here so this
is the
default one which is your unicode
okay eight
so
not mandatory but you can include this
one and as i told you we can also
include your style and you also can
include your script but we'll do that
later so right now i'll just include my
title so which will be displayed on the
webpage title bar on the
topmost one that you can see
i will say
movie time
right so now this goes inside the head
inside our body as i told you
while we were going through this style
so we have already created this
outermost container and i have given
some name for that so we will be using
this
in our html
content so where i am going to create a
dip
and all the id
so will be represented as hash that you
will be using in your css so you can see
this one so
i've used this hash it means that we'll
have to use an id over here
so
let's say
wrapper
now this is going to be my outermost div
and all other elements are going to be
present inside this dip
and inside my div i'm going to have a
head down so this is a html element
header
and inside this header i'm going to have
the title
so which says
movie time and it also has a tag line i
showed you in the finished web page
so
those
movie title as well as the tagline i'm
going to include it here
so inside my header
i'm going to have this one more dev
and i've already created the style for
this
so this will be the page banner
and
inside
my page banner
i'm going to have this title
so the movie title i'm going to use h1
over here
and
i'm also giving the class because i've
already defined
and
you also can define the style outside or
you can have a style inside the head
that you can refer so in that case it
would be referred as internal style now
this will be external style but if you
want you can also have an inline style
say for example
i can include a style
property here so this will become the
inline style of h1
which will have the highest precedence
so
in this i say i want to have a white
color
so you can either
pick from the
text as such or you also can give this
hex value
so both are same
then after that so all your css
properties are terminated by a semicolon
and it uh it's separated with this colon
like this property
name and the value separated by
colon and
the statement it ends with a semicolon
so here you specify whatever is the
heading that you wish to display
and
next
we will be
giving the tag line
so let's also have an inline element for
the tagline
so we'll be using the same thing which
is the white text since we are going to
have a colored background
so we are using the white text here so
i'm copying and pasting it here
yeah
so here
so we'll have to close this
here let's say
um
curated
list of most
amazing
movies
so you can
write your text like however you want so
however you want to
display those tag lines and the title
so
i'm closing my
paragraph here
and i'm also giving a break
there
and so with this this particular div
which is the page banner so this is over
so i've created this page banner just to
display this is the entire thing is your
header you can see
so this is your
which is your banner and this entire
thing is my wrapper so i i still have my
list of movies that will be coming up
here in this section so this will be the
title and the tagline
so after this
header i want to include a div
which is going to be my movie list so
we'll call this
movie
different list
and inside which i'm going to
have
the title again something like a
subtitle
so i'm using my
h2 so where i say
again i get this
title class so which will be used in
styling
and
within which i will say
movies to what so this will be the title
for the list
so after which we are going to include
our unordered list of movies
now inside which
inside the unordered list i'm going to
have now
see two things here
if you could recollect the
movie page that i had shown
we will be
creating the name of the movie
in the in the row wise format and
it will also be having the
delete button so you would be able to
see that the delete button would be
there
and
so
both elements have to be there for each
uh movie list so i will be specifying
the name of the movie here
and i will also be specifying the
delete button so inside my
list item i'm going to have a span
now this span
so i'll say
so it'll have name
and
where let's include the first one
and turn
and i will be including a span element
for the
delete button also
and i will just say delete
okay
so let me copy this one because we are
just going to use this for all the this
particular style for all our
movies so i'm copying this and i'm
pasting
maybe
four five movies
so
[Music]
three
and five
okay so let's
write whatever movies that you want over
here so let me just change these movies
quickly
okay so all of my favorite movies
inception again
yeah
and
stage
okay
all right so the last one maybe i have
included one extra edge okay
um
just the avengers or avengers okay
whatever so i have uh included this five
movies now
so with this this movie list is over
so
now next what we will do is we'll have
to do one more thing before we move on
to javascript file
so in this one we have to create
our
we will be having a form element here
the main reason being we have to include
a submit button so that
i can
inform the javascript module or the
function so which can handle
the addition of new movie when i have to
click on the add button here
so
i'm giving a name for the id
so this will be the forms which will be
the parent element and inside the form
i'm going to
what we are going to have is we are
going to have the
button
and also the input box
so the input
the text box we will be including so you
can see the list of
input elements of your html so we'll be
selecting text
and we can have a placeholder it's
nothing but the text
so
where i can specify okay so this is
this should not be inside
so this is text
so the placeholder property where you
can give some hint
of
what is supposed to be entered in that
text box so i'll say add
[Music]
so let's close this
input box
now this
button let's add
so now this is going to invoke the
function which we will be adding in the
javascript
page
so with this
uh we have closed this form and we have
also closed this div and the body so
with this the
html content the code for the html
content is ready
so if you have to see this
page so
i have this option set up here so open
and default browser
so when i click this one
[Music]
okay so you can see this
and um so if you're wondering why is
this blank over here
um
you can see this here now yeah
it's the
main reason is i've given white text
because we'll have to include the style
we have not included the style yet so
just the html content it looks like this
so it's not it doesn't look so great i
know
so there is no
javascript function also
but we can see that whatever content
that we have mentioned
so
it has been
displayed properly so the next step
for us to
do is to
add the css and see if it matches the
style that i had shown earlier
so if you have to add the css so let's
see okay so we've now seen before adding
cso so i keep saying about the
importance of the style and theme also
so i know your content is ready but it
doesn't look so attractive so how could
you make it so engaging
and
so that the probable customer or your
business user can start using your web
page so how can you make it much more
engaging and attractive
let's add the css and see
if it creates a magic or not
i know this is not our prime focus but
css definitely helps
so
the link is the
tag that we will be
using to
specify the reference so this is the
reference where i have to add so
whatever is your css style so this is a
external style so i use my href property
to attach this
external style here so i'll have to
include so you can see that it gets
listed yes
and
it's not mandatory but still you can
mention
that it is a style sheet
so css is the default style sheet and
javascript is the default
scripting language for your html so we
have attached this now
okay
so
let us see again
okay look at that now look at that
so you can see this before css
so
literally it is uh nothing it doesn't
look like anything at all but you can
see like after css so if you are
if you have
uh fancy taking for your forms if you
love fonts maybe you can change all
these fonts i've used some default fonts
um
so
how would you want you can go ahead and
change it you can see that whatever we
have given in the css that i have
highlighted
it's now
getting reflected in this new page so
you can see the difference between this
and so that's why i opened another tab
for you to show the see the difference
but nothing is going to work so you can
see that the hover so you can see the
red is changing into maroon
and this
may be not much of a difference but you
still can see i would say if you're
using css don't change those text size
and
you know the alignment and
placing because
there
the effect that you will be getting
where it will be like flickering a lot
and it will be the alignment will be an
issue always change the color or some
highlight those things not the size and
alignment so you can also see like how
nicely these rows are getting
highlighted
so now whatever we add
so
nothing is going to be
coming on because we don't have a
javascript
functionality yet so that is what we are
going to see now next so let's start
our javascript coding which will be the
next module
now let's start with the
app.js which will be your javascript
file that you will be
including and coding for dom
manipulation
so this app.js file has to be integrated
inside your
index.html so how we have included our
style we will have to use another
element which is your script and we have
to include src instead of href so that
we will do it later so now let's start
creating this code for the app.js
so let's start with this document
element and we will have to do the
coding for
one of the event so we'll be writing
those functionality whatever
we have done so we are going to create
the event and attach your
functionality for that particular event
so
there are ways different ways by which
you can do it and event listener is one
of the way so i can specify so as you
can see in this intellisense this purple
color box indicates that it is a method
so you can see that it is a method and
this blue brick that you see so that is
a property so
we'll be using this method
so i'm adding an event over here so what
is the event that we are going to add
now so we are adding this
event which is called as the dom
so i will explain so what exactly is
this
dom content loaded
now this event fires when the initial
html document
has been completely loaded and passed
so
without for other dependencies like your
css file style sheets images or any
other elements to finish loading so your
original content
so if it is loaded and passed this event
will be filed
and
the target for this event is your
document itself and that has to be
loaded
and you can listen for this event on the
window interface to handle it in the um
capturing bubbling or the download phase
so javascript event has different type
of phases also
when the event can traverse
inside from your parent to your child so
that it can be handled at that level
also it's called as your tunneling and
when it has to go upwards so it will be
like bubbling face so so different ways
by
how your event can traverse and it can
be captured
so there is another event which is
called as load now that will be you will
not be using that
for this particular purpose so here i'm
just using this event
to check if the content if that
particular document your html document
is loaded
without the other dependencies that's
what i said without the style sheet or
other features to be loaded but another
event is there which is called as just
load and it should be used to
uh today to detect a fully loaded page
along with stylesheet and everything so
it's usually
people confuse between
this load and the document content
included so understand the difference
for load it is like fully loaded whereas
dom content loaded is only when the dom
features or the html content is loaded
so let's write the function
for this so
we will be using this syntax so first is
this event name and here we are going to
include the function so all other
function that we will be including so it
will be going inside this
main function that i have
first thing that i am going to do is
create a variable in this case we will
be creating a constant because we are
not going to change anything
to capture where exactly these
event and the functions will be affected
so in our case the list movie list is
where we are concerned we can add a
movie we can delete a movie so we have
to create a
entity which can refer to that
particular list so i'm creating so you
can use a bear also
here since this is not going to be
changing so i'm using a constant
so i'm using this method which is called
as your query selector by which
you can select that particular
um
you know the element whatever element
that you have created so here i want to
select my
unordered list so i'm using this movie
so it is present inside um
container which is called as your movie
list so inside which
i am selecting this unordered list and
that is getting stored in this list so
this is um
it's like
disabled or like grayed out because we
have not used this list object yet so
when we use it so it will be highlighted
i am also going to create one more um to
store my form
so
whatever forms you can have like
multiple forms also and all the form
elements i'm storing here
and so let's do the first one say
if i have to delete
my movies so to delete these movies
i'm going to attach so we have already
created that list so to that list now i
told you right so now if you start using
it it will be highlighted so you can see
that one
so i'm adding another event listener so
whenever i'm going to click that
i'm going to check if the user is
clicking the delete button or he's
clicking something else so
i'm using this
click event
so i'm attaching a event
an event handler i'm attaching over here
and then i'm also
you can also pass on another parameter
so in this case i am passing some
e parameter which is you can also name
it as event also um
or whatever name that you want so this
event parameter is nothing but all the
metadata will be stored in that
particular
object e or the event object so it will
have all the necessary
properties stored there so you can find
out the source of the event you can find
out the target of even
so everything will be stored in the
event object so here i'm checking using
my if condition
so i'm checking if the target
okay so if the target element has i told
you the event object will have the
source where it originated and which is
the target
so here i am checking if the class name
is equal to is equal to
delete meaning if i'm trying to click on
the delete button i'm checking that so
if it is right so if it is true
then i'm creating a
li
which is your list item and i'm trying
to remove that particular
element there so i'm saying that target
so i'm saying which is the see when i
have to delete the element it has to
delete the entire
ally right including the span which is
the movie text also one more span which
has the delete button
so i have to delete the parent element
so here
i'm mentioning that i'm creating the li
which is the parent element
and
now i say
the parent node of this particular li
so i want to delete this so
to delete an entity in dom if you have
to do it you have an
method which is called as your remote
child so you can see that
so
the parent node along with your so both
your spam so the entire li element i
have to remove
so i am removing it like this i am
calling this method which is called as
your remote child which is going to
remove that particular li element so now
this is with your
li
so here we have added this and
we are trying to delete it
so this is
one of the functionality and the next
one that we have to do is
add movies
um so before adding the movie so let's
see if this is going to really work
so for that we have to include one more
step what is that
yes right we have to attach it so your
index.html does not have this
app.js
linked yet so
let's
add that so here we'll be using script
src
is equal to so this is my app.js and
let's include this one
so once you have included
so in my
app.js i have given the
main
dom contact loaded event so underneath i
have these
different features included
one is the deleting the movie one is
deleting the movie another one that we
will be writing is adding the movie
so let's see if this is
going to work or not
so go back to this
i've already added
the script and
so you can open it so you can refresh
the existing page also let us see if the
delete button really works now
yes it works
so
okay i just deleted everything but as i
told you earlier
this is um
this is not a permanent database that
you will be like storing
so these does not get reflected
persistent in a persistent way
so when we refresh the page we are going
to get it back but we can see that the
deletion
fire dom manipulation using javascript
code has worked successfully now so we
are done with the first feature so we
will have to move on to the second one
where we can add a new movie and when we
click on this button it has to be
instantly added let us go back to the
editor to add the
next feature now
so let's get started with adding the
new movie
so it's not like the straightforward
delete feature
there are certain series of steps that
is involved
when we are adding a new movie
so first being to creating the elements
look whatever
elements that we are going to add so
it's just not one
uh text or the movie list we also have
to add the delete button along with that
right so that would be the first one and
the second one would be to add
the
text
content as such so what is the
text content or value what is the new
one so the delete text and also the name
of the movie so that has to be added
and you can see that each and every um
[Music]
you know these it has a distinctive
style property the left a purple border
when it is highlighted and each row it
also has a delete which is like a red
color
uh button which is curved on the edges
so these different style features have
to be included so how do we do that
so that would be another step that we
have to do which is adding the classes
and finally we will have to attach it to
the dom
so then you attach it to your dom
element
so let's start with the first phase
so
all these element now it's present in
the form so from the form we are trying
to add
the new
movie new element so for that we'll have
to capture the form so form is in the
form of an array
so each html element can have n number
of forms
so we have already given the id as add
movie for that form we just have one
form so we are
retrieving that and i'm storing it
inside my add form
constant
next
so i'm using this add form to add this
event listener over here
so when the
button so which is so here you can have
all these events so here i'm saying
submit is the event so submit is the
most important event so by which you can
actually submit the value
otherwise um
changes that needs to be captured will
not be done properly
so i am including this
function
and again i am passing this event object
which is your e
so now here
um
i'm adding all these ones so
first one that i'm doing over here is to
include your
prevent
default this proven default method
cancels the event
if it is cancelable meaning that the
default action that the
that belongs to the event will not occur
say for instance if we have to use it um
for uh when the user clicks on a submit
button but it has to prevent that
clicking or submitting of a form or
there is a
clicking on a hyperlink or something but
it should be prevented so these default
actions now if you want to prevent uh so
you can use this one so here we are
going to use it because we don't want
this to be
literally
bubbled up and but you also have to note
that not all events are cancelable
you can use the cancelable property to
find out if some event is cancelable or
not
and these this particular prevent
default
method
also does not prevent further
propagation of an event through the
drawn so if you want to literally stop
it so there is another method which is
called a stop
propagation so
we are invoking this
method first and so let me just close
this one also
and i want all these other feature to be
included within this one
okay
so
first step after creating the uh
capturing the form element
i want to create the other
constants for these values and
elements the other elements so first
thing
i'm creating a constant called as uh
value
now here
i am selecting the using the query
selector again this method again
and
i want to retrieve this
input type so where i say
[Music]
my text box so i want to retrieve it so
where i say the
type as
text so
i want to retrieve the input type where
the type as
text so be very careful with the
codes so if you are using the double
quotes as the outer one just use it for
that and use an inner for the inner code
use a single code so vice versa
so check on that
and how it is closing
so otherwise it will not throw any error
but you will not be getting the value
that you expect also
and the second constant that i want to
create it is for the list item so here i
have the document
and here we are going to use this
special uh method you can see that there
are so many number of create element
creative and many create methods are
there as a part of
javascript dom feature
so we are going to use this one create
element and i am going to create a new
li element
because this is the one that we want
which needs to be added to the unordered
list
and of course we will have to create the
um
the corresponding variable or the
constant for the
name of the movie so that has to be
there right so i'll have to create
that one so
that one again is
as you can see it's a spam
so
i'll show you the html code here so
quickly let's go
and so you can see this one so this is
what we are trying to create here in
this feature so i will have to create
two elements over here so one is for the
movie another spam is for the delete
button so these two has to be created so
this is a span and you can see that the
class will have to add next
but this li element we have to create it
like this that is what we are doing here
so i am creating a span so
one is for the movie name and another
one we have to create a
delete button
so if we have to create a new record so
each record has a movie name as well as
the delete button
so i'm going to create that as well
so
in this one again so what is the element
that we will be creating in both the
cases both are span which is present
inside li so li is the parent element
and these two span will be the child
element so all these have been now
created uh individually or separately we
have created now we have to set the
hierarchy so we have to append these two
as child of this li and this li has to
be attached to this
body so this one so this appending will
do it at the last right so first step we
have created this elements so first we
have retrieved the
movie and we have added attached event
listener for the submit button
and
then in the second one second phase for
creating elements we have created so we
have
checked if whatever is the value that
the user is entering inside the text box
so using that we are going to create it
so
then we have created the ali element
which is your list item and then the
span element for the movie name span
element for the delete button so all
these have been created now let's go to
the
next phase which is to add the text
content so we have already
received the value that the user has
entered in the text box and we are
storing it in big constant called as
value so now that we have to attach it
to this particular element which is the
movie name okay so that will be the next
one so here i will say movie name
dot so it has this property as you can
see which is called as the text content
so
so this is the span element so if you
have to create a text for that so i'm
saying that whatever the user has
entered in the text box that is stored
in the value constant so that i am
storing it here that i am passing to my
text content property of the movie name
which is nothing but the span that we
have created
now the second one we have also created
this delete button span right so that
so
content we have to create so which is
nothing but the text that will be
displayed so here we are creating the
button as delete button
so however you want to create it remove
or the d caps however you want to create
you can go ahead and create it
so
now this step is also over so first we
have created this form and then we have
created all these elements uh the
corresponding li and then the movie name
span delete button span
and then we have also attached the
corresponding content for these two span
elements
now we have to add the style so of
course
you can see like how it is displayed so
this one has a red color buttons and
then you can see the different
these borders so that we have already
created in the external style sheet
this has to be updated here
so
we are doing this
so i say class list
dot add
so this is add
so we are adding the
class name
for the corresponding element that we
have created so that you get the
style feature
that we have already defined
okay
by default it goes on with your ad event
listener
um
all right so this is this is the class
name
okay so we are adding it so let's go to
the style.css
and so you can see this
delete
and
name so all these are present over here
right so all these are there so i want
to attach so you can see this one name
and delete it already has this one so
that we are trying to attach it here so
this step is also over so we are
attaching the class for the style or the
theme purpose
now final and most important one is to
attach it to the dom so that
all your content along all your elements
along with those textual content
added with those class properties with
the css features now it is all rendered
onto your dom in a proper hierarchical
way so that is now is very important so
that is the final step
so i am saying li so now li is your
parent element right so
i'm attaching my li
uh
first your li has to be attached to the
list
i think they've already created this
list which is nothing but the unordered
list so this line has to be attached to
the list
and
inside your li these two
uh spans your movie name and delete
button both has to be attached so your
movie name and delete button are the
child elements of li and li is the child
element of your
uh list so it has to be attached so
first let's
let's attach your
[Music]
movie name so the child of your
life which is the first span
and
i'm also
attaching the
delete
button so which is another spam child
and finally i am attaching the
li
which is in turn a child of
the
list element
okay
so here i say list dot append child
which is your ally
okay but inside your li you can see the
movie name and delete button we can go
to the index.html to check so url or the
list is the parent element
inside which i have my li
list item and the li is it becomes the
parent for these two which is the name
of the movie and the delete button for
each corresponding record
so these two child elements first we are
attaching to a line and then this line
we are attaching is uh to the ul so that
is what we are doing here
right so this will be the final and most
important step
so with this we are done with our
script
so
make sure you save this one
and let's go back
to this
and refresh it once
okay so this delete button it is working
as usual
we have already seen that and
let's see if a
new movie can be inserted
okay let's say
wow now you can see that instantly
new
movie has been
added at the bottom and you can see
the two span elements
okay which is the child of the zli it
gets added to the
parent which is the list item so this is
the outermost one which is the uh ul or
your list type list
and then each one is the child which is
your life the li has two child which is
your movie name as well as the delete
button so we have first created these
values
and then
the classes have been added
to ensure that the css is consistent and
then finally we use the doms append
child you can use your append method
also to attach it so that this hierarchy
is formed so using dom manipulation via
javascript so
we have seen that so very very
powerful in a very in a powerful way
and in a very simpler and effective way
how we can
add new elements new nodes attach events
listen to events and
also to delete it all these it can be
done so effectively
so you can keep adding
more you can try to validate this also
and say if i want to edit this i won't
edit the existing movies even that it is
completely possible you can do that or
only the style if you want you can
change that style also so everything
just with javascript so just with
javascript so how you can create the
element so without the html content at
all you can just write from the heading
to the footer to the content everything
you can create
just with your javascript so that is the
power of javascript so
i think we have done quite enough with
this
manipulation so for a quick recap
we started with these three files so
style dot css so i walked you through
the entire style and theme features i
have incorporated and we also had these
two
images already so you can include so
this is just an overview guideline of
how this dom can be manipulated in one
way
you are free to explore uh having this
as a base and you can just work upon how
you want to
carry on with your dom manipulation so
we created first this index.html so we
created all the content the head and
body
and initially we didn't attach it with
the style sheet as well as the script
then we created those containers the
wrapper and page banner so that we had
the corresponding styles for all these
and we also created a ul which is an
unordered list with all these list items
so these list item internally so it has
each one had two span
one is the name of the movie another one
is the delete button for the movie
and you also
can see that last we have also added an
input element for the text box where you
can add the movie and also a button to
submit so that the
new movie has been inserted so after
this we created this
javascript coding so we started with the
dom content loaded and first we saw the
delete movie
we use the event listener when whenever
i click on the delete button so based on
the event object i check for the target
and i'm removing that particular element
so i'm using the remote child over here
for deleting a movie or deleting any
particular node as such and we are using
um append child to add the movie so
these two are the important functions
that you have to keep in mind and in the
second one we added a movie first we
created this form we captured this
and then we created those individual
elements the li span for the movie name
and delete button and we also had those
values that needs to be written which
was added and then we added the class
and finally we use the append child to
append these two spam element to the li
and then li which is the child of your
list gets added so that is how we saw
this
dom manipulation so
i hope you all enjoyed this demo and
also
your the concept of your dom
manipulation via javascript is clear to
all of you if getting your learning
started is half the battle what if you
could do that for free
visit scale up by simply learn click on
the link in the description to know more
in this video we bring to you six simple
applications that you can build using
javascript we'll first create some
simple beginner level projects like the
to-do list app
then we'll move on to a quiz app
then we'll move on to more advanced apps
like the weather app
the tic-tac-toe game
and finally we'll conclude the session
by creating a snake game application
now i'm sure you're excited to dive deep
into it so let's begin
using this javascript css and html combo
known as call
to do application to do applications
kind of general task manager application
where you can attach add a task delete
the task
and uh completed tasks very simple and
sophisticated application we will start
to start working with and here we start
working with our first
very simple statement
that this one is called
so let me go and create a new folder
[Music]
[Music]
html by constructing our css file will
be well taken care of
so we say
here you will see
class equal to
container
now inside this
we would like to have some header
portion
okay let me see another tip type
and insert a strip type will say div
id
equal to
this box
okay and again
classic
you can see
input
item
and
next we like to use the spam tag
and this is span i'll say
one click
equal to
now
i do not have the function name for new
element but you would like to create it
okay and
class equal to
give a name i'm saying
okay and here i would like to
add it
all right that's my spam tag now
tag is also getting closed
so after the div tag you would like to
use the url
well you
say name
learn
new
tasks
is the first item
like that i can have some other items
with me
like this
[ __ ] with the dog like that i can have n
number of tasks which is available to me
okay so here the human tech is getting
closed
and the dip tag is also getting close
that's it
okay so i do not have a css file with me
so i can just create
css
and this i like to import it in
here
link i need to
okay so i can have
very simple looking field for title
nothing is there
add
which must be a
kind of a button for me or whatever it
is
so it is just a span tag for me
on which i will try to click and perform
some action remember this is not very
good
now here once it is ready i would like
to go ahead and talk about my
main css which will help me to make the
complete look and
so we're going to start working with the
css now
from my css
we want to basically perform
the edit where
close button i want to create it
and i want to create a close button to
hide the current list items in multiple
activities i have it which i want to do
it with my css let's get started with
css now and with my css i would like to
create some basic effects toward my
application
fine so step number one i would like to
say a strict
for everything that means for everyone
i'm saying box sizing
border box
basic one
nothing is affected it is for common for
all
here i would like to start with the body
now
body
background color
background color i will say light still
blue
background image it's up to me whether i
would like to use it or not
but i can use
height
600 pixels
next background position
that i would like to use center
next is background repeat
because if i do not have any image i
would not be using repeat so
background
size
cover
looks beautiful
well
going ahead we talk about our container
part now
okay
so if i just see my previous code which
is there with me that is called
calculator here in this app.css
i have a option called container
so that was my container i just copy
this
and i use it again here
here in container width i would like to
use 50 percent now
background color remain white
align self
center display block margin
start using
120 pixels
auto and box shadow
whatever it is we're not using
already once again we're not using
box shadow 5 pixel 10 pixel 20 pixels
perfect
there we go
okay
so this is my simple look now talk about
the ul part now
margin
next order left
sorry left
six pixels
next list
iphone
let's take a look
better
okay
now
so
few things we've used
uh
border left six pixel solid t padding
now we talk about our ul and allied part
okay cursor
pointer
next position
related
next pattern
we just would like to install pixels
like this
background
remember
okay font size
you can select 18 pixels
transition
for
0.2 seconds
for transition
okay and the last option
user icon select
none
perfect
now looks beautiful
you can see now how the effects are
awesome
okay url like that
now we talk about our positions wise
properties ur
li colon
over
okay i said
background color
okay
and after that use your
child
or values
background color
again i can do the same
okay
now
after this
we are using this called ulli project
i'll be using background
then color
i'm using the same white
text decoration
which is the checked option
okay
now
after that
check before i also want to use it so we
just say
url
before content
after that position
absolute
after that water style watercolor sorry
watercolor i'm just using color white
then border style
solid
then border width
border
icon width
then top
10 pixels
left
pixels
then transform
rotate 45 degrees
then height
15 pixels
then with
seven pixels
now you see this now
how they work like
that javascript will be applied later on
to make it even more better so we are
just getting it ready for that
okay after that we'll be using for close
and just close using position
absolutely
then write
zero
zero
ready
four options we are using it here
okay then afterwards
close
or
and just close over and be using
background color
that's called
orange
red and
color
right
this is for close over
then we're talking about color header
header will be using background color
then padding
30 pixels
and 30 pixels
color
looking beautiful
well this is your header what we have
written it now
after we will be talking about for the
header after an input
dot
header colon
after
and then display
okay now after this we'll be using for
the input
not
dot i'll be using rather using directly
input
for input input i have to make
more better way margin
zero
then water
then border radius
0
then width
75
then padding
10 pixels
okay then float left
the next option will be font size
i'm using 16 pixels
perfect
nice
so
this is my text box
okay
now
we like to talk about call buttons
okay
it's time to talk about code button so
we'll be saying dot
add
so
once again the conditions that we remain
same
we talk about call
padding 10 pixels
talk about covet
we say 25
we say background
purple
then we talk about call color
okay and we use float
left
after this fourth left click on what
texture line
center
then font size
talk about 16 pixels
[Music]
0.3 seconds
[Music]
that's it let's check
so my to-do list css part is over okay
well after this
we're going to talk about our gs file
which is on the most important area of
your code
now here let me close down everything
and start creating another file here one
is called
app.js
the main calculation goes here
so from this point onwards we would like
to start working with a property
uh whichever we have created here
on the top of that will be start working
here
okay
so
in my css what are the things are
required
that you want to understand okay so we
talk about option called like the live
stream forward list items
so
let's start working with
name
[Music]
document
is
document dot create text node
and
i'll just give the value here using
forward slash
after that
expand
dot
open change
txt
and then
my
so the first function which we have
written
okay so there's a name
called node list so just a typical logic
in fact i would not even say the
function is just a logic which you write
after that
uh
what we need to do now is
um we have to start working with our
option called r
close
equal to
document dot get element by class
once again
for
zero
price
less than
close stock length
on
click
ok close i dot
equal to
function
and now here we save our
div equal to
this
dot
parent
element
okay
and now
next thing so this is for when you try
to click on a close button to hide the
current list
okay so you can say
is to basically add a check symbol
okay while clicking on the list item
that means if any item that you
basically clicked so what should happen
now
so when i so it will get straight saying
that hey this task is over now so we can
save our
list
okay
which takes even as a parameter
okay here i see this
dot
target
dot
class list
dot
toggle
here i say check
okay and what should happen now
but before that
i just need to check the condition for
if
e dot target dot tag name this way
give it a target dot
toggle
check
okay and here you pass a value called
false
that's it
okay now you have to basically go and
create one of functions for this
so after that i'm going to create a new
function now function
dot
create element
then
input value
equal to
document
dot
get element by id
item
dot
okay
and after that we're just calculating
this value using r
t
equal to
document dot create text node
okay here we pass
input value here and i say align dot
puppet child
of t
like this
and here we see if
input
value
equal to
blank nothing is there
then what
so in such cases we can say alert
this is basically the validation for me
this field cannot be empty
okay this field cannot be empty so this
is the first error procedure showing
that else condition
in press condition
document
dot
get element by id
okay which is the type of item
okay so
taking about item which is a type of
so else condition which is saying
document element by id
rather than item let's pass list here
and inside this list we'll say
dot append chart
otherwise what will happen
we will talk about this option called
talking element by id item
item dot value
equal to
black
okay that's the case now
after that it will start working with
our
span tag now
the span tag will have its own
condition there
so first we check about this and now we
talk about spam diagram so we just say
for this pan we say
or spam equal to
element of type
after this span
we
yeah so we're not talking about call
fire
txt
equal to once again
document
dot create text
child
and then last but not least we have to
basically i treat two or
four
i
equal to zero
i is less than
close dot
length
and
i
plus plus
then
close
off type i
you're passing it dot
one click equal to
function
and here we are saying
div
equal
equal to
so
so friends we are almost ready now
because our javascript file is ready
after that we'll be talking about how to
include it in html to take a look well
everybody so we are all set now since we
have our application ready with me js is
really serious is ready now in our
index.html file let me just check
how to apply
this js within my code now so in my
text.html file i'll just go to my at the
bottom of my page
that is called
script
script src
equal to
the name call after js
that's it
okay and let's check about my final
outcome
okay so you can see now the crossbar
automatically appeared
okay with my application let me try to
add another one that is called
welcome
see it is automatically getting added
click you can see it is called strike
that means it is done if i try to click
on this it goes off if i click it here
it strikes click here it is
also working
delete it
click it again it is uncheck or unstrike
so guys that's it so
we are happy like finally we have
finished one of our very important
project which is called total
application
okay so this time we're gonna develop
another very interesting example
using this html
javascript and css together and that is
called working with a quiz application
so one of the very very interesting
project will be developing it from the
scratch and i'm sure that you will enjoy
a lot
so what we will do we'll start creating
a new folder now first of all i'm going
to give the name called
html
quiz
now i'm gonna create a three files
inside this number one i'm gonna say
index.html
index.html
then i need another file that is called
app.css
and the third file i'm going to create
inside this that will hold the script
related part so we are saying script
dot js
so we have total number of three files
ready with us
now from html page we would like to
develop this html tags first
so we'll go to the html and see
so we have got this basic html syntax
ready and from here we will start
working with the div tag first
here onwards div tag
so within my tab tag we would like to
create
another div tag
okay
so the first top-level class
to this particular tip
see we haven't created a css but we
would like to offer some of the css
classes available here so we see the
class equal to container
now we have got another div tag inside
this we will set them
id equal to question hyphen container
question hyphen
container so that is the name or id of
this step
and we say class
equal to height
now within the step tag
we would like to offer some details
but
before that we would like to create some
embedded div tags inside this so we're
going to create another tab tag here
and just have id
equal to
answer
answer hyphen buttons
so that's the id name and we would like
to offer the class also
class equal to
btn hyphen grid see again i'm telling
you these classes we're just creating it
but we would like to use this
in our css
okay so they are just the normal
classrooms we are giving it right now
now inside this dev tag
we want to offer
some more details
now what exactly the details are number
one i would like to offer a few buttons
now
button
so we see a button class
equal to btn
and after that we would like to give the
name called answer one
answer once
so that i can have this button class
copy it three more times
and now we can change
the names to
two
here three
here four so we have total number of
fork answers ready with us dev tag is
getting closed here another tip tag is
getting closed here
and now here
before the last step tag is getting
closed we would like to create another
div tag
now inside this div we say
class equal to controls
that's another div tag so under this tab
we want to offer few more buttons
button here we say button id equal to
start button
start iphone btn
okay and then we say class
class equal to start
hyphen
btn
space
btm
and we say
start here
now just copy this
complete line
and put it again
so
rather than giving the start button
we say
next button and class equal to
next hyphen button
next hyphen button
btn and we will give additional property
called height
and here we give the value called next
let me make this s capital
and
next
two buttons we have created
after this
div tag is getting closed
after that i would like to start another
type tag
and if this tip tag we will offer
class equal to score
okay
and here
we would like to start working with this
pan
and here we will say span
id equal to
right hyphen
answer
or answers i can say
so
after that a dip tag is getting closed
and
that's it and it last
the last step tag is getting closed
which you can see right now we would
like to use the script tag
but one more thing
this drive tag i would like to close
even before
so two tip tags are getting close and
this is another tip type which is closed
at the end
and here we want to include the script
tag
script
src equal to
script.js
that's it our html page is almost ready
let's review
and
yes i can see some standard buttons has
been created
now we would like to look make gives a
better look and feel to this kind of
button cell
complete ui by offering some awesome css
okay everybody so we'd like to start
working with css part now
so to work with the css we have to offer
few things
here
we're providing a route
and with this route some basic settings
we are offering it number one
hyper hyphen hue hyphen neutral
hue
hyphen
hyphen hyphen q
hyphen neutral
the value is giving a score 200
after that we're giving call hyphen
hyphen
q
again
hyphen rom
this value we are giving is
zero
then we are saying hyphen hyphen here
hyphen
correct
145
so these three values we have given
followed by body
in this body we would like to offer few
details number one
hyper hyphen hue
this we are making with the variable
hyphen open you
neutral
the one which we have already declared
okay now we will try to provide padding
so this padding we're giving zero
next property is margin
module will also remain zero
after that display
none
after that not display covers and none
instead it is better we can have
flex
after that width
we are providing width almost hundred
followed by height
so height we are providing is called
once again hundred
okay now we have called justify contents
this justify contents i can say center
perfect going forward
align items
here we can say
center again
now background color
which color you would like to give it so
we can just use this option called hsl
and this will we would like to use this
var
again this in this world we are using
iphone hyphen q
and followed by
100
comma
20
these things and this is style we
wouldn't we would like to use in my
index.html page
so within my head tag
well
in index.html5 how you would like to
refine the styles we always use
link
link
css
so the value is automatically style.css
but we would like to change to app
dot css that's it
now let's see the final outcome
now it looks better
okay so it is only for the background
nothing else it is impacting
now we want to offer
few more things into my css it is only
for the body now we would like to go
ahead with the body dot
correct
body dot correct
we are providing
you
and here we would like to offer
iphone iphone draw
and also sorry not wrong just for
correct
and
we can use
body
dot wrong
body dot round
so same thing i'd like to copy
so rather than saying correct
we're using wrong
well these two properties we have
defined
going forward we would like to start
working for the container
container inside my container i would
like to offer width
basic thing
that we are providing 800 pixels
followed by
max weight
this max would be 80
now going forward background color
background color we are offering
that always looks better
followed by border radius
border radius that we are providing 5
pixels
after this adding
padding will be 10 pixels
followed by box shadow
this box shadow becomes a 0
0
10 pixels
2 pixels
so this is we have applied for the
container and container is used
right over here let's see
okay that looks better
so this is where it comes under my
container
now
we would like to offer the buttons
here in our css
we want to now offer the button colors
so dot
btn
hyphen
grid
well
in index.html file so we have a call
button grid
this button grid we would like to start
from here
beating grid beaten grid display
great
followed by grid
hyphen
template columns
so here we are saying repeat
in this repeat we are saying 2
comma
auto
then we would like to offer the gap
this gap will be the 10 pixels
followed by margin
that will be there 20 pixels
and then zero
this is for my button grid let's see
awesome so that looks pretty nice
now
going forward we would like to apply the
styles of my button
so how my button will looks like in
well button grids we have created it now
we would like to go ahead with the
buttons
so dot btn
followed by the details so
iphone open you
var
will be using neutral
okay
going forward we would like to use
border
so this border we want to use
12
pixels or i would say one pixel
and then solid
and
hsl
values you would like to give it once
again
followed by
100
30 percent
okay so these are the values for
border
followed by background color
so we would like to use the same
details
now we would like to use background
color
so
in background color we will just use hsl
rather than this
so hyphen hue
100
and 50
okay
followed by
border radius
border radius 5 pixels
now
padding
padding
just 5 pixels
and
10 pixels
then color
this color will be white
for sure
and
the outline
outline we are using is none
last option cursor
so cursor we will be using pointer as
you should see
so
these are the details are available
which you want to use it
for my button
now the last option
you want to use it for the button over
dot ptn
dot
or
and for this performer
want to say border color
this watercolor you would like to use
black
that's it let's see
awesome
so this looks pretty nice
as you can see right now here
well
so
this is how my
initial
looks like
okay now i also want to change
this
start button and next button both
so here
we want to use dot
start hyphen btn
and also for
dot
next hyphen pt
common look and feel for both
font size
one
dot five
rem
next font weight
now this font weight i want to give bold
followed by padding
this padding is
10 pixels
and 20 pixels followed by 10 pixels 20
pixels
next cursor
will be as usual pointers
now we want to go ahead with the
controls
with controls reset display
flex
followed by justify contents
just justify content services center
followed by align
items
and here we say center
and
last option which is left is called
height
this height is
a display
none
that's it let's check this out
well
so
this will be
visible to me
so the moment i said start then only the
other buttons will be visible so this is
how my program is
well my css is all set
well let's get start working with the
script part now
this is a major part of your
main
code development so here we will start
working with this const
and here we will say
start
button
equal to
document dot
get element by id and here it will give
the name called
start
hyphen btn
that's the name
like this
i just copy this line
make it available here like people call
start button
we have a call next button
and
here next button
like
here another one
here we change the name
and give the name called
question
container element
container
element
question container element documentation
by id
here we give the name called question
hyphen
question hyphen
container
because this is already there
you see question hyphen container is
already there
we're using
question hyphen container
like this we would like to use one more
and that is called
question element
question
element document good element by id here
will be passing
question
followed by
we want to use
answer button element
answer
buttons
element
answers
or i can say
answer buttons element answer hyphen
buttons
answer hyphen
buttons
so naming convention must be chosen very
carefully
now we will provide
option called shuffle question because
we want every time the questions to be
get shuffled
shuffled questions
shuffle questions
current question index
shuffle questions and current question
index
and we would like to provide one
variable call let
quiz score
equal to
zero
so we created those variables
now
once it is done we want to basically go
ahead and start creating a set of
questions for my application
so here we want to provide the questions
so we say const
questions
const
questions
equal to
eric
first question which i would like to
create it here is called question
now here we will say
javascript framework
so which of these
is a
which one of these servers are which one
of these is a
javascript framework
this is my question now
okay
so i would like to have answers for sure
so here we are providing answers
so what answers we would like to provide
so in this answers the first answer i
can say
like this
here i said text
first will be python
python
okay
python
answer is true or false
correct
false so it will be the false
copy
now let's change the value here i say
django
correct false
third is react
so
i can say true
last i'm keeping it's called
false as usual
so like this we have created
a question
and four answers
okay so we're all set now
so
here after that
we want to create a few more
okay
so once again i would like to bring some
questions now
and related answers
so just copy this
first
so second question
i can say
who's the prime minister of india
so we can have two ounce answers
available
okay
talk about render mode value is called
what true
second we're gonna give the name called
value is called false
so taken the values like this
and we can take one more
just for the demo purpose
so
like here
next equal what is 4 multiplied by 3
i can have many answers
so i'm just making the first is called
six
which is false seconds turn
like that totally we have created
three
okay so we all are set with this
multiple questions
okay
now once it is done we would like to
offer one function here
okay and what that function would be
the function would be nodes called clear
status class
function
clear
status
class
it takes some parameter call element
and here we will say element dot
class list
dot
remove
element dot class list dot remove
correct
and once again i copy the same line
[Music]
so we have two options available
called what
right
and what wrong
now
going forward we want to have
few more functions to be attached there
is only one function attached that's
called clear status class
now we would like to add one more
function here
call
function set
status class
okay and here we pass two parameters now
one is called element
and second score correct
two parameters we are passing it down
element and correct first we are calling
this function called clear status class
is a function which we have created pass
element
followed by we are saying if
correct
then
element
dot
class list dot
add
correct
okay
else
use the same option
what will try to add
wrong here
so this is how we would like to apply
right or wrong
so this is a set status class which we
have it now
followed by the most important function
which you're going to use it right now
here
is called
your
select answer so you have to basically
select the answer so this is a little
bigger function
so let's try to understand function
select
answer
here we'll pass e as in parameter
and from here we will use
const
select selected button
selected button equal to e dot
target
number one
second const
correct
equal to
selected button
dot
data set
select button dot data set dot
correct
now going forward
we'll be calling this
set status class function
in this set status class we'll be
passing
document
dot body
as a first parameter
and
correct
is the second parameter
okay now we're using
array
dot
from
and here in this editor from we're using
answers
button element
dot
children
okay followed by dot
for each here
we're using
this button
as in parameter
now here
what i will do we are using this option
called
set status class
first parameter will be what
a button then
button
dot
dataset
dot
we can give the value call what correct
okay so this is how we are using this
array
now we'll be
utilizing the
main evaluated value called if
shuffle quotient
dot
length
if
shuffle quotients dot length is greater
than
current quotient index
plus 1
then what then we are saying
next button
dot
class list
dot
remove
and here we will say height so this will
be
hidden
okay
else
else condition says what start button
dot inner text
okay start button dot inner text equal
to
restart
okay
and
next is called start button
dot
class list
dot
remove what we need to remove height
part
that's it okay and here we're using this
option call if
selected button
dot
data set
equal to
correct
then
quiz score
plus plus
and
document dot
get element by id
here we are providing
write hyphen
answers
followed by
dot
inner html equal to
quiz
score
so whatever the score will be after
selecting the correct answer
this will be available to the user
okay
now the next thing which we're going to
develop it is basically your reset state
function reset state
function reset state
so what we're going to offer here we are
saying
clear status class
document
dot
body
okay here we are saying
next button dot
class list
dot
add
height
okay
now we are using this while option now
answers button element
dot first child
so here i will be using answers button
element
dot remove child
here we have a call dot remove chart and
here we'll be giving
answers button elements
dot
first child
so these are the functions are used
right now
we haven't called those functions but
we'll be calling those functions one by
one
but this is something which you wanted
to start with
okay
well
reset state is already set
now going forward we would like to start
working with the show questions so that
the user can start seeing the question
we are saying function show question
show question the first parameter will
be question
and
from here onwards we would like to use
the question element
so we have a call question element dot
inner text
equal to
question
dot
question
now followed by questions dot answer
question dot
answers
dot
for each and here i would like to use
we are passing what
answers and parameter
now
here we like to create a button called
const
button equal to
document.
get sorry document.createelement
i'd like to create a button now
okay after that we are saying
button
dot inner text
you to set the value
equal to
answer
dot
text
then
followed by button dot
class list
dot
add here we are
offering
bta
okay now you're saying
if
the condition is
answered dot
correct
if answer is correct
then what
then button
dot
dataset
dot
correct
equal to
answer dot
correct
okay now
the next thing is we are using button
dot
add event listener
attaching the listener to this event
which event
on click event
second parameter will be
select answer
then
answer button element
dot
append child
of what
button
so this is your show questions
followed by what is the next question it
will appear so here we say function
set
next question
next question
here
function
set next question
here in this next question we are just
saying
reset state
the function we are calling it
and saying
show question
and here we are passing this
shuffle questions
and we are passing this current
question index
that is what the sect
next question is offering it to me
now the last function which is left that
is called start game how the game will
start
function
start
game
and here
the main magic begin here we say start
button
dot class list
dot add
and here
height
after that
shuffle questions
equal to
we have called questions
dot
sort
ok here we say
math dot
random
and
five
we're passing this value
okay after that we are saying
current question
index initially we are giving 0 right
now
after that
question
container element which we have already
defined
dot
classlist
dot
remove
height
okay
and then
we're calling
set next question
which is the function we are calling it
and initializing our quiz score
with the value called zero
well start game is
ready
next thing which you to start the cover
button
so here we are saying
start button
dot add event listener
here
in this
on my click event
i will try to call this function
start game
first thing
now next we'll be calling
next button
dot
add event listener
on click
on click
we are using
okay so here we're calling current
question index
current question index
plus plus
and
set next question
that's it
so we are mostly done with our code
script.js we have basically already
initialized there
okay
the values will be
kept automatically
so most of the things are now ready with
us
okay so
our javascript is almost
ready
index.html file is there and app.css is
also ready with us
now let's finally see how my overall
look and feel really looks like it
let's just go here and try to refresh
and check on a button called start
awesome i could see
the first
question appears automatically which of
these a javascript framework
if i select as usual my correct answers
for react
now you can see
is automatically making the rest of them
as a
red and not giving me the next button
now
for the prime minister of india i'm
saying the red moody
great next
and i say
for multiply by 3a12 i said next
and which of those used in mobile up
development flutter
and flask is say flask it says twitter
and now you can see the application
looks perfectly fine
and it gives me the restart now
and that's it so this is how dear
friends your project is now completely
working
and expected as the way it was designed
for when i
once again restart and you can say start
button that is giving me four multiply
by three that means it is one second i
have taken
random question
hello everyone and welcome to the
another very exciting project for our
development in javascript that is known
as call weather pro it is in a
continuation to the series of the
previous project what we have developed
in javascript and this is once again a
very competitive project i'm going to
present to you
which is called weatherpro where i would
like to offer you the real-time weather
application into your browser taken from
the real-time weather applications
okay so let's get started with the new
development of our application which is
called a weatherproof
now once again
compared to the previous project what we
have seen these projects were working
more kind of static in nature where like
you talk about snake game you talk about
tick tock toe or other type of games
like an online quiz where the data was
very much static in nature but we were
presenting the data in the form of more
dynamic in nature this time
this project we are presenting you while
connecting with the real-time weather
application where i'll be making a one
rest api call or else you can see
asynchronous call and since javascript
is working as a what appear asynchronous
nature you will be enjoying the way how
the javascript can communicate with your
back end
load the data and represent the records
in a very very beautiful manner
so once again we would need this
vs code editor only just to
develop our code and once again
for developing our presentation part
we'll be using html for
formatting part will be using css and to
make some dynamic update we'll be using
javascript now here
i'm gonna create a new file name called
index
dot html
apparently i just want one more that is
called app.css
and another file we need it
and that is called
your js file so we are saying
app
dot gs5
so total number of three files are
available to us i'll start working with
an html now and here
we'll start
with this
html templates
now here first of all i would like to
load my css file which i do not have
right now but certainly i can use it
okay so i can just say link
area
equal to
style sheet
and href
equal to
app dot
css
well that is my css location
now i just want to create
so
this link real i would better use
inside my head tag that will be the more
convenient place
now in my body
i want to have some of the div tags and
there i can decide where the weather to
be displayed so i can just start with my
div tag now
with my div tag i say
class equal to
i can just create a class which later on
i can offer
different size of or different type of
style so we can say container
so we're saying div class equal to
container now within a div tag we like
to use another dev tag which is a nested
one
so this step will have another class
called
class equal to
app hyphen
title
i have hyphen title
in the same div tag we can use
this a typical paragraph tag
and here we say weather info
whether
info
now after this paragraph tag
we want to have a text box because i
would expect a client to enter the
detail on which city or for which city
he or she would like to get the details
so we can say input
sub properties like id
equal to
search
second type
equal to
text
next placeholder
equal to
enter
the city
next
autocomplete i'm saying autocomplete
off
the reason because i do not want the
previous value user can see in this case
we can say autocomplete
oh i do not want any autocomplete in
this
okay
now
here it is getting close now
after that we also want the locations
for that i may use some of the png files
and all but right now
i just want to display the details
of the user
like which city he belongs to and
accordingly i can display the records
right in your application
so for that i really need some of the
div tags once again where i can display
the details of this particular city so
i'm just having this only text box let
me go and go back and check
how it looks
so i have a call enter the city so here
i'll be picking up the city and
somewhere down the line i have to
display the record so
after this div
we can also have some of the locations
to be displayed
so
we can just use the notifications
and
also the location where you want the
details to be displayed
okay so we can use div class
class equal to temperature value
temperature hyphen
value
okay so div plus equal to temperature
hyphen value
inside this i will be using paragraph
tag and here in my paragraph i'll say
iphone
and
this degree centigrade or whatever you
want to display it here
and we'll use
a spandex within this and show
in degree centigrade
that's it
and if you want to define the
temperature description
after this dev tag we can use another
day of tag
and inside my tip tag
i can define the temperature description
okay so we can say table
class equal to
temperature hyphen description
temperature hyphen description
and within this i'll be using what
a paragraph tag
here i'll be displaying
all the description
so right now that is the only thing
which i want let me check
okay so it's here right now
so now let me try to
collect the value from the client
and perform some javascript tag
within this
okay now it's time for us to go back and
try to bring some of the css features
into my code now
now few things i would like to say is i
have basically downloaded some fonts
which i would like to use it in my
application and i also have some of the
icons which i would like to use during
my application presentation so there are
some png files are there which i have
downloaded from the internet just to
bring more beautiful experience towards
my application development
well this is another background image
which is called bg.jpg which i would
like to
make it as a background of my
existing
application so i'll start with my css
and see how this css can really bring
some new features to my code well
first thing i need to have a call font
face so to make this font face we are
using this statement name call here at
the rate
font phase
and
i like to use font family
font family i'm using
mod select
okay
it is already there with me monster
and the url
what is looking forward for so we are
saying src
url
and i'm saying under the
font so we have a file called ttf
okay that is called
bold.ttf that is the file which is there
with me
next thing
so
for every
location i want to use the font family
font iphone
family i want to use same
monster
and the next thing is like in my body
so in my body few details like
background image
i need url
and in this url we can say
bg.jpg
in my background
next thing is background color
that i needed steel blue
then i need height
i'll say 500 pixels
next your background position
this i needed is center
next is your background repeat
i say no repeat
next is your background size
this i'm saying cover
this is my body part
okay let's check
okay
looks awesome now you see this now this
is how my weather it was looking like it
they can see like the background looks
awesome now now
next thing we required a container
so we are saying
dot
container
container we say width
width 50
next background color
we're just using white
next we need it is your align itself
that will be
center
display
if we block
margin
so in margin we can say 100 pixels
after that border radius
border radius we are saying 10 pixels
and then padding bottom
this padding bottom will be 50 pixels
then box shadow
this box should be giving 5 pixels
10 pixels
20 pixels
and black
this will be with my container so
index.html file we have called container
now
okay looks awesome now
so this is where exactly the details
will be
okay
now
after this css
container we have used
we can talk about called title you can
say
hyphen
title
inside this we will say width
will be 100
then
height
will be 150
pixels
then border radius
10 pixels
10 pixels
then we need display
display we need flex
and then we need align items
this align items which is saying center
next we need justify content
that will be the justify content which
is centered
then flex direction
would be column
so this option we're using for our tool
name called what
app hyphen
title
okay so here in my index.html file we
have called div class equal to what our
python title equal to weather info let's
check
okay
so
this is another
we have used that is called app title
now we need to use it for paragraph
inside my app title what should be
alignment for my paragraph
so here
this app title
tab title space p
but it should be the class so we are
saying dot
and there also we have to use what
dot because both have to be the class
type
okay
so here
you can see now
there is a difference i forgot to add
dot and now you can see it looks better
comparatively
paragraph
so once again in my paragraph i will be
having texture line
center padding
i want 15 pixels
then i need margin
margin would be 0
and auto
followed by font size
font size
this i'm saying is called 1.2
yeah
this position then color
we're giving hash
value
call 333
okay
now here
[Music]
okay so some changes in a paragraph
well going forward for the search
because if you remember
we have an index.html file we have a
call id code to what
search so here in my
app.css i have to use
hash
search
okay so this search conditions i want to
use it
now
inside my search i need few things one
is called display
i need block
after that i need margin left
auto
margin right
auto
width
i'm looking forward for 5 pixels
height
that i'm looking forward for 20 pixels
then
border radius
i'm looking for four five pixels
then outline
that's called none
let me say border
okay
in this border what we can say three
pixels
let's paste solid
okay and once again
see
that's what
let's check
so this is actually the text box
so once again search you use display
block
margin
left auto margin right auto width 5
pixels
width
padding sorry one thing i said
padding should be 5 pixels
width
should be 40 percent that's why it is
smaller with it will be
40
let's check
yeah that's look better now
okay so my text box is now ready
i'll be having some of the details for
the notifications also
so what i need for the notifications
let me go back and create a class for
notification so dot
notification okay
now in notifications i would like to
give some value called background color
and in this background color we are just
giving white
and after that we using display
and we're saying
none
this is for notification and followed by
the notification
we're talking about the same
notification
okay and followed by
its paragraph
we are giving the color first of all we
are saying color
color is basically red
okay pulse if you want to give maroon
it will come
and
after this
the next property we are taking is
called font size
one size we are taking is called 1.2
am
followed by margin
margin we are taking is zero
after that texture line
center
id
10 pixels
0.
so this is for notification fee and then
the weather container
okay in my weather container i will say
width
hundred percent
sorry
yeah with 100 percent height
height we're giving 260 pixels
or up to you 250 pixels if you want
background color
this background color we are giving is
called once again white
and followed by margin top
20 pixels
20
pixels
this is for weather
container now for the weather icon
whether hyphen
icon
i'm saying width
is 100
and height
128 pixels
just to give in a better look
now the next thing we're using dot
weather
icon icon
space
img here we can display
none
and uh
sorry display node none is another block
display block and margin
giving zero
space auto
there's four icon and location icon if i
want to give
then location hyphen
icon
this location icon i can save with same
width height
so
width i'm giving is 100
then
height i'm giving 40 pixels
and then we give this option called
padding
then take pixels
so it's for location icon
now
followed by location icon we are also
giving call location icon img
okay dot
location hyphen icon space img
here we're giving the value called
display block
display block width
we're giving is called 22 pixels
and then we're looking forward for
margin
margin would be 10 pixels
and
auto
then cursor
so cursor will be pointed for sure
and then we required padding
padding looking forward for 5 pixels
followed by border
border we are looking forward for steel
glue
steel blue
solid
and 2 pixels
then border radius
quarter
radius
we're looking forward for 10 pixels
and followed by your color
steel blue
so these are the look and feel we have
to basically offer it for my
current application which i yet to
discuss in my
next development
then i'll be having some small small
properties here
okay
and those properties are nothing but to
give you the details of
like
temperature values so we say dot
temperature hyphen value
okay this temperature hyphen value we
can give it
is 100
and height
making this called 60 pixels
okay this is for temperature value let
me copy this again
and
i'm giving this temperature value space
paragraph
here
i am going to give padding
0
margin
0
then color
which color you're looking forward for
so we can just say dark
gray okay for any color which you're
looking forward for it's up to you now
but if you want you can change the color
also to another one we're giving this
call hash
293
okay two five 1
okay that is a more perfect color for
this
development now font size
4 em
then followed by texture line
and once again center
so this is for
temperature value
b
we haven't used much
but you can see now it looks somewhere
in much more better way
okay that is called temperature value p
then you can use a temperature value
span
here
dot
temperature value span
space
spam
and here
we give the additional dot
now within this spam
say color
once again save
and
font size
[Music]
this is for
span
and in the same temperature description
paragraph you can use it
dot
temperature iphone description
description space b
so this will be having the padding
of 8 pixels
then margin
0
followed by color
same color the one which we have used it
earlier
after this color just a texture line
center font size
1.2 you
this is for temperature description
okay
last which is available for your
location
so let me give the location now dot
location
is space three
here we can say
margin
zero
then padding
zero
then color
same color i would like to use
after this color texture line
and font size
and copy
text align center and here we'll be
giving some different value called 0.8
okay and last which is really left with
called tip
in that
relative
here position
i will be using
absolute
top
from top i'm using 600 pixels
okay and right
i'm using
120 pixels
that's it
okay so all set
[Music]
so you can see now
here we have to basically offer the
details how my pictures will be taken
so this is what my css now will be
applying some of the css into my
applying the css into my html to see how
it really looks like it if getting your
learning started is half the battle what
if you could do that for free visit
scale up by simply learn click on the
link in the description to know more
okay so we have seen some of the css
classes we have introduced
in my html
we have used this uh
autocomplete equal to off then we have
used classical temperature
value
okay if we just check carefully we have
used this temperature and there we have
used temperature hyphen
value
but before that we would like to use
some other properties too
okay after this autocomplete equal to
off we want to use
another dev class
okay before my previous date tag is
closed here so here after this we would
like to use another div tag
div
here in my div
i'll say
class
equal to
location hyphen icon
location hyphen
icon
okay and here i'll be using img
src equal to what under
icons i'm using the file name called
location
dot png
and alt equal to we leave it as it is a
blank
okay
now here the div tag is getting closed
okay
now there's another div tag is getting
closed here
so two div tags are closed after that
we'll be using another div class for
notification here dev
class equal to notification
dev class equal to notification and this
step tag is getting close right here
okay now another div for the weather
condition
another div tag and here we say
class equal to weather hyphen condition
whether hyphen what
a condition
or i can say whether iphone container
whichever so i can say
weather hyper container
under this
weather container i like to use
another tip for weather icon
tip for
class equal to weather hyphen icon
weather hyphen icon
and within this
i want to use another img
src equal to once again
icons
slash unknown
dot png
okay div tag is getting closed
so after this dev tag is closed i'm
gonna use
um temperature value
so the temperature value is anyways used
here if you see
raising call temperature value after the
first step tag is closed
you see like temperature value we have
used
after that the paragraph tag
and the temperature hyphen
description b
after the p that the div tag is getting
close
okay
and after this we are using div class
equal to location
so we want to use
div
plus equal to
location
and
within this location
we want to use one more paragraph tag
with this hyphen
after this paragraph exists close
this tip tag this tip tag
and another tip tag three div tags are
closed
captioning not available
js
that's it let's check
great my application looks pretty
beautiful now
so
this i
want to be display only when i don't
find the weather at the location anymore
so look and feel is absolutely
good and now i'll start working on my
javascript front
okay so let's go ahead and start writing
our javascript code
so in just javascript code first of all
i need few things
uh first thing what i need is call
individual elements or individual
properties of my application i need cost
icon element
i can remain equal to
document dot
query selector
and i'll be using the name
called
dot
weather hyphen
icon
okay
now
copy this
location
icon
here we are saying
dot location
hyphen
icon
now
next
i need it is called temp element
here i'm using
the property call dot
temperature hyphen
value space
p
next we're looking forward for
desc element which is called description
here we're giving temperature hyphen
description
hyphen
temperature has been description space
dot
p
then location element
okay we need location element and we use
dot location
space b
next we need notification element
notification element and here we to give
the call notification
notification
so four properties we have taken so we
are selecting all the elements
next
statement what we're going to talk about
see this statement is all about
selecting the elements the next step we
are talking about call
get the input field so we are saying var
input
equal to
document dot
get element by id you'll be given the
name called
search which is the name or id of my
text box let
city equal to
blank
next we're going to give score let
latitude
equal to 0.0 we are initializing this
value and let
longitude
let longitude equal to again 0.0 so we
are getting the coordinates right now
so this is how to get the input fields
next we want to apply the events here we
are saying input
the variable
dot
add event listener
the variable what we're talking about
which event list will be talking about
key up
okay
up
and what even do you want to apply so we
are saying
function
with a parameter name called what
event
and now we would like to attach the
logic now
we send if
what is the condition
event
dot
key code
equal to
13.
okay
then
that means number 13 is basically the
enter
see the key code means for 13 13
represent the enter keyword so even dot
key code equal to what 13 so here
same event
dot
preview
default why we're using this because i
do not want my page to be get
refreshed just to avoid this we're using
this
and after that we are saying city
equal to input dot
[Music]
value
now
you'll be using this another function
because i do not have function created
otherwise i have to call the function
name called get search weather and be
passing this as a parameter so we're
going to get
search
whether i do not have this function i
yet to create this
and pass it here as a what
city and we say
console.log
city whatever we are basically printing
it
okay
so that is the first thing
later on we need to get the data so to
get the data we are just using this
variable name called const
whether
equal to
const whether equal to
curly braces
after that we are saying
weather
dot
temperature
equal to this
and which temperature conditions you
want i'm saying unit
of type what
celsius
i want in a celsius put it in a double
quotes
okay
so next statement will be
getting the details in kelvin i'm saying
cost kelvin
equal to value of the kelvin is about
273
and after that
conc ultimately what we need is
we need to interact with our backend api
from where i will
get or receive the updated weather
applications
okay
now
to get this i'll be using one very
popular api here that is known as called
openweathermap.org
this is a very very popular app
which
people use it and it's used and trusted
by many companies
clear
so here
what you can do this
open method map.org
so you need to basically first of all
get yourself registered because if any
third party application is interacting
it requires that particular
unique
api key
since
as a visitor you really can't get it
unless you register yourself so i have
my api key with me so i'll go here
it'll ask me for the registration
so i already signed up so if you're not
you need to sign it there's an api key
for me which i need to copy
and this api key i'll be using it in my
project
so i just use
this property called const
to paste my key here
okay
after this paste in the key but make
sure that you rather using my key you
use your key otherwise this application
sometimes won't work
so i'm basically trying to use this tool
name called geolocation
i'm saying if
geolocation
okay again
navigator
navigator is you know there's a browser
object model element
so here we're using
navigator
okay navigator dot
geo location
dot
get current position
in which i'll be passing the first
parameter name convert
set position
and second parameter will be show error
in case
if any error is received
okay
else
in the sales condition what would happen
i'm using this statement name called
notification
element
you see this notification element dot
style
dot
notification remain dot
get elements by class name but i don't
need this rather i will use what the
style
dot display equal to
block
then i will be using the same
notification element dot
inner html
equal to
you're gonna use a paragraph
saying what browser
doesn't
support
so you have to enable the correct
location of use
okay that's where exactly
so after that we have to basically set
what the user position
okay if the user is having that support
available
so after this
location we'll be just using another
function here
function
set
position
it will i'll be taking
position as a parameter
and take latitude
latitude equal to
position dot
chords chord for coordinate star
latitude
okay like that
longitude
equal to
what position dot
chords
dot
longitude
after this we'll be using this function
called what
get
weather so this get weather will be the
function in which you will be passing it
so this function will be soon seen
i'll be having it defined below but as
of now we are just saying
get weather and in which this we are
passing
latitude and
longitude
that's it
so we have this function name called
what
set
position in which will be passing all
the values
okay at the same time
i will be using one more function here
that is called function
not function in fact
i would like to use location
icon the one which you define at the top
part
add event listener which even listener
i'm saying
one click
second
function
which take
even doesn't parameter
and inside this i'm saying console just
to confirm whether the records have been
taken console.log
hey
just
and
we say get with it
okay once again we'll be passing what
latitude and longitude same i just copy
this
and paste it here
okay everyone so we have written till
here when i try to run my browser
so i should see there is a message name
called show error is not defined
but obvious because this message what
we're writing it here is called show
error
okay this
as a function as a parameter it is not
defined let me define this function
called show error so we are saying
function
show error which take
error as in sorry just take
error is in parameter
now in this we are using
notification
dot
style
dot display equal to what
block
after that once again
notification element dot
inner html
equal to what
we're just using this as a paragraph
and here
error
dot
message
okay and after that
paragraph
so this is how we are basically writing
it down
and now
see it is immediately asking you
to know your location okay if i say
allow
that's okay
okay so nothing
you can see now it is saying get weather
is not defined because right now the
moment i click on this
so it is saying like get weather is not
defined but obvious because i told you
this get weather function i need to
develop so
i get to develop this function called
get weather but before that i'm using
another function called function
get search weather
get
search weather in which i'll be passing
what
city name
now what exactly my api will be in case
if i want to make a call i will be using
let
api equal to
now the url will be what
http
colon double forward slash api dot
open
weather
map dot
org now open weather map dot org
slash
data
slash two point
sorry two point
five that is a version slash
weather
okay question mark
i have to take the city dynamically so
i'm saying weather
question mark queue
equal to
here
we're using what city
and
we're using ampersand
app id
equal to the one app id we have used it
already
okay what is that
that key
so that is the key
which you've already written so that app
id we are passing it right over here
okay q equal to ct and i have id equal
to this
now after that to make the restful api
call i'll be using one independent or
by default api which is available to us
that is called what
fetch
okay so if you just check this fetch
it is basically a take requestion form
and give you the what a promise response
so return type will be the promise type
in this fetch i'll be passing what
the api
and we'll be using dot
then that means if the request
is successful using function
function
response
then function is a parameter response we
are saying let data equal to
response dot i'm expecting the responses
type of what json
using json and return what
data
so it'll be returning data back to me
now
if it is
successful then what then i'm saying dot
then once again it is chaining
again
function
again
data and parameters
now in this case we'll be getting lot of
things
i'm saying
whether
okay dot
temperature it's a predefined dot value
equal to i'm using what
math
dot
floor inside this we are passing what
data dot
main
dot temp it is a predefined property we
are receiving it now hyphen
kelvin whatever the kelvin value is
basically we are taking score 273 on the
top
minus
kelvin
followed by
another property what
weather dot
description
weather dot
description
equal to we're using
data dot
weather
zeroth position because it contains lot
of data but i will be taking what
description out of that
then
weather dot
icon id
whether dot icon id equal to
data
dot
weather
dot
icon then
dot icon then once again
weather dot
city
okay equal to
data dot
name
after this
weather dot country
dot
equal to
data
dot
sys dot
so these are the properties i have it
right now with me
okay and once i received all the
property i'll be using dot
then
i'll be using one function
and i will say what
display there is no function written
called display weather but i'm gonna say
there's one function name called
display
weather this function i yet to write
but this function just putting it here
okay
now this is closed
after that
since i need to get a weather from the
api provider
so i have to also pass what the latitude
and longitude which i'm receiving it
from the client because
here i just want to have two things
the properties as well as whether both
and both i'll be using it one by one
okay so here
we have kept this get search weather and
now i'll be calling one more function
after this logic and i'm giving the name
called function
getweather
okay it takes two parameter one is
called what latitude
and thing is called
longitude so we have two things called
latitude and
longitude
and here i'm using this property called
what let
api equal to
once again
if you remember uh
i have used this statement i'll just
copy the same
and
pass it here
but challenge would be this time
i will not be passing city name because
that two options are available either
you type the city name or else you click
on the icon and let your application
identify the location which you belong
to
so after this feather question mark
here i will not be using queue i'm using
what
led
equal to
latitude
okay
and we're using
and
hello in
equal to
we're using logitech
okay and app id equal to what key so
this is the variable which we have it
now okay now
similar thing which we have used it on
the top
okay called fetch api
so i just copy this same fetch api again
because i really don't want to waste
time on keep on typing the code when we
know it very well it can be similarly
done i just copy and
paste it here
so the same fetch api
dot then response data equal to
response.json return data then
whether the temperature method flow says
country dot display weather so we have
used the same thing here and after that
we have to use the last function here
that is called display weather
display
weather
and here in my display weather i can use
what
i can element dot
inner html equal to
i'll be using
img
src
equal to
icons
slash
dollar
and we'll be passing what whether
okay dot
icon id
okay
dot
png
okay so
that we are basically putting it here
dot png and after that it is closing
that
okay and this icon we also need to close
here
rather than closing this i'll be closing
that and
this i'll be closing it here
now
we'll be using top element
sorry temp element
template
dot
inner html
equal to what
we'll be using this dollar
feather dot
temperature
dot
value
okay
and
after this value we can just use
this asterisk side
the one which i told you okay and use
spam
spam
okay next we are using call talk element
so we have that sorry dac element
we have
dec element dot
inner html equal to
weather dot
description
and last but not least location
element dot
inner html
equal to
what
i'll be using once again this
and here
weather dot
city
comma
dollar
weather dot
that's it
these two properties we have to use it
and we're all done let's check with my
code
if i get any error
now
allow
so
awesome you can see now
27 broken clouds globe undefined that's
perfectly fine intercity
you can see awesome beautifully it is
showing you
the conditions it's saying smoke 28
degree centigrade and not let me put
another city here i'm going to say
called pulley
awesome your application is working
perfectly fine
and
let's see one more
i would say
awesome and now we are planning to
develop one very special game for you
in javascript and now it's time to talk
about another very interesting game that
is known for tic tac
tic tac toe is
world's favorite game we have already
played a lot in our childhood days and
still my favorite game so i have decided
to basically offer you this tic-tac-toe
game
developed in javascript html plus css
which can create something really very
great effects for the end users so let's
go and start developing our next game
that's called tic tac toe
so in this tech tactile i will start
working with creating a folder called
tick tag and inside this i'm going to
create a new
file name called index
dot html
now here onwards the same thing
i'll be creating this html tags
and now here onwards
we want our some classes for headers and
footer
but so we're going to create some dev
tag now
so in this div tag
i'll be creating some of the tags
in which the css class will be applied
so we are just going to create a classes
for encourages use those classes but
we'll create it later on so just go
ahead and create those so we are saying
do
okay
so now this point onwards is my first
div tag inside this i'll keep my h1 tag
and under this h1 i will be offering
some of the headings which will be
useful
to contain some necessary information
with regards to this game so tip here we
say
h1
and inside this h1 it gives the message
called class
equal to header
and here i'll give the name call
is a tic tac token
after this div class
yeah here we will start working with our
form tag
within my form tag i will start my div
after div tag i will use
label
so label for player one
or else i can say player one and inside
this let's give the name call
layer
label is closed
and
after this label will start working with
our input tag
input
now in this input what are the details i
need first i need call type equal to
text number one second
placeholder equal to enter name
next name
equal to player1
next we want id
equal to
player1
and then
any class if i want to apply
anyways we're gonna close this this is
my first text box
and
same thing i would like to create for my
another one
so the first dev type we have used let
me go and create another tip tag
in this div tag i'll use the same label
copy the same
paste it here
and this is for player 2.
so we have this
two players with me and after this div
tag
i'll offer the submit button now
input typically submit
start game
now the form tag is closed here
dev tag is also closed
so
you want the div tag to be closed or
before that it's up to you now
so here we have a called div class
whichever we have taken so if you want
you can basically put it later or before
whatever
so we will basically form that with this
so form tag is there later on you can
just show some containers where the
details will be visible to me
so here after the form tag
let me try to offer but first check that
is really working fine
so here
yeah we have this option called enter
name internet after the stick tag tool
so
yeah so here the details we have taken
input applicable text and input
applicable text
okay so two values we are taking now and
accordingly we will go ahead now finally
after the form tag
we would like to start with working with
the tape tag again
div
and inside this div
i says i haven't created any css classes
so those we can use it little later on
but let's have
this div
and inside this step i would like to use
one more tip type
okay and here we want to use one more
div tag
so inside this div we will be using one
more div tag
so in this div we can just give the
value called data id equal to zero
id equal to
zero it's just the value we're passing
it
the div tag is getting closed
fine so
that's how we want it now
so here
the first step tag is closed like that
we can create another data id so 0 1 2
total number of three we want to create
it so i want to create 0 1 2 3 4 5 like
this
so the way we have created here
for this div let's go and create one
more div tag
id equal to
one
two
three options we have it now
okay like that i can keep on creating
the others also
too
three
four
five so zero one two three four five
total number of five we have created
one more i would like to create it down
here for six
there'll be no difference because we
haven't changed anything here
okay
so the div tag is getting closed here
okay
and
that's it
and if you want to create a some clear
border button that you can basically
offer it a little later on
but here
we can use one more div
and here we see
div
div classical relative
and within this step tag i can use
any image type if i want
so i just leave it as it is
and after this
i can create one more div type
and inside this another tip
okay
and
under this i'm going to create
a button
okay and in this button
we'll be having some value
okay we can secure the volume called
replay
this button is created and now we can
create a clear board
span
and here is a clear board
that's it
okay so here
it's just
a small game i want to develop it
better
now there's no user interface has been
used so this user interface will be
using it later on by offering them a
pure
look and feel so that you know it gives
me more better look when your
application will start
but most importantly i need to start
working with a javascript part where the
logic will get calculated here
okay so
we want to start with the javascript so
let's get included the javascript with
my code
so here
i can see here
script tag
script
equal to
now file i haven't created so let it be
as it is
that's it so this is my script tag and
let me try to include my
style cheat also
so
i just say
link
real quick style sheet
and give the name called
css though i haven't created but i'm
giving it
okay
that's it
so we have taken
this html into our
consideration now we'll be creating this
css as well as the javascript
to make this example complete
well we are ready with our html now it's
time to basically go back and spend time
on our javascript we're going to create
a new file now with the name called
app.js
and inside this we will start writing
the logic with our main application
okay now the first thing is how we're
going to start now
yeah
so
first thing what we need to do is we
need to attach window
dot
add event listener
and when the window will load some logic
should happen so i'm saying load
second is the name of the function
so the name of the function perhaps does
not exist but i can give the name called
which i'm gonna create it shortly
now here first of all let me try to
create a game board i'm saying let
gameboard
equal to now let me have some of the
values because it is eight digit
so we just make it
like that
and one more
for making it nice
okay
so that's how
we're going to create it now
okay now this is all empty right now
after that we're going to create let
turn
just a new variable
equal to
0
what this is it keep tracking if x or
zero player its turn
like which player turns it to b so just
it is trying to measure it i'm saying
let
winner equal to
false
okay now let's go and create the player
so
create
player how are you going to create a
player we say const
player equal to
what we're gonna pass
name
okay equal to
now inside this we can say name equal to
name
next we say return
name
that's it
okay after that i'm defining let
here
x equal to
player
with the empty value
and again
player
y
equal to
there is an empty value now let's try to
initialize the app
okay
initialize
now inside this initialize the app we're
going to create a new function
function
app
and inside this we're going to create a
variable likewise saying that
input feed
equal to first of all
document dot
get element by id
here
we're gonna take
the
class name of this particular text field
so we are saying input
hyphen
field
okay
dot
focus
okay now after this we have to say const
add players
[Music]
equal to once again
document
dot
get element by id let me just give the
name called player form
okay next we are saying
pad
player
okay dot
add event listener we want to attach the
event
on which event
submit event
and what logic
add
players
okay
after that once the players are added we
are saying
let replay
replay button equal to once again
document
sorry yeah
document part
get element by id or rather i will say
document.queryselector
document. query selector
replay type
btl
okay
just the name we are basically taking
that
and here we
say sorry
replay button
dot
add event listener
which even i want to say
click
ok that is the first event second
reset board
reset
board
that we are basically passing that
okay
now
this is the initial case which we have
it
now beyond that i will add
this is the place what we have added and
right not slides to add the players so
this is how we have initialized after
that let's
add
plates
how to basically add the players here we
have to just define the function
add
players
okay it will take
event as a parameter
and say event
dot
prevent
prevent default this present default
will try to prevent
the default
you know
behavior which is submitting to we get
avoided and now here we say if
this
dot
player
one so we just define the property
called player one
if this dot player one dot what
value
okay
is blank
okay or
just start
play two
sorry
let's start
player 2
now i just want to find it out its value
also
value
black
then what i should do
in this case i'm saying alert
you
must
enter
name
for
each
page
the user has to add the values and after
that
return
okay
now the next thing is like we would like
to select the players in this inside
this by saying cost
layer
form
container
again
const play from controller container
equal to
document
dot
query selector
document a query selector here we will
just pass the value call
enter
hyphen
okay now we say cost
boardman equal to
document
dot once again
query selector
dot
classlist
dot class list dot
add here we're giving the name forward
height container
right
list dot
remove
height
hyphen
okay so we've basically taken that
and after this what i will do i'll just
say player
x
dot name
equal to
this dot
player 1
dot
value
okay this for player x copy this
player y
two
and after that
that's it so we have done it now
so
we'll be calling other functions one by
one but that is the first thing which we
have implemented
well so
add player function is added right now
and uh after this add player we have to
basically call
one more that is called which returns
the current player so i'm saying return
current player
and here what i will do is just write
function
and here we say
current
player and in this current player what
we will do is
we will say return
turn
just variable
okay percentile
2 we're just adding it with this
0
okay if it is
then
x
turn i'm telling you
okay or else
so we're adding like the current player
who says the current tail right now
well
after this adding the return current
player we're gonna add another function
that is known as call rate of the
current player return current player is
having this value and after that we need
to say
resize the square in event browser is
resized
once again if the browser is getting
resized automatically the square size of
your
tic tac toe should also get increased so
we just say
resize
squares
and here we're gonna save this option
equal window
dot
add
event listener
now we have a call option called resize
here
and the second parameter what we are
passing is called on
resize
okay on resize
now let's try to add it
after this we are writing this function
called
function
on
resize that is the functioning for me
the one which we are passing into the
second parameter
we are saying let
all cells
equal to
document
dot
query selector all
in this we are passing
board underscore
cell
okay and then we're using another option
called what let
cell height
equal to
all cells
with the position
okay dot
of
set width
or
set width
after that we are saying
all cells
dot
for each
here we are passing
cell
and after that we are using cell
dot
style
dot
height
equal to now he'll be using this
backtick and use this
dollar sign
and say
cell
height
and that to you know pixel
so this will be taking the dynamic
values
okay that's it that's it over
now we have to just launch our build
board
now
billboard
build
board so how we gonna build our board
now for this we are saying function
billboard
and inside this billboard we will see
this option called let
reset
container equal to
document dot
once again query selected
and pass the value call dot reset
okay and after that we are saying
reset container dot
class list
dot remove
and we are passing the value call
reset hyphen
hidden
this value and after that
we may call some other type of functions
also okay so for those functions i can
say first will be called on
resize
after that we are calling
add cell click listener
but i do not have that function with me
with these functions we need to create
it by our own
okay so we will just leave those for a
time being let's go back and create
another functions now so we just want to
write another event with self click
event for play to attempt to make move
so
here we're trying to say
cell
click
event
for
player 2
attempt
to
make move
now this function need to create it so
we just say function now
we just say function and give the name
of the function
to make move now
function
make move
it takes
give it as a parameter
and here we are saying console.log
and say enter
now let's go back and try to check
another condition that is called let
current cell
equal to
because you have to read the value from
there and here we are saying what
event dot
current target
sorry
even dot
current target dot
first element child
okay dot
data set
dot
id
so we're reading these values
after that we use another variable
called
sell to
add
token
now here we are typing document
dot query selected
and here
you know using backtick
i'm using this value called
data hyphen id
okay equal to
here we are using
once again in a single quotes
dollar
current cell
okay
so this value we are taking it like that
after that we are using this situation
called if
cell
to
add token dot
inner html
exterminatory mark
blank
once again if cell to add
token dot inner html
equal to blank
then what next
so cell to add token
dot inner html
equal to blank then what you should do
i'm saying console
dot
log
and give the value the one which you
want
okay
so
in this console.log what value we can
give it
cell to add
token we have it it is taking this value
to the current set dot inner html
console.log
and inside my console.log we can set
this
cell
is
already
taken
so values are already taken for this and
now we will be
returning those values
after that we will be using else
condition
and here we use once again if
current player
okay
is x
then we'll be using this option called
cell
see we have this property option
available called send to active
consuming cell to add token
okay dot
text content equal to
current player
okay and we say
game board
the one which you have created pass in
this game mode
this value call
current cell
and in this correct cell value will be
equal to
x
okay
else
we can say
send
to add token dot
text content
equal to
current player
okay and say
game board
current cell
equal to
like this
okay so here we are adding the values
like that
so it is closed after that we can just
use the function name for
is winner to check whether the user is
winner or not so we are saying
is
winner
okay and
after that we are
saying turn
let's press
after that we are saying
change
we do not have the function name called
change board header names
okay so it's just like that we're giving
it so as usual we can leave this
function for a time being
and uh we'll call this little later on
so
leave it as a full time name
okay so your function is now ready
so the next thing what we need to check
whether
it is tie or not
okay so we are saying function
check
if
i
we're just taking the function
whether it is game is tie or not so here
we say
if
the condition is turned
greater than seven
alert
game
over
okay we can say game over first we can
say our type
okay
well after that we are saying winner
function
is winner
now what we will check is we will check
const
wedding sequences
winning sequences
and here sorry
here
we are having this array and having the
different conditions associated we say 0
1
2 probability we are checking it
and then i just copy it
well using 0 1 2 and here is saying
3
4 five
six
seven
eight
and zero three six again
zero 3
6
and once again 1 4 7
4
7
and next we have a call 258
eight
then we are checking the value zero for
it
eight
and one more last option we'll put is
called two four six
six so these conditions we are adding it
now
after this array we can say
varying sequences start
for each
and give the name call winning combos
winning
combos
and inside this varying compound we are
giving let
cell 1 equal to
varying combos position 0
then
copy
and paste three times
cell two
cell three
and here we get the other call what one
two
three buttons we're giving it and after
that
we're checking the condition
let's say
if
and here the conditions you're checking
what exactly that will be for the game
board using
game board
set
one
current player
sorry
current player
ampersand time percent
come down
game board
cell 2
i just want to copy this the same line
and paste it multiple times
now here
we are checking the condition for set 2
and cell 3
and
cell 3
and
after that
we're starting the position
so after that
we're starting the position call
recording this condition call
call sense
const
sense
and then equal to
document.
query selector
query selector
all
and here let's select the position dot
board
underscore
okay
then after that we will be using
cells
dot
for each
cell
and inside this what we are passing we
are saying
let
cell id equal to
cell dot
first
element child
okay dot
data set
dot
id
so this is the value which you are
basically adding it now and we're using
one more if condition
pressing if
cell id
now we're talking about call cell id
equal to
cell one
or
cell id
cell 2
or
salary equal to
so 3
and in that case we can use
cell dot
class list
dot
add
and get the name board
just give the class name
winner
so here we'll be giving the winner and a
part of that we can use the other
conditions too
okay so here it is
adding the value and now let's say
let
current player equal to
document.
get element by id
so you can basically define it so
current player you want so we can use
the current player or whichever
conditions you want so here we use what
the cell winner
now
small change rather than using correct
layer we can use
the current
layer text
the new variable we are creating it
current player text document dot rather
than saying get element by id
we can say
query selector
and in this query selector will be given
the value
by saying dot board
player
and that
query selector
value whichever you given this let me
try to put it a
parenthesis
like this
okay now here we just check
if current player
x
then what
then in this case we can say
current player whatever the value we are
using current text
dot
inner html
equal to
now we can define the value whichever
you want to
operate
we just use a condition called div
class equal to
okay so we are saying congratulations
okay and here you say
congratulations
along with
dollar sign
and here we pass
player
dot
name
and here the tip tag is getting closed
like this
okay
so that's the message we are basically
printing it
and after that
we give this value
and say this message called
winner equal to
true
and after that
if you want to apply
remove
that function we haven't written
we'll be talking about a little later on
and just say return true early
[Music]
so your function is ready now
and later on we can just check the
condition if filler
winner
or you can say
check
if ty
and
return false
that's it
now in our continuation to this example
we're gonna develop another function
which
the name is called change board header
names so let's continue by defining the
new function called function change
change
board
header names
so this change board header names will
be the new function for us and here they
would like to check whether the user is
winner or not so here we say if
not
winner
then what
then in that case you have to say let
current player text
equal to
document
dot
query selector in this we will be
getting the details like dot
or
and here we gonna give the name called
player
and hyphen turn
player hyphen turn
now later on after this particular
variable we have to just check the
condition by saying if
current player
equal to x if the position is x sorry
let me try to put it in capital letter
here
x
then we will say
current player
dot
inner html equal to
now here we have to just use the same
option called backticks because i want
to go multilines
that's the benefit of this backtick and
here we say in our inner html span
class
equal to
name
hyphen hyphen
style
close this and here
we want to use
the statement
now this
value we want to write it with name
attributes so it is getting close and
here we are saying dollar
with this player
x
dot
name
and then
close the
span tag
and we say
you are
up
like this
and after that
we say div
class equal to
we just gonna create a class which later
on we can apply the css style on the top
of that u hyphen r
hyphen
winner
and here we say closing the div tag
so dip tag is closed
that's it and now after this line
what next we have this called else
condition
else
what else here we say
current layer
text
dot
inner html
inner html equal to
after this
we gonna write the span
class equal to here we say
name
hyphen hyphen same option we're gonna
use it
so in this condition so
winner conditions so let me try to copy
this thing rather than copying it again
and again
i'll just copy the whole text
expand class equal to name hyphen iphone
style player rather than saying x you
could use file
you are up you are
winner
okay so here it's getting closed
well after this what we need to do
create another function called resupport
function
reset
board
now in this function reset board we just
say console.log
a small message
resetting
resetting is added now afterwards we
will be using
the game board
now the same game board what we have
used it earlier
i'll be using the same conditions
on the top
if you remember
that was a game code for me so i'll be
using the same keyboard
they copy this
yeah
with the same condition
okay gameplay go to this
after that line we will say let
sell to add token
sell to add token
equal to
document
dot query selector all
here
in this i'll be using
another class called
letter
now
cell to add token
whichever we've used dot
for each
square
and within this square we would like to
use square
dot
text content
equal to
black
after that
square
dot
parent element
dot
class list
dot
remove
and here you would like to say board
okay underscore underscore
cell
winner so these classes we had to create
because these changes classes were just
using this but we haven't created we'll
be using it later on
so that was the point
now after that we are defining the turn
value
turn
equal to zero because we are resetting
it n
winner equal to false
after that winner equal to false we just
define another variable called define
let current player text
current player text equal to
document
dot
query selector all
yeah document query select all
so here
we're gonna use the name call board
define player hyphen hyphen turn
after that current player
player
text
current player text dot
inner html equal to
once again we have to use the condition
for
up
and winner point so let me try to copy
this
inner html equal to
okay and in this we have to say player x
dot name
okay just everything is same
no change at all
okay now
here after that we're gonna write one
more function call function
add
cell
click
listener that means when i will be
adding
or clicking something to my cell
what kind of event i would like to
listen
here
we are saying const
cells equal to
document
dot
query selector all
let's check
the condition board
[Music]
cell
and here once again we say sell stock
for each
dot
for each
and here we say cell
dot
add
event listener
which even i want to listen
click and the second parameter will be
handler
once called
make move
okay and this function which we have
created called add cell clicks listener
okay this i'll be calling it here
perfect
later on once it is done let's try to
add one more function called function
remove
cell
click
listener
remove cell click listener
now here we say
let
all
cells
equal to
document
dot
query selector all
pass
board
cell
and now we say
all sets
dot
for each
cell
and here we say cell dot
remove
event listener
which event
click
and second parameter will be
make
that's it so friends now here
most of our javascript code is written
now
so going forward we would like to use
css
and finally we'll be applying everything
into our html file
well after the javascript file is ready
towards my application now it's time to
go and create
our html file now sorry the css
so
inside my tic tac i have got app.js and
index.html ready now here i'm going to
create another file here called
app.css see you can basically put this
app.css in either folder like in static
folder but i have just kept it outside
now from this point onwards i would like
to start with my basic functionalities
okay what those are let's start with the
first feature called body
with my body
some basic settings i would like to do
like in background image background
color so i just start with
background color
background color i can just use it as a
white
okay
but i don't think so it's really needed
it so if you want you can have it
otherwise leave this background because
it's by default going to be white only
and now
next would be called height
height will be 800 pixels
next background position
background position i just say like
center next background repeat in case if
you do not want to repeat the image
background repeat
and here i say no repeat
next background size
they're using cover
okay so it resize the background image
to cover the entire container
okay so that's what the body part
now the next thing is we have to select
the
rest of the css classes so first select
div
dot relative
inside this data alternative is first
say call position
position we are saying absolute
next is top
from the top i'm just making 760 pixels
next right
right is saying 120 pixels
next
after this we are saying height
container
height
dot
container or sorry hide hyphen container
here in hyphen container we will display
display
colon
none
well after that we have to use the
header point
header
inside the cell we will say color
will be by default white but still we
just say color
and
white
next text line
we just say center
next margin
margin will be 50 pixels
next font family
font family i'm selecting called
permanent marker
permanent
permanent marker
okay next class we are talking about
call inter player that's called dot
enter
hyphen
players
and enter hyphen players are the same
color
will once again
we can use any other player but we can
just use white or any color you want or
you can just use
hash
okay
margin
margin we are giving it's called zero
auto
we width looking forward for 80
next texture line
center
position
relative
now
next we're going forward for input field
in this input field we just say border
border two pixels
solid
and black
next
outline
outline none
i do not want any outline to be there
next padding
i can take 4 pixels
8 pixels
4 pixels 8 pixels now margin
we are saying 0
0 10 pixels
okay and finally
for pixels
after smashing you say font size
18 pixels
okay so that is your input field
next we are talking about something
called input field focus
input
hyphen field
okay color
focus
now here
border
two pixel
solid
right
or any other color which you want to use
it
next
how you want your submit button to be so
i'm saying
dot
hyphen btn
border
2 pixels
solid
and black
adding
8 pixels
and again 8 pixels
font size
80 pixels
now with
250 pixels
followed by border radius
5 mixes
next your margin from top
let's take 10 pixels
after that background color
let's take
white
only okay
so this is the property
now going forward you can associate
with your submit button active and
submit button focus so we are saying dot
submit hyphen
btn
colon
active
and
two options we are taking
followed by condition outliner
outline
none
next border
we're talking about 2 pixels
solid
and the color
red
ok
so that's the one
and after that we like to use over
dot
submit hyphen button
colon
over
what you want
change the background color
to what
white
you can use white smoke
well
here we like to use
a
dot
board
here we'd like to use player
hyphen
these are the classes we were using in
our javascript we remember
and here we say color
color we are using once again
white or you can use this white smoke
whichever you want
so
well later on
text align
center margin
10 pixels
0
and 10 pixels
height
54 pixels
okay
so these are the properties initially we
have taken
okay so after this
turn let's go and start another classes
here i'm saying dot
name hyphen hyphen
style and here we are saying color
red
and then font size
22 pixels
well
now coming back to the another
properties now we're talking about a
next important called border container
called board container dot
board container here we define width
which is 40 pixels we are taking
or sorry 40 percent we can rather take
after that background colors
that we can say coded blue
okay
next margin
we're taking is zero
and
auto
after that font size
font size we are taking 0
next border
bottle we are taking two pixels
then solid
and then black
followed by
box shadow
you remember this worksheet is one of
the very very season
three popular property here we're
defining three pixels
three pixels
three pixels
zero pixels
and
rgb
we can talk about call black
okay
so my border color will be shading color
will be
black
after that we're offering this
board cell
dot
now in this board cell we are defining
width
now in this width we are using
calculation
ca lc and in this calculation we are
defining 100
okay divided by three
this calculation
after this
the next property will be display
display will be inline block
next font size
we're taking 40 pixels
well texture line
center border
we are taking
2 pixels
solid
and
black
adding 20 pixels
vertical align
top
next font family
this formula you can use permanent
permanent marker
okay
now next option
a part of this
we have a call
your board syllable
board
sell iphone
winner
i would say rather iphone
now
spelling wrong this has to be d
yeah for cell winner
let's make background color
red
okay
and
[Music]
later on just use
letter
now in this letter we just give the
color combination so color will be
white
next position
relative
top
fifty percent
next transform
translate y
to minus 50 percent
after that font family
we are making it once again permanent
marker
let me copy
okay
now
here next option will be called winner
container
here we're
giving winner
with dot
dot
winner hyphen
container
okay so for this winner container
what are the values we want to use it
that's you want to basically do it so
before there's been a container what i
would rather suggest is you can use dot
reset
texture line
center
margin
20 pixels up
that is for reset and now reset hidden
inside this reset heading we will set
display name
display
none
okay after this the replay
button let's yeah i'm going to talk
about replay button dot
replay hyphen
vta
and here with
we make it
to 25
okay
and followed by padding
10 pixels we take it from here
and 20 pixels
border
this bottle we are taking is called two
pixels
followed by solid
okay and black color
now later on
border radius
border radius we're taking 5 pixels
later on outline
i'm saying none
after this outline we say letter spacing
now this letter spacing would be again
zero
after that
text transform
text track form value we are talking
about
uppercase
next font size
font size
we are taking 16 pixels
then margin top
margin top would be 12 pixels
then word spacing
that you are taking three pixels
followed by background color
this you are taking white as usual
so this is for your replay button
okay
now in a similar line we can also have
call dot
replay iphone btn
colon hover
followed by dot
replay hyphen
active
now apply the common style outline
we are making it null
that color
we are making is called white
then background color
will be black
okay
and
when it comes to the congratulations
so we'll be using this
dot
okay
so this congratulations class will be
using font size
to what 24 pixels
and after this we are using this call
winner dot u
hyphen r dot
winner
in this winner we will be taking
font size
okay that's 18 pixels
after that height
we are taking little pixels again
then line height
line height we are taking 18 pixels
and then
margin two pixels
and then zero
okay
that's it so
last but not least we would like to use
this
dot
replay
hyphen btn
this i'm saying with 50
50
percent
so this is what my css file is all set i
know it was pretty lengthy but it is
required for this particular application
okay everyone so we are all ready with
our css also now it's time to go back to
our index.html file
and take care about the final finishing
touch
so we have this index.html file with us
and now
the css class which we were using it in
our application that is known is called
this
permanent marker this class is not by
default available so we have to include
this using this external api so here
where we have a call css with us
before that
we want
link
so within this link we want our
variable name called href
equal to now we have to give the proper
location by saying https
colon double forward slash fonts
dot google apis
okay dot com
slash css
question mark
family
equal to
permanent
plus
marker
okay so if you just copy this
into your browser
you will get to know
where exactly it is using
okay if i just copy and paste it so i
just need to say https before
yeah https
fonts
dot
google apis
dot com slash oh spelling wrong
css family equal to permanent marker
that is the main url from where i can
take this kind of font so here
css so that's what i was cross verifying
it
well it's there we have included our css
also but in which class we need to use
that is an important now
js i also want to include it so here
in my head tag only
i would like to include
script
src equal to
app.js
so here my script is actually loaded now
after that
if i just go back and check
the
final outcome of my code
which is index.html file
well it pretty much look like in basic
nothing else has started when we talk
about call start game
okay so it needs to start because there
is no css class are attached so i need
to attach those classes within my code
so here onwards we have to start with
offering those css classes so that at
least i can apply
those common behaviors to my application
okay like here we have a call
div
we haven't attached any class to this
after this body we have a part tip h1
class equal to header
tic tac toe then we were called div we
have a call
body
uh
under this we have a call another dev
tag so
just imagine how many type of classes
are available one we have called tip
class equal to header div class is
closed again we have a call one more div
tag so like that multiple css files are
there where we have to apply the new css
class
to make it happen so now we have to just
go back and change our html and to apply
our main class
so this is what my final html which
looks like the same you can see we have
added
all those type of css classes which we
had that is called interplay
player form player container label
placeholder
and player container and if you see all
different type of classes we have
attached this to
okay because
here only my css class will get applied
and the javascript will apply those kind
of dynamic css based on certain
conditions so these css classes are
already there added inside your html
page
our app css is ready
app.js is also ready now let's go back
and try to reveal how it looks like him
awesome so it looks like pretty nice tic
tac toe is a game it is expecting and it
says start game it says you must enter a
name for each field validation is
working
let me try to add
two names and say start game awesome so
now you can see it is saying a you are
up
now let me try to give the values
awesome now you can see
it's saying like hey you are a winner
great so guys congratulations on this
the first example of how the tic tac
door game is used so it is a classical
example of css
javascript and html together
so this time we are going to talk about
our next very interesting feature that
is called dealing with another example
that is called snake game so staying
keep is one of the very very powerful
example which i'm going to share with
you which will help you to understand
like how
we offer a very simplest way of
developing a mini project
okay that is something which is a snake
game let's see how the snake game is
important and how we're going to deal
with this
these are our previous examples which we
have seen which i will call a project
which we have created that is called
quiz application and now we're going to
start working with our new project
now here first of all i'm going to
create a new folder
that is called snake
again
and inside the system we need some new
folders
uh first folder i'm going to create it
inside this that is called images
and
within this snake games i'm going to
create few new files that is called
index
dot html
and here
i'm going to create a new file name
called app
dot
js
at the same time i'll be having some of
the css files if i need so i can say
app dot
css so total number of three files i
have it now
let me close down all the files
whichever i have opened it earlier
so
now that looks cleaner approach
so
this is a snake game for us from where
we need to start
and we have called index.html file and
here i will create
our basic html syntax
and
here i would like to include
our script tag
script
src equal to
app.js
that's it and now going forward we will
start developing
our next
implementation of
snaking
now inside my body tag i would like to
have some
basic property called speed
okay and later on i'll be taking the
input from the client so we are saying
[Music]
input
type equal to
so here we can justify the speed and we
can give id
equal to
gamespeed
and followed by value
equal to we can give the value called 5
initial value
and
min
equal to
1 that is the minimum value
and max equal to 9 that is the maximum
and minimum value we can offer beyond
that i won't allow the users to go
and step
that means the increment value that is
one
well that is the input type and now
another input we are taking input
type equal to
button
and
value
equal to
start
and then id equal to
game start
okay so we're giving these values
after that
i can give some
bricks
so two bricks we are giving it and start
working with the div diagonal
and in this div tag i'll be using the
canvas
it is a html5 feature
we use canvas
and i just give id equal to
game
area
there is a canvas
and
after this canvas
we will
that tip tag is closed here after the
div tag i can use another tab type
div
here i can say
class equal to
i may not have any class written but i
can say
class equal to related so later on if i
want to apply any css style i can
certainly apply
and after that i can offer the images
okay so i may not have any images right
now so i just leave this image blank
right now
okay and this is script src i'll load it
only
before my body tag had closed it's
always a good practice to keeping this
script tag on a bottom of the body tag
always designed for good practice
now this is almost ready for me let me
check
okay so i can see
values
now it will go maximum nine that is how
we have given and minimum is one
start is the button which not doing
anything but later on we can allow some
logic inside this
now we have to start working with our
main javascript tag
this is my amp.js and here onwards we
will use
some of the properties okay which i want
to initialize it so using var
game
start
equal to none
initialized
second game speed
equal to
next game area
equal to
null
game area context
equal to null
then
game area width
game area
width
equal to
zero that is in integer value
game area height
game area
equal to zero again
then solve it
solve it equal to zero
play score
equal to zero again
next snake
equal to null
next snake food
equal to null
next snake direction
equal to
null
snake speed or else i can say speed size
speed size
equal to
zero
next we have a timer
equal to
so these number of properties
we've initialized
okay
now after that we will be writing a
function by saying function
name is called initialize
okay and here in initialized
we would like to use some of the
properties first we are saying
game start equal to
document dot
get element by id
here i can give the value call
hash
game start
let me put it in double quotes
okay
start
now game speed
now these are all basically the values
are there game start game speed
these all values we have to take it
okay so we will be seeing these values
one by one
so let me set another one that is for
game speed
game speed equal to again
document dot
get eleven by id now we are passing
the game speed
game
game speed
now
here
once again i will take another point
game area
i say game
game area
here you have to give the value called
game area
okay so these values we have taken
now we'll be talking about called game
area context
game area context equal to
game area
dot
get context
okay
and in this game context we will be
using what type of context using 2d
okay because i want to have
the kind of 2d so
this is how the kind of environment we
want to set
next we talk about game area width
equal to just initialize to 400
next
game area height
equal to 600
now solve it
we are initializing with 20
next game area dot width
okay so game area
dot
width equal to
game area width
and then we define game area dot height
dot
equal to
game area right
so these are the values we are
initializing this
okay
now after that we have to start writing
the logic here i'm saying game start
game start
dot now we have to line
which event you would like to take so i
will say on
click
on
click
so when i basically click
what should happen so on click equal to
function
so what you want to write it here i am
saying this start
this dot disabled
equal to
true
so i want to disable these values
and after that we want to call
another function inside this
but which function let's do that so here
we are saying function
start game
start
okay
and
here in start game
we want to define the initial score see
the initial score for the player will be
certainly zero so we say
player
score
equal to zero
after that
direction in which direction you want
the snake to move so we are saying snake
direction equal to
right
in the right direction
then speed size
the value of sort the variable which you
have defines the speed size equal to
because
it will be accepting the value
from the text boxes or from the drop
down so it certainly will be string type
so we have to use power sent
[Music]
so we're using this option called power
sent and here we're using
game speed
dot
value
okay so we are using this value gain
speed dot value now here we would like
to calculate certain things
what those are first we are saying if
okay
what if condition
uh
see this function we are writing called
start game
because there are certain things which
you need to
make it
so like that you have to define it so
function initialize
we have started
okay and then after that we have written
on click within this
so this is what the on click we had and
there onwards we have to finish this
point
and after that we've started
start game and now we'll be writing the
logic for this so here we are saying if
we're using speed size
missing if
a speed size
greater than
9
in case if it is
the values hard-coded it
then we would like to write a logic here
and what this logic would be it says if
it is greater than 9 we say speed size
equal to 9
we basically initialize to what nine
here we say else elsif
speed size
is
zero
we say speed size
sorry
speed size
equal to 1
that means if it is less than 0 i will
be making it minimum to 1 if it is
greater than 9 nine i'll be making it to
nine maximum
and that's it
okay
so after this else if condition
is getting closed we are seeing speed
size equal to
one
so here we just say snake
snake equal to
array so that is my array for me and
after that we are saying snake
dot push
because it needs to move ahead and here
we'll be pushing it towards
by saying
x
position
0
and
then the y
and here the y value will be what cell
weight that means how far it can go so
it will go within the width of this
application
okay so that's how exactly we would like
to make it
okay so here we have a call cell width
which we have given here
after that what we have to do is
we have to define our own function
called
clear interval
and this clear interval perform any
logic whichever i would like to make it
okay so here after that snake dot push
value has been given
here i will be creating one more
function here that's known as call
create food okay so here we're saying
create
food
so create food will be the function for
me now you might be thinking where this
function is but this function will be
declared soon within your application
but here first we are seeing the
function called clear interval
clear interval
with the timer
[Music]
okay whatever the timer will be passing
it
and after that
this clearing treble will be saying
timer
equal to
set interval
with this we are saying create game area
create
now
here in our application whatever the
value we are giving it that we need to
basically implement
so
here we are giving this call create food
is a function we are calling after that
we are calling this clear interval
cleaner will be just like in a typical
function which is there after that we
are using this option called create game
area
so
[Music]
this will be available to me on which
the value will be taken that
okay and then we will be telling you
how you can call this function create
food and how to create it first well so
we are talking about a functionality
called create game interval so this
create game
timer is the one which we have to create
it by our own so this function which we
are passing it after the saying set
interval
this function is not it there so we have
to basically go back and create this
function within my application
fine so
what we will do is just particular one
we will try to comment it for a time
being
okay so here we have a call what create
interval
in this great interval we'll be
passing any parameters which we are
passionate about as a timer here and
here we are calling this call create
food
so here after that we'll be calling this
function called create food so let's go
and say
function create food
in this function create food let's go
and write a logic here
and what logic we want to write it in a
create food we say snake food
is network equal to
and here in our curly braces we use two
direction x and y
we say in x we say
math dot
route
and inside this we say
math
dot
random
after this math.random function we have
to just take this calculation
and check the another parameter called
game area with
game
area width
minus
cell width the one which you are passing
it and here after that we'll be
performing the calculation by saying
cell bit
okay so this is for our x coordinate
similarly we would like to use for my y
coordinate also
now
math dot round round dot number game
area
game area height
but
here rather than using width we'll be
using height
minus
solve it let me give some space
divided by cell width
okay
so that's where exactly it's got closed
okay
now
here
our applications is now ready by calling
the function called create4
like that we'll be going to create
another function called create game area
let me go and create all the functions
first so we are saying
function create game area
create
game
area this is another function for me
after this create game area there will
be another function i'm going to create
it
that is called control
function
control
okay after that we're going to write one
more function called function
right score
there's another function available for
us control we have a call right score
there's another function which you're
going to write it on here that is called
function
right score is done now we say create
square
create
square
with another function
and finally we'll have a call change
direction
function
change
change
direction
so that's it so these many functions we
wanted to create it
here in our system
well
we know very well that we have taken
this called create food grade food
function is already ready now now we're
going to talk about our next function
called create gain area and in this
great game area we are defining two
location bar
x direction and y interaction so we say
snake
x
equal to
snake the position we are taking is
called zero and we are saying dot x
for the x direction
we are saying var
snake
y
equal to
snake
position we are taking once again zero
and
dot okay so two directions we have taken
x direction and y direction
now here we are starting
game
area
context dot
fill style at the united variable it is
a property
fill style equal to which color you want
to fill this up
so i'm saying hash white color
okay and then we're using this game area
context again
dot fill react
fill react
now keep the position values i am saying
0 comma 0 comma
game
so we are basically filling the values
with color we want to use it called
stroke style let me take this game area
context again
dot
stock style
stroke style
equal to now we give the another color
here
by saying hash
okay and then the next option called
same gamery context dot stroke react
stroke
react and here we pass the values again
0
0
comma
game area width
cover
game
area
height
so we're passing those values like that
and now after this we have to write a
logic of the directions
now see that when you talk about snake
game it move left right and center
up and down so now in this case we have
to increment the situations accordingly
so we say if
the snake direction
if the snake direction
equal to
right
then we say snake
x
plus plus now
elsif
elsa
same
let's copy this
snake direction
left
then what should happen
here we say
snake
x
minus minus
okay so we're taking like that let me
copy this again
now here
here we're taking about left right we
set down
so in this case we say snake
y
plus plus
and in this case
if it is up
then we say
snake
y
minus minus
so these conditions we are taking it now
now here after this else if condition we
would like to take another if condition
now here in my if condition
we are
using some more lengthy statements
what's that we say
f snake x
f snakes x
-1
or
snake x
double equal to
game
area
width which we have taken
divided by
selved
okay or
we are taking this condition called
snake y
snake y double equal to
minus one
okay so we're giving this call minus one
or
snake y
let's take y equal to
gain area height
to serve it
or
here we will take the another condition
here
yeah we will take the another condition
here call
we will have another function called
control
which we have
created some time back and inside this
control
it will take some parameters so what
those parameters we can pass then we can
say
snake
x
comma
snape y
comma
third parameter will be
stick
so this could be my another function
okay
so here we are passing the conditions
just like that
okay now here
this is
available to use a parenthesis
and here
we're writing the situation for right
score
which is so far the function is only
created not
described more so we're writing the
right score the score will be written
here
and here we are saying clear interval
because the timer will be stopped
okay and using game start
dot
disabled
equal to
thoughts
and after that
return
that's it
so this is the logic for we have written
to this particular
example now we can use
another if more conditions here just to
check the behavior of my code if getting
your learning started is half the battle
what if you could do that for free
visit scale up by simply learn click on
the link in the description to know more
well here we have finished this
game start dot disabled equal to false
and we returned
now going forward after this return
we would like to have another condition
for the snake egg so we say if
snake x
if a snake x double equal to
snake food dot x
okay snake food vertex
ampersand
snake
y
double equal to
snake
food dot
y
then in this case i will say
var new head
bar
new head sorry
var
new head equal to here
x colon
snake x
snake x and y colon
snake
y
these options we are taking it
now
after that we are using this option
called player score
plus
equal to
speed size
and then we are calling
createfoot method again
and here after that we're using the else
condition
and in this as condition
we are saying var
new head
equal to
snake
dot or
okay and we are saying new head
dot x
equal to snake x
and new head
dot y equal to
snake
y
so these values are basically
associating with your heads and after
that we are saying snake
dot unshift
and shift
snake dot and shift and here we are
passing this option called new head
that's it and after that we'll be
starting with our for loop by saying
for
var equal to
ri
i equal to 0
then
i
is less than
snake dot
length
and
snake dot length
and once i
plus plus
okay later on we just use the option
called
create
square
and in discrete square we are passing
snake
snake position
i
dot
x
comma
same
snake
dot y
that's it
so it's getting closed here and after
that we are calling the same option
with this snake food let me copy this
again
and here rather than
using this we can say snake food dot x
and snake foot dot y
okay so now this values has been added
into my code now it will start working
with your control
control needs to take three parameters
x y and the array so we are passing this
option called
control and in this control we are
taking x
comma y
comma
array
three parameters we are taking it later
on we are using this option called for
var
i equal to zero
i
is less than
array total
length
and i
plus plus
and after that we'll be using this
option called if condition and here we
say
array
i
which value you're passing dot x
double equal to
x
ampersand term percent
here we say array
with a position called i
and in this we are saying dot y
and this position we are checking for
the y condition
for the y condition so it returns what
true
written
true the condition
okay that is for if condition else
return were
false
now that's it now we are talking about
this option name called write score
this right score we have to use the game
area context
game
area context dot
font
equal to
here we'll be passing this situation
using 50 pixels
50 pixels and then
sends
iphone
service
after that we're using call game media
context again let me copy this
take it again call game area context dot
fill style equal to here i'll be using
another color now
we say hash
okay
now after that we are saying once again
the game area context dot
fill
text
here we are saying
score
colon
and here we say
plus
player score whatever it is
with game area width
game area width
slash
2
minus
100
and then
again
in area with
slash
so this is where exactly the right score
where the data will be actually written
okay next we'll be having this option
called create square at this great
square it takes two parameters one we're
talking about call x
second is taking y
and now here we're using this game area
context
same
dot
fill style
equal to let me give the color
after this we're using call same gary
and text
game area text dot
fill react
here we are saying x
multiplied by
cell width comma y
multiply by
cell width
comma
cell width comma
circuit this is what
my great square is now we are left with
only one option that is known for change
direction
it's time to figure out this last
function called change direction
which takes one parameter called e
typically we talk about for
parameters
now here we are passing this option
called var keys
equal to e
dot
and
later on we want to say if
keys
equal to
40
okay
ampersand
is sneak direction
equal to
up
okay so here we say
snake direction
equal to
down so we are changing the directions
here
okay now let me try to copy this
[Music]
and here we use elsif
[Music]
four times
okay
so here we talk this
30 40 and here we say 39
and followed by 38
followed by 27
39 38 27
and here we say up
let's change to what
left
down
right
here we say
right
up
left
the three options we have changed and
last but not least here
i will just use
window dot
on key down
equal to
change directions
and
window
dot
on load
okay equal to
initialize that's how exactly we want to
use now and this function what we have
defined in initialize
okay
so in this initialize
we are having this game start dot on
clicking and all so you have a call
start game now this start game will be
calling it here
okay so in start
we were called snake we have called
snake dot push
and after that we are calling this
function called what
create food
clear interval and here we say
timer equal to
here set clear interval and here
change
game area
slash
speed
size
let's say you want to use it
okay everyone so our code is almost
ready so we have this complete
javascript code ready with me
now it's time to basically use within my
html
just to check how it may behave
so in my html page i have written this
normal speed
number
game speed value
button start we will call game start
after that we have a call canvas where
we can id equal to call game area
dev classic to relative
and
that's it and here we have a call script
sr is equal to app.js
so that's it what we have written now
finally we would like to see how it may
look if i try to use in my browser let
me try to refresh
okay
i really do not see any changes in my
code
okay
despite i'm having this because
the css content is actually missing
okay because then only my code really
look
better
because if there is no css
it won't really make
good towards my application
okay and i also want to have certain
images but those images we will take it
later on
let me go back and try to bring css into
this picture now
so first of all
have this
index.html file with me and here i want
to use css so inside my head tag
we want to use
link
real
equal to
style sheet
okay href
equal to
app
dot
css
okay
now
here
in my css we want to offer certain
details
what those details i want to start
working with i will start with my body
part
body
so we want to offer
the font family
so
font family may be little bit later on i
can use it first i want to use margin
margin 20 pixels
auto
later text
align
center
next font size
font size 150 pixels
also 150
and here we want to say background
background image
since i do not have any image so i will
just leave it as a blank
okay so just otherwise you have to say
url
and insert this url
it gives some values but i leave it as a
blank because i do not have any image i
will say background color
in this background color i can just use
white
after that height
i can just say 800 pixels
after that
background position
background position i want to use center
then background repeat
background repeat i want no repeat
then background size
okay let's see if there's an effect in
my
okay i see it's now
in the middle
better
now
inputs canvas we have to basically take
that here we just talk about call input
okay in this input i say font size
font size may be optional i can
make it
but let me just say font size 100
percent
then text align
center
then padding
i want to say 5 pixels
and
7 pixels
okay looks better now
well here after that i can use canvas
in this canvas
i want to see the background color
i just say white
after that border radius
border release i can say 20 pixels
then
shadow if i want to use it
so i just say box shadow
box shadow i can say 3 pixels
five pixels
and six pixels
and the color is
black
let's check
awesome
so i can see here
uh
the
logic is there so shadow you can easily
see how it has been using
and
that's it and this div
i can say
div
dot
relative
position
absolute
top
here i'm saying using 760 pixels
left
120 pixels
that's it
so this is where exactly
i program now when i say start
okay so there may be some error here
let's say cannot set a property of call
on click
none
so this we can just check this into this
gamestop.onclick
let's check
anyways
we just try to fix that issue in a
while
but anyways we have our created css and
now going forward we'll be implementing
the rest of the logic within my code
okay everyone so we have changed some
names here because there was some value
was mismatched so we have basically
changed those values
with your properties and now when i try
to relaunch my application
by uh
this
index.html file
so now in my index.html file when i try
to add
so
it's just as usual same let me say start
and here you can see game start when i
go up you see like it's starting right
now
okay isn't this an amazing game right
now friends
okay that is the same game what you used
to play it earlier
okay you can just change the direction
go up and you can see the score line is
being placed here
that's it so this is where exactly the
look and feel of your game has been
taken
and you can just increase the speed
suppose if we just put a value call what
zero by default set
whatever value you want to take it with
a start now you can see
based on that the speed can be justified
and the example can be developed
okay you can see the start button is
disabled because right now the user is
still going on unless the user game is
finished this one is not going to work
right
so like that you can see and
automatically this will be positioned
this is what's called food that is how
we have used in my example
called app.js you can see we are using
this example name called food
create food so in create food of the
specific interval time this would be
automatically created and the snake will
eat and increase the size of the code
okay that's it and now the css has been
given if you want to add certain image
certainly you can add it otherwise this
is the first game which we can see how
it is running and giving you the better
example choose from over 300 in-demand
skills and get access to 1 000 plus
hours of video content for free visit
scale up by simply learn click on the
link in the description to know more
let's get started with the javascript
interview questions
so let's get started with the beginner
javascript questions we have multiple
levels available here we start with the
beginner level first
so the first question is always like
what do you understand about javascript
so we know it very well the javascript
is a very very popular scripting
language it is basically designed for
client-side scripting
and server-side scripting development
why server-side because nowadays
javascript is also used in a back-end
using node.js so that's why it is also
called for server-side development so
the question is like
uh javascript is
actually also helps the developers to
develop some more responsive html pages
okay which can be well understood and
executed by the web browser
okay which having the support
capabilities for object-oriented
programming skills
now
the next question is like what is the
difference between javascript and java
see the reason is because the javascript
initials are java so everybody think
like okay there is some relationship
with the java so actually the thing is
like there is no relationship with java
i would say javascript
is object based language
whether java is object oriented language
lot of syntax
and some standards are matching with
java that's why exactly it is saying it
is javascript
otherwise there is nothing like that
but another difference if i talk about
javascript is mainly designed to run
with the browsers where the java is
designed especially for the virtual
machine and operating system
now another thing is like javascript
does not need a compilation because it
is directly used interpreter but when
you talk about called java it requires a
compiler as well as the interpreter both
now what type of various data types are
supported so all standard
data type second byte short int long
float double character boolean
these all different type of data types
are supported in
javascript also just like in traditional
programming languages
okay
now
what are the features of javascript so
the first feature which you always
remember it's it is a lightweight
programming language it is being
interpreted by
the browsers rather than compile
it is a cross-platform that means it can
work across multiple browsers so it is
not specific to the browsers
so that we need to understand next it is
an open source hence you do not need to
pay for any licensing fees it comes free
with all different type of browsers
it is an object oriented but i would not
say it is a pure object oriented i would
rather say it is an object object-based
language
next it can gel well
with multiple front-end as well as the
back-end technologies because most of
the languages which are coming up in a
market they have a support available to
get integrated with the javascript and
due to that javascript is very very
popular
so it is also used especially for the
development like a network-based
application
so in case if you want to have some kind
of network-centric application here the
javascript really suits very very well
okay
next question what are the advantages of
javascript so the first
advantage which we are talking about
like javascript basically have a very
very nice interactive language it is a
event-based
okay functional programming language i
would say so it is a quick feedback
because it loads very very fast in your
existing web pages
it is
giving you the support of developing a
very very rich
user interface because of that your
application look consistent across
multiple type of browsers
another is like we have a call variety
of javascript based frameworks are
available like you can talk about
angular you talk about react you talk
about vue they're all basically
different type of javascript based
frameworks that helps the developer to
enhance their skills
with writing less amount of codes
so how you create a script or how you
create an object in javascript it is
very simple the curly braces
curly braces is basically designed to
give you the feel of this is a typical
object there are variety of ways are
there to create an object in javascript
which we're gonna see
in our next vpt
okay
now here we see about the next set of
questions which are there with us
like how to create an array in
javascript so creating an arrays
in javascript is very very easy
now you can see the square brackets
okay they are the way to basically
create an
array in the javascript so just a square
brackets are a very very simpler way so
called laterals to create
the array objects
in javascript actually you should know
that array is also object which is a
predefined object comes with your
javascript
so called implicit objects
now what are the built-in methods
available in javascript so you remember
about these methods comes from those
built-in objects comes with your
javascript as we have mentioned in our
last slides
like math
boolean
string
okay
date they're all basically predefined
objects are available under those
objects these methods are actually
available like date if you can see it
will display the current date and time
concat to concat two different type of
string push some
adding some new records into your array
pop to remove
around to do the round
length to calculate the length of the
string so these are all some well-known
methods or frequently used methods
available in javascript
now what different type of scopes
available in javascript for the
variables now
so
scopes are basically designed to give
you the visibility
within your program
okay so different type of scopes are
available when it's called a global
scope so global scope is having the
availability within a file
anywhere else you can access this
particular code or particular variable
that is called global scope and local
scopes are those scopes which are
accessible within a function
and hence cannot be accessed by any
other function or outside of this
function so two standard type of scopes
which are available here
now what is this keyword in javascript
this means to refer the current object
okay so whenever you see that this
keyword it is designed to refer the
current object in
javascript so we typically define that
this keyword to assign the value to my
current object properties
usually this is the place where that
this keyword is mostly used
now what are the conventions of
giving the names to the variables
okay so some standard naming convention
which we should always follow
but few things as you remember there are
certain reserve keywords
are there in javascript which you cannot
offer
while giving the names to your variables
or to your functions
like if i can say var
let const and many more which are there
available which you cannot assign to
your any existing variable
provided or functions
under your javascript
now
here they are trying to say
variable names cannot begin with any
numeric value like you cannot give
var with abc so not abc i would say
rather one two three or something like
that so they must be a combination of
i would say integer as well as a
character
okay so
they must only begin with letter or
underscore characters it is the same
like as we have it in java also
now
naming conventions are very very
important
javascript is a case sensitive hence
the small a and capital a have two
different meanings for the javascript so
that part needs to be well taken care of
now what is the callback in javascript
so you need to understand the callback
in javascript is a kind of function
which you are passing as an parameter to
the other function to execute
okay so callbacks are mainly designed
to
tell your application that
they need to wait rather than continue
to execute
so callbacks
will help you to behave
asynchronously and that's what exactly
this most
valuable feature of javascript
so as i discussed already so it is where
the function needs to be passed to get
executed
so how do you debug a javascript code so
to debug your javascript code in any
browser you can just press the f12
no matter which browser you have it
either chrome
or firefox or anyone you can just press
the f12 key and there
you can get this option called debugger
where you can just go and perform all
the necessary debugging related stuff
right over there
or
so many other editors like in sublime
text visual studio code
atom
they're all offering you the built-in
support to debug your javascript code
now what is the difference between a
function declaration and function
expression so this is a very very simple
difference
so when you say
function abc here
okay so you declare as a separate
statement within the same javascript
code
okay in another example what you do you
define a function within a variable name
called a
which you can create to construct some
another object for this
that's the only difference between these
two
so
this function
can be called before the function is
defined
and this will be created where the
function is pointing
and reaching it
okay so it can be used only after that
so that's what we have discussed it now
going forward
this offers the better code readability
and better code organization and that
the other part is basically used to
create a conditional or a declaration
functions
so what are the ways of adding the
javascript code in an html file so they
are
i would say
two ways are available one
either you can declare it in a separate
file you can add it or second you can
write a embedded javascript code where
you can just write a javascript code
either in your head tag or body tag but
there there'll be one difference like if
you're writing it as an embedded
javascript you cannot use it
for the different html file where the
internal javascript file will be limited
to that html however external javascript
will be more useful when you want to
reuse it again and again
so these were some
standard
basic javascript questions for us so
let's go ahead and talk about something
which is related to your intermediate
questions in javascript
now so what do you understand about the
cookies see the cookies are basically a
kind of a small text file okay which is
kept in your browser
and contains the information
about your client
activities okay so whenever the client
is accessing your websites
these websites
can track your activities through this
particular cookies
okay so this just basically record your
general
behaviors like what you're doing with
your website so that accordingly they
can give you
the better recommendations
now how you're gonna create a cookie in
your javascript so creating a cookie
cookie is one of the property available
under your document object so that you
can create it using document.cookie
and give a key so
your all cookie
stands with your key and value pair so
you have a key you have a value pair
so how you gonna read the cookie
so cookie you can read with the help of
the same property called document.cookie
and here you can just use this statement
like what key and value pair so whatever
the keys you have defined
similar q will be reading it to give the
value of whatever
option you want to read it
now how you gonna delete the cookie
so
cookie can be deleted it very easily by
calling this delete cookie function
where you can just tell about
the time and duration when you want the
cookie to be get deleted
so when you set the expiry time so
cookies are deleted
after specific period of time that will
be treated as a good programming
practice
so what is the difference between a
letter and var keyword see there's a new
feature which is there added called let
keyword which is known as call
block level scope the blockable scope
means
your variable whichever you're defining
under
any block level statement will be
limited to that particular block like if
you're defining it any opening block and
closing block
so beyond that you cannot see that
suppose if you're defining it under if
block
or any block so these
type of variables
are no longer accessible outside where
the var keyword will be typically
treated as a global variable and hence
it can be accessed
anywhere so what is the closure in
javascript so closure is basically going
to give you
a better way of
providing the consistent way of
developing a javascript code for the
developer so closures are basically
created whenever a variable that is
defined outside of this current scope
can be accessed within the current scope
okay that means which is
a variable which is defined outside of
this scope even using the scope of this
particular closure it can be accessed
inside too
now
what are the arrow functions in
javascript
friends arrow function in javascript is
very very popular now they're just gonna
give you a kind of alternative way of
defining the function keyword
these are just a shortcut way of
defining the function in
javascript these are simple handy
functions i would say
so what are the difference ways of html
can be accessed in javascript course so
there are multiple ways are there so you
can access using document.getelement by
class name you can access git element by
id you can get access document get
element by tag name and you can say
document.queryselector
so these are the multiple options are
there
through which you can access the element
within your html tags
what are the ways of defining a variable
so var keyword as we discussed
you can define a variable
you can also define the variable using
const
so if you define any variable using
const so these variables will get
constantly declared and it cannot be
changed
once you define the value so any value
or any variable which is defined using
const
it cannot be changed in later stretches
what are imports and export in
javascript
so to make your javascript modular
so there's an option available of
importing and exporting it
so what exactly the difference
difference is very simple like you are
writing the set of javascript code and
if you want to get it accessed
outside in another javascript file so
how the two javascript files can
communicate with each other that is
where exactly the important export code
comes to make your javascript highly
reused and more modular
now
these are the quick example as you can
see now
two different files are there so if you
want to make your particular variable
or function accessed outside you always
use export keyword with them
and if you want to access them out you
can just use an import keyword
as you can see it is defined there
so
another file can easily access your
the content of the previous files to
make your code even more modular and
useful
so what is the difference between a
document and window in javascript see
document is the one which is a part of
your document part which user can
actually see that
okay so the document object is the
object which falls under the category of
window window is a top level object so
in javascript we have an option
available name called
bom that is called browser object model
in which the top level object which is
there that is called window and under
this we have a called document so
whatever you see
under your browser it is a part of your
document
so what are the some
javascript frameworks
and their uses see javascript frameworks
are mainly useful to make your
application more organized
with less code
and without getting into into the detail
okay so having this particular framework
will give you the opportunity so that
developer can
use the javascript in much more better
way
to write a complex code in more
simplified manner
this is where exactly
your frameworks are designed for so
there are some very prominent and useful
frameworks like in react angular
vue.js and lot many other names are
there in market which will be using the
javascript as a core and take the entire
javascript development to the next level
so the next question is what is the
difference between
a
undefined and undeclared in javascript
see it is very simple
undefined means the variable which is
undefined you're declaring a variable
okay and which you haven't defined okay
that means the variable has been
declared but the value has not yet
assigned that is called undefined
undeclared means the variable which
you're trying to access that itself is
not available it doesn't even exist
so what is the difference between
undefined and null in javascript see
undefine as i already told you it means
the variable has been declared but it is
not assigned with any value null is
actually the assignment value that
we can assign to any variable
which
contained no values as an alternative i
would say so what is the difference
between session storage and local
storage see it is very simple html5 has
offered these features to you
so the session storage and local storage
both offers you the
data which can be stored in a browser
but session storage is short-lived
the moment your page is deleted or
closed the session data is immediately
get deleted
where the local storage data is remain
for the longer period of time and the
data doesn't get deleted after the
browser history is over
okay so i would say the local storage
time span is far bigger compared to the
session storage
okay everyone so we'll have some
advanced javascript questions now
we've already seen the beginner level as
well as the intermediate level questions
now it's time to discuss about some
advanced double questions too like
the first questions like comes like how
do you empty an array in javascript so
it is very simple
if you want to assign
so there are a few ways of there
number one
by assigning the array length to what to
the zero
so automatically turns to empty second
is what by assigning the completely
empty array
okay the third will be by popping up all
the elements of the array
so multiple options are there and the
last which you talk about by using the
splice function so these are the four
important aspects are there
which you can treat how to
empty your
javascript
array in a very very simplified manner
now what is the difference between even
capturing and even bubbling see this is
one of the very very common question we
talk about even capturing even capturing
is actually the kind of process
where you just try to
capture the event of
most outer most element and then
propagating it to the innermost element
so even capturing is what like you're
talking about picking up the element
or picking up the even from the
outermost like you talk about call
nested div tags so you pick up the
particular you know even from the most
outer most div tag and you're just
passing it to the innermost then it's
called capturing the bubbling is the
process
okay which starts with the innermost and
goes to the outermost elements it's just
an opposite direction that is called
event bubbling
so the question is one of the very very
popular like what is the strict mode in
javascript see the strict mode of
javascript is introduced
to give the more better error handling
capacity of the javascript so whenever
we talk about call strict mode so all
variables have to be declared explicitly
so you cannot leave it like that and it
cannot be assigned to the read-only
properties
so we can enable the strict mode only by
adding the user strict mode on the top
of the javascript file
now
what about
and how we would be able to get the
following output of the below javascript
code so we have a call var equal to 10
and we have written one function in the
if block
and after that we're just capturing the
value
of a and then you are printing the value
in a console.log
so what would be the output for that see
it'll be
a call then undefined
once again it'll be kind of what it'll
be
undefined how come it would be look it
is very simple
first thing
okay
in your application
you are basically saying the if
condition statement in the code will
evaluate the eval function
as you know very well what exactly the
evaluation is later on the eval
function
okay
will take the function and return the
function abc whatever the function it is
available
and then inside the if statement it
execute the abc and return the undefined
because as you know it variable the if
statement code executed runtime was the
statement inside this if condition is
being evaluated so that's where exactly
it is
next can you write a javascript code for
adding the new element in a dynamic
manner yes exactly you can write it down
so you have this very common function
available name called
document.createelement
like people say like i want to add the
new text boxes when i click on the
button
so
i can write it very well so either it
will be a text box or it could be the
new element you want to add it so
document.createelement
is one very very common
i would say the function and later on
you can use the typical dom
functions like i can talk about create
next node or append child so using this
combination you can easily do so
next what is the difference between call
and apply very common question so the
call method
whatever the method you have it in a
call
these
method arguments are provided
individually okay along with
this value but in apply what happens
arguments are provided in the form of
array
along with this value that is the only
difference between call and apply
so what would be the output of the below
javascript code as you can see right now
we've written a one object name called
student provided one property called
college with abc after reducing object
dot create passing this is student as an
object itself and after that you're
saying delete student1 dot collagen
console.log
student.com so
what would be the value for this
so it is very simple it is very simple
example of object orientation so the
output will be what abc as we are
accessing the property of
student object so certainly the value
will be what
abc for sure now
what would be the output for below
javascript code as you can see now we
have written a one
function
for and it is written 11 so we are
saying type of
so this will certainly refer to what to
the error
reason is why because a function
definition can have only single
reference variable
as its name that's why exactly it will
be throwing what an error to you
how do you remove the duplicate value
from the javascript array it is very
simple we have called filter function so
the filter method i can basically call
it and three arguments it may be
expecting it the name of the array the
current element and the index of the
current element
so that it can remove all the duplicate
elements from there so how do you remove
the duplicate elements
from javascript array so the same way i
told you like
first it takes three parameters
so using the filter method and by using
the for loop so the empty array is used
for sorting all the repeating elements
so like that you can simply make it more
easy
so how can you draw a simple javascript
dom so you can say it is a very simple
javascript dom elements which are there
where you can have the document and then
the html
and followed by all child elements like
a head tag body tag body may contain
further child elements like an anchor
tag
so these are all basically known caller
presentation elements through which this
complete html hierarchy will contain
inside this
now with that we have come to an end of
the javascript tutorial and also to the
software development week by simply
learn we hope all the sessions were
informative and interesting
if you have missed out on any of our
sessions then please feel free to check
out our official youtube channel the
link to which is in the description box
below if you have any queries regarding
any of the topics covered in the session
or the previous sessions then please
feel free to write us down in the
comment section below and our team of
experts will be happy to resolve all
your queries until next time thanks for
watching and don't forget to subscribe
to stay tuned for more from simply learn
you